session governor penny asked
do we have any preliminary matters we
have some exhibits oh that would be
fantastic that'll make jamie's day
all right we're ready for the jury then
okay
all right
good morning ladies and gentlemen have a
seat all right your next witness
your honor amber calls dr richard moore
all right dr moore
do you suddenly swear or testify
truthfully in this case
all right yes sir good morning dr moore
good morning can you please tell the
jury your full name uh richard salter
moore jr
where do you work
emerge ortho in wilmington north
carolina
and what is your position there
i'm a shareholder physician orthopedic
surgeon uh practicing hand up extremely
microvascular surgery
for how many years have you been an
orthopedic surgeon
so i completed my fellowship in 1997.
um
so for 25 years
and i believe that you you mentioned
this but tell the jury
what
area of orthopedic surgery in which you
specialize so so i'm a uh orthopedic
surgeon i finished medical school went
to a five year orthopedic surgery
residency at the completion of my
residency i wanted to specialize in hand
surgery so
i did an additional year of training
specifically in hand and upper extremity
surgery
before starting practice in my first
year as a as an attending
where are you currently licensed
north carolina
for how long have you been licensed
since 1990
one or six
i think it was 1996 when i was licensed
in north carolina
beginning with your undergraduate
studies dr moore could you please tell
the jury
a bit about your educational background
i know you mentioned a little bit of it
just now so i uh attended university of
north carolina chapel hill uh graduated
in 1987 with a bs in biology i went on
to medical school at unc and i graduated
in 1991.
i then went to the hospital the
university of pennsylvania in
philadelphia
did a five-year orthopedic surgery
residency there and in 1996 i went to
duke university medical center and did a
year fellowship and hand upper extremity
microvascular surgery
and on completion of my fellowship i was
invited to join the faculty
and my role was was
hand and trauma and so i went to los
angeles for about six months for a
preceptorship in pelvic trauma
and then went back to duke and uh
practiced
as a director of the orthopedic trauma
service and a member of the hand upper
extremity and micro vascular
reconstruction team until
2000 when i relocated in north carolina
to wilmington
and you maintained an active clinical
practice since
2000 and before that when you were due
correct
yes
just very briefly can you tell the jury
what is a residency
uh residency is
largely an apprenticeship so when when
you finish medical school you have a md
medical degree but you really
can't practice medicine
and you take a tract of internal
medicine or pediatrics or ob gyn or
orthopedics and then
it's a graduated training program
anywhere from three to five or six years
and what's a fellowship
and a fellowship is a year beyond
training when i completed my residency
had i chose to i could have practiced as
a general orthopedic surgeon
but i wanted to specialize and and
therefore that required an additional
year training
and i believe you mentioned this but
your sub specialization was in the hand
is that right that's correct why did you
choose to specialize in the hand
patient population
the types of problems we treat
the anatomy is really the biggest reason
i chose it
i mean for lack of a better term it's
really pretty beautiful anatomy
and let's talk about that anatomy
there's there's bones in the hand right
correct and then there's tissue and
blood vessels right objection leading
overruled
i'm sorry you can go ahead and answer
that yep that's correct and what what is
the surgery um
called where you operate on tissues and
blood vessels in the hand
uh
well
that that would be hand surgery i mean
there are different components of it
there's there's trauma where we do
repairs of tendons or blood vessels
there's a microvascular element where we
repair injured nerves um
in in my practice at duke i was on the
replant team and so we would we would do
replantations when digits were cut off
we would uh we would try to reattach the
bones and tendons and nerves and vessels
to
to
reattach the digits
and hopefully i'm survive
and have you performed surgeries of that
nature yes
when you perform surgeries of that
nature what assessment do you make of
the cause of those injuries
so so cause is a is a big element it's a
it's a uh it's an uh an important um
element to appreciate because it can
impact management in a lot of those
settings you know there's a there's a
difference between a
laceration caused by a razor blade
and a laceration called by say a
serrated knife there's a larger zone of
injury so what we anticipate having to
manage is
is based on
on uh
how the injury was created
there's also other elements
contamination you know farm farm yard
injuries are totally different than
clean injuries and catching injuries
with raw chicken are totally different
than than
some other other settings and so it does
play a large role in in management
after your fellowship at duke university
i believe you mentioned you had another
role at duke for a few years is that
right can you tell the jury about that
so i did my fellowship and i joined the
faculty as an assistant professor and uh
so i was in charge of teaching residents
and fellows i was the director of the
oregon trauma service
and i
was on the hand
call team
in addition
have you had
academic appointments at any
universities other than duke
i have a
adjunct
assistant professor
[Music]
appointment at the university of north
carolina at chapel hill which is
has affiliated training programs in the
center where i practice now
have you held any leadership positions
in your field
um
i've been the uh
an officer and the past president of the
north carolina society surge of the hand
the duke hand club or society now
um uh
i mean a member of the american society
surgery the hand of the orthopedic
trauma association of the american
academy of orthopedic surgery and of the
american orthopedic association aoa
are the majority of your surgeries hand
surgeries yes
how many hand surgeries
ballpark would you say you've performed
in your career
over 25 years
thousands
have you seen finger injuries
similar to the ones sustained by mr
death in australia yes
and have you evaluated injuries like
that yes have you treated injuries like
that
yes have you operated on fingers that
looked like that
yes
how many times
ballpark
hundreds if not
if not more
what does it mean to be board certified
in your field so uh board certification
is a process that um
that you pursue after you complete
training so at the time there have been
some changes but at the time that i
finished my training
after residency we took a written
examination and if you pass the written
examination you had to practice for two
years
at the end of that two years you
submitted a list of cases over six
months to the board and they picked
12 cases and then you gathered up 10 and
went to chicago and
and had an oral examination based on
those cases
and if you passed the world examination
you were board certified
and your board certification is
in what
orthopedic surgery d what is a
certificate of added qualification
so in the in
in the event that you elect to
to do a fellowship and subspecialize
hand surgery is one of the
specialties that
you can
apply for a certificate of added
qualification and so
once i was board certified i practiced
for an additional year or two had to
resubmit a list of cases and take a
written examination to become certified
in hand surgery
do you teach other surgeons how to do
hand surgery uh occasionally on occasion
yes
when was the last time you did so
uh
day before yesterday
tell the jury about that i was uh over
the weekend i went to
miami to
serve as faculty for a course bioskills
course we call it on shoulder and wrist
surgery and
surgeons come in and we have case
presentations and panels and then
they had a cadaver lab and we were able
to
allow them to perform the surgery in
cadavers to become familiar with the
equipment
have you published in your field
i have
in peer reviewed literature yes
your honor at this time um
we'd like to offer dr moore as an expert
in the field of orthopedic surgery and
specifically hand surgery and injuries
to the hand all right any objection no
objection so moved yes sir
dr moore
now we we get to talk about this case
at our request
what have you reviewed just
general categories of information have
you reviewed at our request in this case
so uh
so a tremendous amount of material um
i reviewed the video deposition and and
trial testimony of mr depp regarding the
injury
the medical records from australia the
photographs of the injury from australia
and los angeles
texts and emails the deposition of dr
kipper
and i'm sure there's more
and when you review the deposition of mr
depp was that just in paper form it was
a video deposition
and so what did you review of that
deposition the section where he
describes the injury
and did you see a video of him
describing it i did and you you watched
the testimony from this trial of him
describing it yes
and you mentioned that you reviewed some
texts as well what are those
uh
there were there were more there were
communications amongst um
mr depp and his
physician and and and others
and and what
did you specifically review in those
texts relating to the finger injury well
with relation to the finger there was a
there was a text where he had stated he
cut his finger off
now dr moore i'm going to ask you some
questions about this case regarding the
opinions that you formed
relating to mr depp's finger injury
when i ask you those questions do you
agree to answer my questions to a
reasonable degree of medical probability
yes and do you agree to advise the jury
and the court
if you are not answering any of them to
a reasonable degree of medical
probability yes
dr moore based on your analysis did mr
depp's finger injury happen as a result
of a vodka bottle being thrown at him
objection leading
overall
i'm sorry
no
and what is the basis for that opinion
well the
medical data is inconclusive
it's
not consistent with what we see in the
in the described injury pattern or in
the uh the clinical photographs
and there are there are several elements
there's there's uh you know the
description was of the hand being flat
on a bar and the and the bottle crushing
the finger from the top
but
looking at the images there's really no
no significant injury to the dorsum of
the finger and to create the type of
injury with that with that
type of a crush injury we would
anticipate both injury to the fingernail
and other parts of the finger
can i can i stop you there and just just
break down a few things
you said the hand
resting flat on the bar
can you show the jury what direction
the hand was resting based on the
documents you've reviewed i think that
the demonstration was was with the hand
flat
like this
um
across and maybe even curled over the
edge of the of the bar like this which
side was facing upward which side of the
hip back of the hand or that we call the
dorsal surface of the hand was up doctor
if you could get closer to the
microphone oh just sorry thank you thank
you your honor
so you referred to the back of the hand
as the dorsal side of the hand is that's
correct sort of like a dorsal fin on a
shark
correct there
and
what is the other side of the hand
called the palmer surface palmer okay
so what direction was mr depp's hand
resting on the bar so the dorsal side
was up
which with the descriptive
mechanism of injury or the injury the
bottle would have struck the top of the
finger at the fingernail
and you also mentioned a term that i'd
like you to explain to the jury crush
injury please
so so the with review of of the images
and the x-rays i mean this this was a
crush injury
that's the that would generate the
findings clinically on x-ray that we saw
um
the fracture is is a um we call it
comminuted and the and the tip of the
finger is in multiple splinters so there
are multiple fragments and typically you
see that with a with a crush type injury
so a common neuted fracture is one where
there's multiple fragments of bone
that's correct
and
what was the basis other than
what you've read and heard but from the
from the pictures what was the basis
of your opinion that the the
hand was resting palmer side down
well that was that was the way the the
injury was described
and demonstrated in the videos and so
um in that position where the bottle to
strike the finger the way it was
described it would have it would have
struck on the nail
um and and
and the nail was really
not injured and and so that's not
consistent with with that
pattern of injury
michelle could i get you to pull up
exhibit
dx369 page 26
your honor this is admitted ask for
permission to publish
yes sir
thank you your honor
dr moore is this
one of the images that you reviewed
yes what tell us in relation to your
expert opinion on the cause of mr depp's
injury tell us what you see in this
picture please
so so this is a um
it looks like an avulsion type injury
where tissue's actually pulled or
pinched away
i think what's important in this picture
is that the tissue loss is
on the palmer aspect from underneath the
finger rather than
then all
transversely in the finger which you
would anticipate if the if the bottle
struck the finger you would expect more
of this this level of injury rather than
isolated to the palmer aspect
and what do you notice about the
condition of the fingernail in this
picture so so from this image the
fingernail appears to be intact um you
you can't necessarily see the entire
nail but
um there are other images that have a
better uh
profile of that
um and and the nail is not elevated it's
not there's no um sub-uncle hematoma
beneath it or there's no bruise
underneath anyone that's ever stuck
their finger in a drawer or caught it in
a car door or hit with a hammer knows
that almost immediately there's
typically um bleeding underneath the
nail which creates this hematoma
so
not being a doctor i'm going to try to
to
summarize what you just said are you
saying that in an injury like this
if
something had come from the top that
there would be an immediate impact to
the fingernail bed that's correct
michelle could you please pull up
plaintiff's exhibit 144 your honor this
has been admitted as well
all right
thank you
dr moore i believe you mentioned just a
few minutes ago that there were other
pictures that showed
a more of the nail
is this one of those pictures yes
and
explain to the jury
again and i'm sorry for the the graphic
nature of this photo but it's important
that the jury understands the basis for
your opinion
that a bottle couldn't have caused this
coming in from above
yeah so it's so it's
it again the mechanism described would
have
almost certainly led to a severe nail
injury you know
see no subungua hematoma again it's it's
a palmer tissue loss
and the loss is from distal to proximal
which is in which is from the tip
back far below the nail and so for it to
create that tissue loss down there there
would almost certainly have to be injury
dorsally with that described mechanism
so what you're saying is that something
coming from the top could not have left
the nail intact and yet caused injury
from the tip of the finger underneath
the nail objection leading
over
you can answer so so uh so i believe
that um
with the mechanism described that if the
if the bottle struck the nail there
would have certainly been an injury to
the nail bed
and in order for the for the
soft tissue
injury to be created by that mechanism
there would have almost certainly been
tissue loss on the top of the finger as
well
does mr depp's description of what
happened line up with the undisputed
photographic evidence that you've
reviewed
no
now we mentioned the term crush injury a
few minutes ago um
i'd like to show you
dx360 please
and your honor this is um
we won't publish this at this time
um
did are these is this a document that
you reviewed in connection with your
expert opinion in this case yes
and
um
michelle if you can please go to pages i
believe they're five and six you're on
our i'd ask for permission to publish
these as a demonstrative
to the jury just page five and um sorry
uh sorry um
oh nine and ten
could pages go to 10 also so clean up
and see it okay any objection to oh no
okay oh 9 10 can be
published
dr moore are the what are these pictures
of
so these are x-rays of the uh injured
digit
and what do you observe in these x-rays
so the jury um
what you see
so these are these are
two views so one in the plane looking
through the finger in this direction one
of the plane looking through the finger
sideways and you can see that the the
tuft or the the tip of the
finger
the last bone in the finger called the
distal phalanx is shattered you can see
there's multiple little specules of bone
and there's also a transverse fracture
at that level
which runs through the bone
so this is this is what we would
describe as a comedy to fracture and
it's commonly associated with crushed
injury
in your decades of practice dr moore
have you ever seen a comminuted fracture
like this
result from an object thrown in the way
that mr depp described
well
not in not with the constellation of
findings shown on the x-rays i mean i
think
that could create a fracture but in the
in this setting it wouldn't create a
fracture with the asso without the
associated
um other injuries that we would
anticipate
and in your decades of practice when you
see a comminuted fracture like this
what are some things that have typically
caused it
so crush mechanisms could be
slammed in a drawer caught between two
logs and in the fireplace uh car door um
[Music]
sliding glass door those are all any
mechanism that
that squeezes the finger between two
hard opposing surfaces could create this
type injury
in the statements of mr depp that you
reviewed how did he describe what
happened to the
alleged bottle when it hit the bar
i believe um he said it exploded
chattered if
a bottle had exploded
near his finger
um in the way that he alleges what would
you expect to see in the documents that
you have reviewed
uh well i think that that the physicians
did a good job of documenting the
presentation the appearance of the wound
they did not document the presence of
any glass yards
um
and there were no other associated
injuries elsewhere on the hand okay
and
i just want to step back for one minute
michelle can you pull up the next page
of the x-ray here
um
thank you
and dr moore just before we move on from
x-rays um can you i know that this one
is blown up like this it's a little bit
blurry but can you point out um or
describe the jury where the where the
multiple bone fragments are in the
finger um so they're in the very tip
you know the
if you see the joint and then there's
the
what we call the transverse fracture
which is across the the
middle of the bone in the in the same
plane as the joint and then the multiple
fragments are in the tuft
um
and and the with the xerox copy the
quality is not as detailed as a true
x-ray
you can take that down please michelle
thank you
so so back to to to the glass in the
records that you reviewed dr moore did
you see
any
adjacent injuries in other words
injuries to any other part of mr depp's
hand other than the tip of his middle
finger no
and
is that observation consistent with the
explosion of glass type phenomenon that
mr deaf alleges
well i think in the setting of an of a
glass explosion like that where there's
multiple fragments the tip of the
fingers cut off you would you would
anticipate that there would be other
lacerations
did you review the documentation in the
medical records from the hospital in
australia yes
did any of those providers report
retrieving glass from the wound no
what about any glass near the site of
the injury
no
what about any glass in other parts of
the hand
no what about any glass in any of the
other fingers
no is there any reference at all dr
moore that you've seen
to any glass in the records that you've
reviewed
no
and dr maury in your decades of practice
have you ever seen an injury associated
with a glass explosion that was focused
on the end of a single finger in the way
mr depp describes
when
not consistent with the with the
clinical images and the findings in this
case no
have you ever seen an injury associated
with an alleged glass explosion where no
other glass
was found on any part of the patient's
body or clothing or anything
no
and because there's been talk of a of a
glass explosion um dr moore there's
there's
seems to have been a suggestion that
somehow glass may have sliced off the
end of mr depp's finger is that what's
going on here
this wound doesn't
really appear to be a sharp glass
laceration you referred earlier to an
avulsion
um which is a term i had never heard
before your opinion in this case explain
to the jury what that is so so often
with crush injuries and and um
and
we'll see uh tissue loss that we call an
avulsion or uh where the tissue is
actually um
pinched or or
pulled away uh rather than than sliced
or cut
and and it's not uncommon with crush
injuries to see that
in your decades of practice dr moore
have you ever seen an avulsion injury
with a partial amputation that results
from
an object thrown
from the top of the finger
and the way that mr depp describes
no again i think that the description
differs from the clinical appearance on
the images
michelle can you please pull up exhibit
369 at page 12.
this has been admitted your honor
all right let me publish to the jury
dr moore you've you said you've treated
thousands of hand injuries over the
course of your career correct correct
um what is that on mr depp's hand
uh
so we we'd describe that as objection
culture speculation
the picture just changed sorry page 12
please
okay
thank you thank you
what is that on mr depp's hand so that's
a that's a plaster splint
okay sorry thank you
i'm sorry please tell the jury what that
is on mr depp's hand uh so that's a
that's a plaster splint um a half a cast
is is how i sometimes describe to
patients and
it provides stability uh for comfort and
to protect fractures in the course of
treatment is that plaster splint hard or
soft uh what's plaster paris it's it's
uh it hardens like a cast does
dr moore um
does mr depp's description of how his
finger became injured line up with the
facts that you've seen
no
i have no further questions thank you dr
moore cross examination
good morning dr moore good morning
you said you reviewed mr depp's video
deposition is that correct that's
correct and you said you reviewed mr
depp's testimony at this trial correct
that's correct
and was that also a video of his
testimony yes
and you testified that mr depp
demonstrated that his hand was flat on a
surface is that correct that's correct
that's not entirely accurate is it
though
no his his description was relatively uh
consistent in both um
including turning and resting the hand
on the on the edge
isn't it true dr moore that when mr depp
did the demonstration in his deposition
he showed that his fingers were hanging
over the bar
well
even hanging over the bar it still
leaves the
dorsum of the hand or the nail
vulnerable that's not my question dr
moore my question is isn't it true
that mr depp said his fingers were not
laying flat on a table they were hanging
over the bar
yes okay and in fact you knew that
when you made that opinion isn't that
correct well i i believe that i uh as i
demonstrated sitting here that i said
that he it said they were slightly or
slightly curled over i think
was the description that i gave
your description in this courtroom was
that it was laying flat and i think
you've done that now twice but in your
deposition you testified that his
fingers were actually hanging over the
bar isn't that correct objection your
honor mistakes the witnesses testimony
he clearly indicated they were curled
who could have been overruled
so that's a so so
that's a distinction that that perhaps i
um
misstated in one of the two descriptions
however
that does not substantially change my
opinion of the impact it would have on
the mechanism
isn't it true that mr depp also
testified that the bottle came from an
off angle
yes okay and you consider that in
rendering your opinions today correct
yes i believe he stated that uh it came
from between six and ten feet uh
i think it was off to i think he
demonstrated was off to his right i
can't recall specifically but
it was off angle yes okay so it didn't
come from the top as you previously
testified just a few minutes ago correct
well no it would have struck the the
top of the finger but it may have been
slightly off angle in its approach based
on the description
mr depp described it as off angle
correct
correct
dr moore just at the outset your billing
rate for providing deposition testimony
is a thousand dollars per hour that's
correct all right
and you were deposed in this action for
several hours on march 22 2022 that's
correct and your billing rate for
providing trial testimony is five
thousand dollars per day that's correct
you were retained in this case by ms
hurd's legal team correct
correct and over the last few years
you've provided expert services for one
of ms heard's law firms on at least two
other cases right
that's correct yes
dr moore is it fair to say that you have
no personal knowledge as to how mr depp
injured his finger in australia correct
no i have no personal knowledge my my
impression is based on his uh his
description of the injury and the
available medical records for review
but you weren't in australia mr daphne
misheard chris not in australia no and
so therefore you have no personal
knowledge as to how that injury was
sustained
correct all right
you also never personally examined mr
dap's finger did you
correct
you didn't examine mr depp's finger at
the time he was injured
i did not and you never provided any
medical treatment to mr death in
connection with this finger injury did
you i did not
now you've testified that you identified
mr duff's finger injury as a crush
injury correct correct
and a crush injury is when a body part
is crushed or trapped between two
opposing firm surfaces yes yes
and a crush injury to a finger can occur
when a foreign object
hits the finger
right
yes
and based on the pictures that you
reviewed of mr jeff's finger injury you
cannot determine what particular object
caused the injury to his finger
yes well i i can't
i can't determine exactly what what
object did it i think that um i can i
can
say
with confidence that the described
mechanism of the bottle hitting and
shattering the finger
was not consistent with the appearance
of the injury my question is just very
specific you can't determine the object
that caused the injury to mr depp's
finger what's it's a little bit more of
a non-specific answer i mean i you know
again i i can't determine the exact
object but i can determine that that
it's unlikely that it was
sustained in the manner
a
described
is a foreign object isn't it
yes okay so you can't rule out that the
injury to mr death's finger was caused
by a vodka bottle correct
well based on the injury pattern i can
say that the described mechanism of
injury is inconsistent with medical
findings right
but because a vodka bottle is a foreign
object you can't rule out
that a vodka bottle is what caused mr
duff's injury
well i can't rule out that a vodka
bottle caused the injury but i can rule
out that it was caused in the manner
described in his testimony
you can't rule out the injury was caused
by a knife right
i think it's unlikely that the injury
was caused by a knife but you can't rule
it out
well if a simple knife laceration
wouldn't impart the energy to the distal
phalanx to result in
the comedy fracture
now a a chopping type
uh but again that would likely come from
a direction that would that would create
a dorsal
injury to create the fracture that was
developed do you remember giving
testimony in this case dr moore
uh deposition yes yes okay and you were
under oath correct correct all right
and that was on march 22 2022 yes
correct okay
may i approach your honor yes ma'am
thank you
dr gourmet please have you go to page
163
of your deposition
specifically line 17.
163
actually apologies 164.
line four
question but you can't rule it out
completely right answer i can't rule
anything out completely i can't rule out
that he caught it in the door cut it
with a knife or slammed it in the car
door or again as dr gilmer said we can't
definitively say what caused this injury
did i read that correctly you did
you're your honor what i would object is
to the incomplete impeachment i think if
she's going to read his answer she also
needs to read or give dr moore the
chance to read the paragraph below
she just picked out half of his answer
you can redirect us
yeah dr moore there's no question
pending thank you though
so you can't rule out the injury was
caused by a car door either is that
right
correct
but it's your testimony sitting here
today that you can rule out that the
injury was caused by a vodka bottle is
that your testimony
my testimony is that i can
rule out the injury
as caused by the mechanism described by
mr depp in his deposition
but you can't definitively say what
caused the injury to mr duff's finger
well the definitive injury was a crush
injury um but i but
again i i i can't say i mean i think
it's i think that that it's
quite likely that the initial
uh
mechanism described at the time of
presentation of the accordion doors
would would
classically create this injury pattern
you know the the hand up in front if you
picture accordion doors as the end as
the edges closed if the hands up the
palm is exposed if the door is pushed dr
moore closes about the face i understand
that but my question is i think it's
important that they understand that this
is the time for me to ask you questions
your counsel will have the ability to
rehabilitate you and ask you questions
on redirect right now let's try my
question okay you can't definitively say
what caused the injury to mr depp's
fingers yes or no
no okay
in conducting your analysis of mr duff's
finger injury you did not attempt to
reconstruct the incident is that right
well i think the the incident was
reconstructed do you mean i throw a
vodka bottle at something
no you're no dr moore i mean you didn't
do any type of accident reconstruction
either computerized or any you didn't
conduct any type of accident
reconstruction of the elections that's
correct my opinion is based on the
medical records and the clinical images
and mr depp's description and and your
analysis is based on an understanding of
how mr depp described the exact position
of his finger at the time of the injury
yes
yes okay and your analysis is also based
on the assumption that mr depp's hand
remained completely still in the
instance that a vodka bottle was hurtled
at him yes
no my assessment is on his description
of the
bottle striking the top of his finger
but his hand stayed still according to
your analysis yes
i guess it was still long enough for the
bottle to hit it but natural reaction
would be to try to pull away
when you perform traumatic finger
surgeries you inquire about the cause of
the injuries correct correct
and your best information on that is
typically just the self-report of the
patient yes
correct and your assumption is that the
patient is trying to get care
because the patient is trying to get
care that person that patient is
generally telling the truth right you
would hope so yeah you reviewed dr
kipper's deposition testimony informing
your opinion about mr duck's finger
injury correct correct
informing your opinion did you consider
dr kipper's deposition testimony that
while dr kipper was providing emergency
treatment
okay
so
let's start over
because it's important the jury hears
this so informing your opinion did you
consider dr kipper's deposition
testimony that while dr kipper was
providing emergency treatment for mr
depp's finger injury in australia in the
driveway of the house mr depp told him
that his finger was injured when
misheard threw a vodka bottle at him
uh i i don't
but i don't recall that from the
deposition i'd be happy to review if you
have the deposition
available
did you consider dr kipper's testimony
that he recalled that mr duff's finger
was found in the kitchen
i do recall that
so you must have also seen dr kipper's
deposition testimony that he wasn't the
one who actually found the finger
correct that's correct
dr kipper testified that someone he
thought was the chef told him he found
the finger in the kitchen area correct
uh
i'm gonna assume so without reading the
deposition now
did you review uh any testimony from ben
king and rendering your opinions today
uh not to my knowledge no did you see
any of mr king's testimony at this trial
i did not okay so you're not aware that
mr king testified that he is the one who
found mr duff's finger are you
no
and you're not aware that mr king
testified that he found mr dapp's finger
in the bar area
right
correct
and you're not aware that mr king
testified he found mr depp's finger in a
piece of tissue in the bar area either
no
and you're not aware that mr king
testified that multiple broken liquor
bottles were also found in the bar area
right
correct if we could please pull up
defendants exhibit
1817 which is already in evidence
and it may be published please
i just don't have it yet
that would help yes i just have a blank
screen at the mall
there we go
there we go okay
have you ever seen this picture before
dr moore no
so you're not aware that this is the bar
area where mr king testified he found mr
duff's finger
no
okay do you see that broken vodka bottle
in the back corner near the bottom of
the bar
yes
okay
do you see the blood drops on the floor
yes
can we please pull up defendants exhibit
one eight two zero which is already in
evidence
have you seen this picture before dr
moore
i i'm not so you're not aware that this
is also a picture from the bar area
where mr king testified he found mr
depp's finger
correct
do you see the bloody tissue on the
ground at the bottom of the bar
yes
do you see the blood drops around that
tissue
yes
so you didn't consider any of this
evidence in rendering your opinion about
how mr depp injured his finger in
australia did you
i did not
nothing further your honor thank you
redirect
yes sir
can you pull up um exhibit 1817 that was
just shown to the witness please
and can you um
blow up that what what miss vasquez
referred to as a broken vodka bottle
michelle please
dr moore what what based on your review
of the documents in this case what did
you understand to be the size of the
bottle of vodka that mr depp alleged cut
off his finger the description was that
it was a uh
a handle a half gallon bottle
and that's bigger than a 750 mil or
fifth of liquor correct yes
and what size bottle if to the extent
that's even a bottle what size does that
appear to be to you calls for
speculation your honor i'll sustain the
objection does that appear to be a
handle
objection calls for speculation don't
sustain the objection
you can take that down
um dr moore
miss vasquez just just um
asked you about dr kipper's deposition
testimony
um and she said is that
where where she claims that mr depp
allegedly told him that the finger was
severed from a vodka bottle do you
remember that question a few minutes ago
objection leading
over
i didn't remember that question yes
thank you is that consistent that
alleged account is that consistent with
the texts you the texts you reviewed
between mr depp and dr kipper
uh no and what did those texts say
uh as i recall
mr depp indicated that he had cut his
finger off
now miss vasquez wouldn't let you finish
when you were trying to explain to the
jury
how
mr depp's account of injuring his finger
in an accordion door would be perfectly
consistent with the photographs you saw
could you please explain that to the
jury
well well so
again uh we tend to try to believe
patients we hope that they come in with
an honest history initially and and
that's a reasonable mechanism for this
to have occurred
and again if you picture your hand up
with a with a either a closure of a
hinge or a closure of the door the
palmer surface is exposed if it's caught
in that hinge as it closes it could be
it could be slightly off-center it would
pinch that tissue away in a similar
fashion but because it's below the level
of the nail bed it could create this
injury with the fracture the tissue loss
and preserve the nail bed
can you look at page 164 of your
deposition the one that miss vasquez
just showed you
yes objection your honor i'm going to
object on here say grounds
your honor sheep only
thank you
miss vasquez asked you a question and
then she read your answer trying to
impeach you but she only read half of
the answer so i'm gonna read the whole
answer to the jury and i'm gonna ask you
to tell me if i'm reading your answer
right okay
the the question is on page 164 line
four but you can't rule it out
completely right
and you answered i can't rule anything
out completely i can't rule out that he
caught it in the door cut it with a
knife or slammed it in the car door or
again as dr gilmore said we can't
definitively say what caused this injury
and then you go on to say this is where
miss vasquez cut you off and didn't let
you finish
what i i don't think that's in the
transcript objection i'll sustain that
the rest of the rest of your answer
that she didn't read to you dr moore is
what i the question i can answer is is
that the mechanism that was described by
mr depp and demonstrated by mr depp is
inconsistent with the injury pattern
that's found on the images and the
description
did i read that right yes
and does that remain your opinion today
yes has anything that's been presented
to you on cross-examination
changed any of the opinions that you
hold in this case no
i have nothing further thank you dr
moore thank you all right dr moore
you're free to go or you can stay in the
courtroom it's up to you all right thank
you all right your next witness your
honor we'd
like to call dr david spiegel dr spiegel
all right that's fine yes sir
is
is
thank you all right
the doctor could be
sworn i swear
thank your honor
will you please tell the jury your full
name and business address
uh david
r spiegel i'm a physician
i work at 825 fairfax avenue in norfolk
virginia
as part of the eastern virginia medical
school
and what is your occupation
i'm a physician psychiatrist
and and where do you work do you work it
i work at eastern virginia i'm employed
by east virginia medical school but i
also work at a norfolk general hospital
which is the teaching hospital in
norfolk
how many years have you been practicing
as a psychiatrist
i entered residency in 1989
i graduated regency in 1993
so from 1993 to today
i've been
in uh
physician practicing
so that's almost that's 30 years
thank you
please describe for the jury the nature
of your clinical practice
so my clinical practice is comprised of
both inpatient care at norfolk general
hospital as well as my outpatient
practice at eastern virginia medical
school
about
85 to 90 percent of my day
is clinical between
the two components
and what is involved in a comprehensive
evaluation
so in a comprehensive evaluation
in addition to reviewing historical
information that you receive from
collateral other sources
you undertake a history from the patient
you get whether it's the history current
illness the past psychiatric history
family history social history
legal substance history
then you do what's called a mental
status exam which is the psychiatric
version of the physical exam they're
actually giving a description of what
you see in front of you
uh then you can do cognitive testing
which tests the patient memory
attention concentration etc
then you come up with a working and a
differential diagnosis
describe any other additional testing
you may need or not need
and then you come up with a treatment
plan
how many patients have you treated over
the 30 years
quite a lot probably in the tens of
thousands
and how many patients do you regularly
see
so inpatient
is generally about five to eight
sometimes more
outpatients probably five to six
sometimes more
i should point out that my inpatient
work is divided between uh consultation
psychiatrically we're going to talk
about that as well as working on the
inpatient service so hopefully we will
talk about that
um what if any differences are there on
how many patients you see on weekends as
opposed to weekdays so when i'm on call
which is uh on either a saturday or a
sunday meeting i have to be in the
hospital and around that's probably
additional 35 plus patients
how frequently do you treat patients who
abuse drugs and alcohol
unfortunately drugs and alcohol are part
of psychiatric practice
and so
probably three-fourths of my patients
have substance abuse problems
does this include both legal and illegal
drugs yes
put them both together probably 75
and how frequently do you treat patients
who have suffered from someone in their
lives who abuses alcohol and drugs
on a regular basis like i said on a
daily basis this is part of what
psychiatry is
okay and as part of that treatment of
patients who abuse drugs and alcohol do
you evaluate the impact of the abuse on
their brains and personal interactions
with others
yes uh substance of abuse
both in the short term and the long term
can affect the brain in terms of mood
behavior
cognition meaning
attention concentration memory ability
to control your behavior as well as your
overall level of functioning
it can affect it in the short term such
as alcoholic blackouts it can affect it
by causing strokes such as stimulants
can
and so at the end of the day
it's a rather lengthy
list of what substance abuse could do to
the human brain
dr spiegel how frequently have you
treated patients who have suffered
intimate partner violence
again it's very unfortunate that
probably 50 percent of my patients
suffer from trauma
if i had a guess of those 50 percent
probably 25
of my practice is
people who have suffered intimate
partner violence
and how consistent is that with the
national average in america
unfortunately uh it's about 20 to 25
percent depending on the study of uh
women have complained
reported
intimate partner violence
and how frequently have you treated
patients who have perpetrated the
intimate partner violence
so again in the outpatient setting i
don't see it quite as much but in the
inpatient setting again it's a really
relative uh common phenomena that we'll
see uh perpetrators of it partner
violence
and
you know their patients who need
treatment too
and overall how many patients have you
treated who have been perpetrators of
intimate partner violence
perpetrators yes uh probably five to ten
percent of the patients i do is
perpetrators
and would you say uh tens of thousands
over the 30 years
yes in leading
thank you as part of treating patients
relating to intimate partner violence do
you regularly evaluate these patients
do i regularly value the patient
evaluate the patients oh yes yes right i
mean they get the same comprehensive
evaluation
that i described before
are you licensed in virginia yes i am
and when did you first become licensed
in virginia
1993.
have you been qualified by courts as an
expert witness
yes i have in how many states have you
been qualified as an expert
three which would be virginia
maryland and south carolina
dr spiegel can you please review for the
jury your educational background
beginning with your undergraduate
studies
so
i went to duke university undergrad
i went to medical school at the state
university of new york health science
center in brooklyn formerly known as
down state medical center
i did my internship and residency
between dartmouth hitchcock medical
center and penn state hershey medical
center
and
i'm also fellowship
uh board certified in consultation
liaison psychiatry okay
and uh
did you so where did you do your
residency and your internships so i did
my residency for penn state and
internship at dartmouth
okay
and what is your current title and
position
so i am in the acting chair
uh endowed chair and professor in the
department of psychiatry behavioral
sciences at eastern virginia medical
school are you board certified yes i am
and what are you board certified in
general adult psychiatry and
consultation ways on psychiatry as a
sub-specialty
okay so you have two board
certifications okay can you explain to
the jury what's involved in board
certifications in those two fields
so board certification is the standard
we strive to
in
being a physician or any other
mental health practitioner
it involves
taking a very comprehensive
test at the beginning of your career to
initiate board certification then you
get tested
again every 10 years
then you have to go through continual
medical education
throughout
the entire period
you have to do what's called performance
and practice which is basically ways to
improve things
in your practice uh and again this is
throughout this occurs always throughout
the years
okay
now are you a member of any professional
organizations
psychiatric association
as well as the fellow of the american
psychiatric association
i'm a member of the medical society of
virginia
a member of the
psychiatric side of virginia
i'm a member of the tidewater academy of
psychiatry and i'm a member of the
academy consultation liaison psychiatry
do you have any teaching
responsibilities
teaching
teaching so yes so teaching is a daily
occurrence
as part of my job when i'm in when i do
my inpatient rounds uh residents
medical students physician assistant
students are assigned so we round
together and there's teaching with every
single encounter
uh in addition to that i teach lectures
to the residents
to the uh third second and first year
medical students
as well as a fourth year medical student
lecture as well
so i'm constantly teaching
have you engaged in any hands-on
training of psychiatrists practicing in
virginia
hands-on training with the residents
with psychiatrists oh yeah so again uh
i'm
teaching at bedside i mean we don't
speak in front of the patient obviously
but i'm teaching at bedside meeting
after we see a patient we discuss uh
important points to to learn and again
that includes residents at every level
that includes medical students third
second and first year physician decision
students so
every day is a teaching explanation
session to the students in residence
what is your role at eastern virginia
medical school as the acting chair
please tell the jury what that means
so as the acting chair you are not only
accountable for your own practice but
you are accountable for your faculty
members practices so i have to make sure
that everyone is
treating
seeing evaluating a certain number of
patients i have responsible for their
academic requirements so in terms of
publishing etc i'm responsible for their
uh
teaching assignments to other residents
to other students i'm responsible for
fiscally that they are
accountable to their uh fiscal
productivity
so and a heck of a lot of other
administrative uh meetings that i go to
okay
have you published in your field
uh to the tune of about 80 manuscripts
and i have my own book on catatonia the
consultation liaison setting i have a
book chapter in on the uh
current and uh
current and contemporary approaches
temporomandibular disease psychiatric
portion i'm also in a dissociative
identity disorders chapter on a uh
wikibook
and have you peer reviewed literature
yes so i'm a i'm a reviewer on i've
served as a viewer on
lancet i've heard a viewer as
innovations in clinical neuroscience
i've served on a reviewer for clinical
neuropharmacology and i'm actually
editor-in-chief
of at this point of clinical
neuropharmacology
have you lectured on the effects of
drugs and alcohol on the human brain
yes uh i teach to the residents i teach
a
lecture to the second year medical
students third year medical students so
i am fully aware of
not only what i teach but what i see in
the emergency room and the consultation
in patient settings
have you published and lectured on the
causes and effects of intimate partner
abuse
yes i punctured i believe two articles
on the effects of trauma and in that
trauma was intimate partner violence
are you familiar with the hallmarks of
intimate partner violence yes
are you familiar with what causes
intimate partner violence one more
what causes intimate partner violence
yes there's a multiple explanation that
caused intimate partner violence and if
i kind of just mentioned at this point
too that
when we are discussing intimate partner
violence i think it's imperative for the
jury to know we are talking about
repetitive
behavior over periods of time
and the type of abuse can be any
physical psychological
sexual
but just as important is for somebody
one of the partners to maintain
some uneven element of control
or to maintain
power
control or authority so there are a lot
of facets to intimate partner violence i
know people tend to think of as just the
actual
abuse act
but there's more to it than just the
actual abuse act because that's
important but it's not so fun
your honor i'd move to qualify dr
spiegel as an expert in the field of
psychiatry and behavioral sciences with
specific emphasis on drug and alcohol
abuse intimate partner violence and the
effect of these as they pertain to the
issues in this case all right any
objection yes
you wish to avoid dear i do okay
to his qualifications
his wealth okay thank you
sir you talked about two board
certifications
general adult psychiatry
yes
and
liaison consultation site psychiatry uh
other way around with confrontation
right
now that
is
not
inter partner violence that deals with
with a
issue of comorbidity between people who
have
medical problems
and health problems
so you're saying sub-specialty yes so
consultation lays on psychiatry does
have that but you're also treating
patients who have medical illness who
have co-morbid psychiatric illness or
people who have psychiatric illness that
have comorbid medical illness and many
of the patients that i see on the trauma
service have tried to take their own
life and unfortunately as part of that
intimate partner violence and trauma in
general is part and parcel of that so
it's
very very narrow to say it's just a
medical psychiatric interface it's much
more of psychiatric patients you need
medical help medical patient develops
psychiatric problems but also
that interface
so
as a subset of your trauma patients
which you say are about 50 of your
practice
as a subset of that practice some people
have been involved with intimate partner
violence so as a subset of my overall
practice 50 percent of suffering from
trauma about half of that number have
suffered from i'm sorry about 20 so it's
20 about 20 that suffer from my intimate
partner violence all right you've never
conducted any empirical research
on individuals who experienced intimate
partner violence have you sir
if your definition is trials is that
what you're saying yes like
pharmaceutical trials or what are you
saying
as i was saying because i've done review
articles on
patients who suffered from trauma so the
answer is oh i haven't done any
studies like where you
uh
give them medication for treatment or
try one treatment versus another i've
reviewed the body of literature on
intimate partner violence to get two
review articles yes so you
so you've read about it is what you just
testified i would have to disagree with
you on that sir reading about it and
writing a review article are completely
two different things sir all right you
haven't authorized authored any articles
specifically on ipv have you sir as a
subset of trauma the answer is yes in
terms of in the name of the title of the
article the answer is no
you've never written any books
specifically on ipv
i've never written any books on ipv
although although
temporomandibular disease
okay in terms of psychiatric issues does
have a higher frequency in those
patients who have suffered from trauma
including
intimate partner violence
you know and i am part of that book
okay temporal mandibular disease deals
with
problems with the jaw
what is temporal mental traumatic dipole
disease problem with oral issues yet but
there are many patients who complain of
oral issues where the uh where the oral
surgeon cannot find a reason for it and
the reason why they can't is because
people who have suffered from trauma and
intimate partner violence are prone to
increased sensitivity of somatic
sensations which can manifest in
temporal manipulates thank you i
appreciate that nice plug for my book
you thank you
didn't hear it but there we go um
so
you haven't written any chapters of any
books specifically about ipv
again i think i've gone over that i've
written two articles on that and i've
written parts of chapters and
dissociative identity disorder i should
have where i did write a chapter on is
completely based on trauma and intimate
partner violence right i'm not asking
about trauma because you want to talk
about trauma i'm asking you about ipv
specifically
i will reiterate again
you cannot separate
intimate partner violence and say that
is a separate rubric
aside from trauma trauma
is overall
intimate partner violence is part of
trauma and the answer to the question is
any individual with substance from a
dissociative disorder which i am the
author or chapter of suffers from trauma
whether it be at the hands and childhood
or be in the hands of an intimate
partner
right but you've already testified that
half your practice is trauma and a
subset of that practice is ipv correct
which is now actually i treat the
national average patients about 20 of
patients suffer from it and that's about
my practice number
that except you're discounting the fact
that half your practice is
not trauma at all so
ten percent of your practice is ipv
i don't know if the number is exactly
like i'm just using yours
i don't know if i'm doing uh i don't
know if those numbers end up like that
uh because i'm not sure if that's the
case if you take 25 then maybe 12.5
percent of my practice that's be rather
specific so again a significant number
of my patients have suffered from
intimate partner violence i see it on a
daily basis and i'm not sure exactly why
i'm
getting asked the same question again
thank you sir
you listed 60 references to articles i
guess you said 80 now and publications
um and i said around so i said around
80. i said around look 60 80 whatever it
is right now 60 and 80 is not if you go
to the pubmed you want you're going to
put men right now and google
put pubmed spiegel dr and you'll find
that number is 72 with two waiting to be
impressed one submitter that would be 75
so it's around 80. so again what's on my
cv is not necessarily the most updated
version because i still publish
since the cv has been uh
given to you sir
right
and
not one of the 72 80
articles
has ipv in the title right
correct not one of them has ipv it
doesn't have trauma but not ipv right
and you've never presented on the topic
of ipv specifically
you as a function of trauma and as a
function of somatic illness again i
would say to you that it's part and
parcel of these illnesses so the answer
is yes i have okay the answer is yes i
have and ipv doesn't appear in your cv
at all
if if you say it's not in my cv i will
believe you
there's a lot of things i'm not in my cv
and you're not associated with any
professional literature on ipv
i'm sorry repeat the question sir is
there any professional literature that
you've contributed to relative to ipv
specifically as as opposed to trauma
generally
the answer to the question again sir
is that you cannot separate this
artificial separation you are trying to
do between trauma and intimate partner
violence it is part and parcel of trauma
we don't
thread it like that
your honor
plaintiff would accept this witness as
an expert on general psychiatry but
and
with respect to the drug usage issues
that mrs bredehoff referenced but not
with respect to ipv all right over
objection he's entered as an expert as
as stated on the record all right you
may continue thank you very much
dr spiegel at our request what have you
reviewed in this case and just go ahead
and give you so
it's a lengthy review but court filings
uh psychological testing that was done
on misheard by both dr hughes and dr
curry
uh
other physicians medical records vicinio
dr kipper
um
council
councils and therapists
that both parties and psychiatrists that
they went to
uh
text messages
depositions
uh
snippets of uh the uk trial
um
and i'm sure uh pictures of uh physical
injuries so i've seen a lot
what if anything have you seen in terms
of emails audios videos yes so i've seen
videos of uh
mr depp i think the video was showing
right of mr depp
destroying uh
slamming cupboards and
breaking glass
and yelling at misheard
while having a wine glass in his uh with
wine in his hands
i've seen videos of
a destruction of property in the house
okay uh and what if any review have you
conducted of the deposition and
testimony of mr depp's hired witness dr
curry
object
approach sure
do you remember my question
did you review the
deposition and testimony of dr curry
dr curry
yes i've dr yes i'm sorry yeah so every
testimony dr curry i reviewed dr perry's
reports i reviewed dr curry's test
okay and what if did you review the
deposition and trial testimony of dr
hughes
yes objection you're honored beyond the
scope of the disclosure
uh i'll allow that thank you honor
overruled did you interview mr depp no i
did not
did you request
i requested to interview mr depp twice
and both times mr depp and his lawyers
refused
dr spiegel i'm going to ask you some
questions in this case respecting your
opinions and and the opinions you have
formed in the bases for them and i'm
going to ask you to provide me with in a
reasonable degree of medical probability
or certainty can you do that yes okay
on what were you requested to analyze
and opine in this case
so it's fourfold uh
one i was asked to opine about the risk
factors that are associated with
intimate partner violence
and behaviors that are shown
risk factors that are shown in intimate
partner violence to be consistent with
behaviors that mr depp has demonstrated
two
i've been asked to opine about the acute
effects on alcohol and substance use and
i mentioned that including mood behavior
cognition functional impairment
three
talking about the psychological profile
if you would of
i'm is there a question i'm sorry oh no
okay of uh psychological and medical
sequelae of patients who have suffered
intimate partner violence and perpetrate
intimate providers and whether or not mr
death's behavior is consistent with that
and lastly about
alcohol and other substance use
disorders
their diagnostic criteria their medical
and psychological effects psychiatric
effects their cognitive effects and
their functional effects
and i think i would like to just just go
with the jury one other thing when we
talk about when we when psychiatry talks
about substance use disorders i it's
imperative to understand we're not
talking about someone who rarely uses
and happens to have a bad night we're
not talking about someone who uses on a
weekly basis and has a bad night we're
talking about repetitive patterns of
behavior that meet a list of 11 criteria
that can be deemed mild moderate or
severe
because i think people get confused when
they hear the word substitutes that they
think of oh i may have used this because
i use it twice
there is a whole criteria
of behavior
and sequelae and consequences that go
with a substance use disorder i'm not
just talking about someone who will
occasionally smoke a joint or smokes a
joint or snorts occasionally coke okay
or has alcohol on weekends so i really
need to reiterate that because i think
when you look at psychiatric behavior
we tend to look people look online and
say my gosh i have all seven of these
right and they they're reading it not
quite the way the psychiatric lyrics are
supposed to go so please when i'm
talking about this i need you to
understand
one that that's what's going on as i
told you about intimate partner violence
it's horrible that anyone would strike
anyone okay but again we're talking
about repetitive behaviors from means of
control
right so that's real important to
understand when you're moving forward
and i may
say occasionally substance abuse but
what i'm referring to
is substance objection beyond the scope
of the question
sustained next question okay
dr spiegel could you please just
summarize for the jury the conclusions
you came to with your opinions and then
we'll take you through the specifics
so in my opinion
based on my
review of the evidence
based on my clinical experience based on
my publishing experience based on my
teaching experience
that mr deb has behaviors that are
consistent with both someone who has a
substance use disorder as well as
consistent behaviors for someone who is
a perpetrator of intimate partner
violence
thank you i'm going to start with the
impact of drug and alcohol abuse over
time
first of all based upon your review of
the record evidence what type of drugs
has mr depp used
so mr depp and i will get i'm told by
you we're talking about a substance use
disorder here we're not just talking
about use
okay so we are talking about alcohol
we are talking about amphetamines
we are talking about marijuana
we talk about cocaine
we are told by lsd
we are talking about ecstasy we are
talking about opiates we are talking
about prescription benzodiazepines
and we'll get into a separate thing
about the abusability of seroquel
and organ in iran
and we're talking about much of the time
concurrent use
meaning simultaneously
in your practice do some patients
suggest to you that drugs and alcohol
actually help them
so i think it's
patients who lack insight or are in the
very early stages of recognizing they
have a quote unquote problem
will sometimes actually say
that they have
this medication actually calms me down
this medication makes me feel better
and in actuality
they may not acutely feel
anything
but chronic and continual use will take
its toll on the brain so the answer is
yes but again people who have substance
use disorders have a very have lack of
insight and lack of judgment about
what's going on the very poor
moderates of their own behavior
has mr depp suggested based on your
review of the record evidence that
alcohol and drugs
actually help him yes in review of the
evidence he has suggested that alcohol
xanax i'm in the list of medications do
help
although i will also tell you on review
of the evidence that there was
at least two times i can remember
that mr depp was referring to
at least short-lived periods of sobriety
and i cannot exactly tell you what that
included
that both times he said that he
functioned better and that he recognized
that alcohol drugs was at the root of
his problems
now
there have been there's been testimony
that mr depp is quite charming both off
and on
the drugs and the alcohol
what is your answer to that so
again
let me
put one thing clear here i am not here
to impeach mr depp's acting skills
or his persona he has way greater skills
than i do in that
what i'm here to say is talk about how
drugs and alcohol affect what we all
have in common we're all human beings we
can all only get so much take so much
when something is going to happen
and that's what i see every day
in the emergency room on the council
service an patient psychiatry
bad things happen not because of
anything special except we're all human
beings and our brains substance of abuse
are not titrated they're not regulated
by the fda
we don't know what we're getting we
don't know how much we're getting there
is no control over what makes it to our
brain so it is not the actor it is not
the persona
okay
it is a person just like the rest of us
who are human beings
who will have these effects and that's
what we all share in common every one of
this courtroom shares that in common
when mr depp was in his relationship
with amber hurd was he a poly substance
abuser
what's he and what substance abuse poly
substances yes
can you explain leave it here what that
is overrule
i'm sorry
okay so poly substance abuse is the use
of three or more substances
and i answer like i said concurrently
um
he was
even while i was getting ready for rehab
on the island he was so yes he did
engage in that
did mr depp's drug and alcohol abuse
affect him cognitively
yes
so
if if nothing else to look at uh dr uh
blaustein psychiatrist valerie mr depp
did a mini-mental state exam on him and
as part of that mini mental state
examination you're asked to remember
three words and then come back
five minutes later and repeat those
three words and in the meanwhile you're
getting other types of testing for
attention and concentration and visual
spatial and language so other things
that are being tested too
mr depp was unable to recall any of them
and that is
very unusual
for a
50-ish year old male i don't remember
how old he was when he took that
generally speaking
that age group should be remembering two
or all three of those words
um
one i do know that his uh lines were
also
fed to him by earpiece uh again
affecting memory i did see in deposition
i'm sorry video deposition about having
to have
uh questions i don't want to say repeat
as much as completely forgotten
so
the answer is yes and you know any again
any one of us who use alcohol and
cocaine
to that level of degree and i'm talking
about a severe level of substance use
disorder
are going to have effects is inescapable
because we all have brains that are male
affected by extensive substance use and
potentially sometimes less
but certainly what we're talking about
here is extensive
what if any anything did did you observe
from the record evidence about mr depp
having difficulty focusing his attention
span processing whether he could
function as an actor
so electron compound
compound is only if it's overruled thank
you
so again in terms of the acting part we
do know that he needed his lines fed to
him for movies
part of that
could have been also due to
and i don't know which movie and please
forgive me about that that he actually
confessed he did a movie entirely wasted
so i imagine it would be harder to do
that
um
additionally like i said when i looked
at that position you can tell that the
processing speed was down his thinking
rate was down
if your thinking rate is down and i'm
not talking about it again i'm getting
older i'm probably not as sharp as i was
at 25 okay
but i'm talking about it so slow that
when we're trying to move on to other
questions
we're still trying to answer the
original data that's presented to us so
attention span
is very much impaired and if your
attention span is impaired your memory
is going to be impaired it is
inescapable that that's going to happen
so all that
comes into play and that's what i
witnessed in the um
in the
video deposition
fortunately for mr depp i do see that
during this trial that's he's uh uh his
cognition has improved someone which
will happen if you are sober
uh so i commend him on that
uh but again i'm specifically
referencing the time with ms hearns and
mr depp's relationship so we're talking
about that
what if any uh
uh observations from the record evidence
did you have about mr depp having
alcoholic blackouts or foggy mind
again the reported time where he would
be essentially quote unquote passed out
drunk he saw pictures of him passed out
drunk and not being able to remember
what he did which is again if you look
at the record evidence
you will see that
and this is linking intimate partner
violence and substance use together i
know we're going to get to that which is
basically if you have blackouts
and you're using alcohol or using
cocaine
it's going to be near impossible to
remember
what happened at night for i don't think
i'm the first person that's ever told
you that alcohol can cause blackouts and
basically alcohol
decreases a brain chemical glutamate
which is involved in memory formation
if it blocks that
to an extensive degree the individual
cannot remember what happened because
they didn't have enough time for their
brain to process the memory we need this
brain chemical so does alcohol blackouts
happen every time so no of course not
but are they complication of use
disorder absolutely yes and there was
record evidence of that
dr spiegel you said at one point alcohol
and cocaine is it possible to have
blackouts with alcohol and different
types of substances yes so
my clinical experience that i'll be i'll
data back within the last month
we had a patient who was using both
especially cocaine and she had these
kind of
stroke-like lesions around the brain
center known as the hippocampus which is
involved in memory formation
so objection relevance
just giving an example
combining the two sums together
increases the likelihood even if you
don't get what is a major stroke again
we think of a major stroke as someone
who has speech difficulties and movement
difficulties there's a lot of different
types of stroke that can just affect
cognition they don't necessarily have to
have
severe movement deficits or severe
language deficits they can solely affect
you in terms of your cognitive symptoms
and actually known as a vascular
neurocognitive disorder so i you need to
and that's part of the psychiatric
diagnosis you need to understand that
you can have these insults these lesions
these strokes without demonstrating
physical features and at a minimal
we know that he was using both
substances concurrently and in the
middle we know he had cognitive issues
that we talked about or at least had
some of them
thank you dr spiegel what if any
correlation is there between domestic
abuse heavy alcohol abuse and cognitive
disorders
so
um
the risk factors if you would for
intimate partner violence
okay and there are probably many of them
i don't have time to have all them but
the ones in particular characters in
particular are one
having someone in the relationship who
is jealous or suspicious
two having someone who has
a higher than average acceptance of
violence ideations
three someone who has rapid and extreme
mood shifts for
someone who has limited self-control
one of the roles of cognition one of the
roles of our brain
is to prevent inappropriate behaviors
and acting out on thoughts we all get
angry at people
that's human we all get angry at people
we all think things about people the
difference is when our brains are intact
and working well
most of us don't act them out
okay most of us do not act them out
so that's
because your frontal lobe and other
parts of the brain are involved in
making sure these negative thoughts
don't get acted on okay
so
when you have the effects of alcohol
acutely
that causes disinhibition
which means you are by definition
losing control and having rapid mood
swings
two you are affecting parts of the brain
that are involved in what we call social
processing clues cues so you no longer
can interpret
what's in front of you that is i would
say right or wrong or what i should act
on and what i shouldn't act on
so we act on them
even though
sober and i've seen it in with mr depp's
uh mr deputy record evidence i've seen
it clinically sober
we can contain that
we can contain that
but when you have these mixtures
together
knowing by the way that about 40 up to
60 percent
of intimate partner violence is uh
uh done under the influence of alcohol
and those substance use disorders
okay
knowing that treating it gets it better
improves i'm gonna say it removes it but
improves it
hearing from mr depp's own uh text to dr
kipper that he was better with that that
things are going better we'll show you
that given those confluence of factors
given them all lining up the risk
factors
combined with something that when any of
us any of us
use to a certain amount if we're not sad
it'll be a lot less
if we're more experienced and more
tolerance dependent it's going to take a
lot more
but inevitably will make us disinhibited
and will make us act out and acting out
could be done in a lot of different ways
an intimate part of violence okay with
also remembering
control is the endgame of its memorial
violence so that's how they basically
interact in a nutshell
miss brotherhood i assume you have i
have quite a bit more let's go ahead and
take our uh morning recess ladies and
gentlemen just do not discuss the case
and don't do any outside research we'll
be back with you oh i'm sorry in 15
minutes we're just all right
break no no we're taking a break
all right let's just take a break till
11 then we'll come back at 11 okay thank
you
are you ready for the jury yes we
approach before the majority okay sure
so
all right
thank you baby seated all right your
next question thank you thank you honor
dr spiegel before we took the break you
were talking about the correlation
between domestic abuse heavy alcohol
abuse and cognitive disorders does the
literature support uh your your
testimony on this yes the literature
fully supports everything i just said
i'll do that interaction
thank you um
now you indicated that you reviewed mr
depp's video depositions is that correct
from november 10 through 12 of 2020 and
december 14 2021 is that correct yes
okay
did you reach any conclusions about his
cognitive symptoms insight and judgment
in watching those
so
during the
video deposition
what was readily apparent
was a gentleman who had a significant
delay
in processing speed
and like i said when you have a delay in
processing speed
many other cognitive functions are going
to follow you're going to be impaired
attention
concentration
memory
all that's going to
happen in terms of uh uh
having to
the the speech process if you heard the
deposition the way the thoughts were
conveyed
were much more in the way of kind of
disconnected disjointed statements it
wasn't that they were not necessarily
understandable
but they didn't have any coherent
pattern until
he was more structured by ms britthoff
to kind of get to the point of the
question which happened throughout most
of the deposition
um and so
you could see there that there was
obviously some form or cognitive issue
that
should not be happening
in someone in their mid-50s i think
probably due to the
alcohol and substances
what if any observations did you make
about impulse control
so during the deposition or yes or no
record
um
so
again i think that
under the
guise of not being acutely intoxicated
i think mr depp was able to
control
much of his behavior much of his
thinking even if it was
aberrant or negative he's able to
control that
i think that
once you start getting to the point of
adding substances to that
that will set it over
um
if you saw the the video i think you you
all did about the uh in the
kitchen where there was smashing of
glasses slamming of cupboards and
yelling at miss her that you don't exist
um
and throughout
the deposition of dr kipper
mr deb is firing him and rehiring him
and yelling and screaming and i do
believe that a lot of it had to do with
the interaction of hey
we're trying to help you get sober
okay and it is obviously something you
are resisting
not ready for not wanting and so you saw
a lot of yelling a lot of uh a lot of
acting out if you would
which
puts you on the state of hey this is a
gentleman who has really significant
trouble
with delaying gratification
okay delay and reward
um and certainly one way to one way to
make that significantly worse
is with substances
there's no question about that
and you may have
subsumed this in but what if anything
did you observe relating to erratic
behavior based on the record yeah i mean
i i think again when you talk about
erratic behavior um
the uh
uh
dr kipper's deposition i believe it was
where and i think i made particular note
of this only because i'm i'm a
psychiatrist myself
there was a very
uh
large
ranting about dr cowan who was miss
heard's
psychologist therapist
um
and
the language you can be dissatisfied
with your provider i have no problem
with that you could be dissatisfied and
you have a right to go to wherever you
want to go to
but the
the texting
that it were involved in this in terms
of erratic behavior
um
was
disturbing in terms of the verb you
choose the phrases you say i i'm
am i free to
uh
use some of the language or should i
reserve that your honor
go ahead
okay
believe me the jury's been hearing that
okay all right i want to make sure
i want to take sure okay so there's
something along the line that uh
uh dr kipper is an effing charlatan
he ordered objection hearsay
he's entitled to rely on it he's to give
his examples
he can talk about what he
uh developed from the hearsay but not
repeat it himself he's entitled to give
examples of it
without giving the exact words that you
recall
yeah okay so i mean without giving the
exact words it was basically
vulgar language directed towards dr
cowan you have multiple tests
texts
multiple
uh
things that dr cowan were doing in uh in
therapy
uh uh
uh it was like i said it was without
relaying the exact thing i'm trying to
be as accurate as i can um
and i think at the end of it i think he
was also talking about that dr cowan was
filling amber with
positive
thoughts or therapeutics objection
hearsay
i think he's keeping it more general and
he's rela he's entitled to rely on him
thank you
so
more along a lot of
giving amber psychiatric
uh uh uh
uh jargon to put on him and and and
actually
what i read and interpreted with dr
cowan's uh was getting blasted for
was he was
you know kind of teaching amber how he
was heard how to use conflict resolution
in a more appropriate manner and
learning to express things more
rationally
rather than express things as irrational
as they have been expressed
and uh and for that
there were a lot of negativity
being sworn out so again erratic
behavior in terms of writing a text but
i have no problem people being angry
okay none whatsoever it's just
the expression of it and the continual
ranting of it
is is was was very uncomfortable for me
to read but regardless i think we have
seen in terms of erratic behavior uh
much of the
psychological and the physical
uh maltreatment uh we talked about
objection beyond the scope of the
question
i don't agree
next question okay
mr dip is 58 years old are the behaviors
that you have been describing for the
jury are those typical uh and
age-related
no so
while i don't consider 58 years old i'm
59 okay i will tell you that the
age-related changes that occur in humans
are very they're very um erratic hit and
miss
meaning they'll occasionally bear it be
there you may need a little bit more
time to answer question or pull things
out of memory just you're just a little
bit slower and a lot more inconsistently
slow
um you wouldn't describe what
dr blasey's changes were or what i saw
on the deposition attribute to age
dr spiegel what is sierra quail
cerebral or occupation is and actually
an atypical antipsychotic
which is indicated for many things
including schizophrenia bipolar disorder
adjunctive treatment for major
depression so it's indicated for a lot
of things
and but what what uh
what effects may it happen this is this
is one of the drugs that that mr depp
was taking correct it was a prescribed
drug yes okay
so
what yeah please explain the effect of
cerebrals is is it's very often used as
a sleeping agent
uh because it doesn't have a lot of the
side effects that are associated with
conventional antipsychotics movement
disorders higher dyskinesia et cetera at
least it's a very low risk for that
so
people have used it off label physicians
have used it off label
to help them sleep
the problem is
the effect is very barbiturate-like
and it really knocks people
out or certainly if you use it at high
enough doses it can
okay
and the problem is the problem is it
also has street value
so it's absolutely used on the street
for that down or like effect and
obviously it's a little bit more readily
available because it's prescribed
so it so it does have that street value
portion of it
and dr
spiegel what effect would this have on
mr depp based on the dosages he was
taking
so
i think what you're looking at
is uh objection speculation
please continue
what you will see in patients who have
substance use disorders
are people who unfortunately
kind of wake up and fall asleep only
through pharmacological assistance
meaning that their own circadian rhythms
are no longer in control
of that behavior so you will take
stimulants to quote unquote get you up
in the morning and then you will take
things like quetiaphy and cerakwell
to knock you out
so basically what these are being used
for is
i'm going to get up
and i'm going gonna get knocked out and
that's very characteristic of what would
be
actually
legal prescribed substances
that's not illegal at all that's very
legal um and that's the seemingly these
what these medicines affect our
on patient substance use disorder
dr speaker what is neurotin
so neuronal gabapentin
uh is actually an anti-seizure medicine
which it's i think is
it's indicated for seizures and it might
be indicated for one chronic pain
condition although i can't swear that to
you
that said that said again in a substance
use disorder population
it has significant street value and
people who misuse opiates
often
supplement that with neuron because it
has this anti-pain
calming effect
so unfortunately it also can cause
respiratory suppression and so when you
use it with opiates they're very there
are people that are lucky enough to
succumb to respiratory suppression as a
result but it has a very
additive calming
effect that people use it for
and what effect would this have on mr
depp in the dosage he was taking
again for an objection okay again
what it would do
is have the street value of using it
with
the opiates the advantages you're using
with opiates
and it's making because opiates in
general despite everything else it does
are common
and you use it with it it offers further
calming which is why
doctors have been warned not to
prescribe
medications like gabpen
and opiates together
unless under significant strict
following because it can cause serious
problems
such as death
respiratory suppression and mr depp was
also taking adderall correct yes can you
please describe to the jury what that
impact would happen particularly in
connection with the dosages so
adderall
is a psychostimulant which is prescribed
relatively regularly for
adhd
um
the problem comes again
when you're
you you
shouldn't be prescribing or receiving
adderall when you're already using
misusing cocaine
okay you're now doubling your stimulant
dosage here and basically what you are
talking about again it comes down to in
the substance use disorder population
you are using it to stay awake have
energy keep yourself going
getting high getting energetic and then
the only way to kind of combat that
because you have this effect is to kind
of
take cut down as during the day and down
as being anything that's calming so
anywhere from opiates prescription
anywhere from new rotten anywhere from
cerakwell all medications that are
potentially not potential which aren't
usable
and so
that's what this is going on that's what
the substance use disorder patient has
and you you know it can't be given with
someone using cocaine because that's
extreme risk for for death it can't be
given together
and what if any effect would these drugs
have if they were mixed with mdma or
cocaine
so when you combine the two together
like i talked about before
there are
effects where you are looking at
right the the predisposing traits of
intimate partner violence
so jealousy
rapid mood changes
poor self-control
and to some degree at to some degree
condoning violence to a certain degree
when you combine them all together you
get this disinhibiting euphorian effect
from
cocaine and adderall then when you
combine the two together what happens
you get too much and then you start
getting irritable
you start getting agitated
okay you start becoming suspicious
jealous
potentially
disinhibited
psychotic
and
these are the risks and again we're
talking about not your average everyday
use of these substances we are talking
about chronic use
together
and we also know
that alcohol and cocaine use
independently
increased significantly the risk of
intimate partner violence these aren't
statistics i'm coming up with they all
depend anywhere reports up to seven to
27 fold
so
you are
quote-unquote colloquially playing with
fire when you are talking about
substances and intimate partner violence
you are playing with fire
and that's all of us
and the substances that mr depp was
taking and the record evidence relating
to those
did you draw any conclusions concerning
uh whether he met these this criteria or
these risk factors
so
in terms of substitute disorder when you
when you look at it
so major role obligations not being
fulfilled
don't have any evidence about operating
under the influence or not
uh social issues especially
disagreements and arguments with your
spouse or family
obviously there was tolerance
independent for the amount he was using
because if anyone is naive to this these
medications
most of us will be dead
uh
unsuccessful efforts difficulty cutting
back
using more than intended
giving up social uh occupational
obligations because this i know it was
part of enjoy words right after the
rehab on the island in australia when we
mr deb went out partly with marilyn
manson
um objection beyond the scope of the
question
actually so it's asking for the record
evidence
next question um
okay what other record evidence did you
have supporting um
so
uh psychological using despite the fact
you know what causes known psychological
psychiatric or medical effects and i
think that's been pretty well documented
so in this case you're talking about
someone who has a severe
substance use disorder i do want to
emphasize uh let it down to the jury
that intimate partner violence and
substance disorders are two scourges in
this country
there are two plagues
this is very serious stuff we're playing
with and when you are just getting
someone closer and closer to the
threshold objection your honor
relevance
this is highly relevant
i'll overrule us to relevance beyond the
scope go ahead
yeah scope of the question yes i'll
sustain that objection all right um
tell me more about the relationships
between substance abuse and ipv please
yeah so again that you are talking about
this and you are
you may be able to control the risk
factors for it any of us
may be able to control the risk factors
for ipv any of us might be able to okay
when we're thinking and we're not
disinhibited
not having these hyper intense emotions
from substances
once you add that to this mix
your brain can no longer do what it's
supposed to do and it's supposed to
prevent you
from doing this
quite frankly because it's wrong
did you arrive at any conclusions
concerning substance abuse and potential
self-harm that may have led to mr depp
injuring his finger
so
i think the physician uh before we uh
explained that pretty well but i'll tell
you that mr depp has a history of
self-injurious behavior
meaning cutting himself mr depp has a
history of burning himself
i know
when the actual event happened
there was uh texting to dr kipper
paraphrasing not saying exactly that
amber and him got into a disagreement
related to
her wanting him to be sober and then as
a result of that he said he got so angry
he uh he cut the tip of his finger off
so if you're asking me can someone who
has or have i seen and can someone who
cuts themselves burns themselves can cut
a tip of their finger off
with or without alcohol or cocaine or
the rest the answer is objection beyond
the scope of the question exact exactly
thank you
please continue the world it was
overbought go ahead um
so
that that is not a very far jump i've
certainly seen patients do a lot worse
than that who started out with similar
risk factors of you know burning self
and cutting so i'm not going to get into
the descriptions but i've it has seen
people do a lot worse than that okay so
the answer is yes okay i'm going to turn
now specifically to intimate partner
violence and i know you've you've talked
certainly about it
but can you tell the jury please
a little bit more about intimate partner
violence and and what is included in
that
so
uh the apa task force on violence in the
family
defined
more or less this topic of domestic
abuse intimate partner violence as
recurrent abusive behavior
by means of psychological
sexual
or physical maltreatment
for the purpose of achieving control
or maintaining power
authority and control
can it include threats and intimidation
includes so in the part of psychological
abuse which is done essentially as a
means of emotionally and mentally
hurting someone but with the same end
goal to achieve control
it can be
destroying property
it could be financial which is part of
that
verbal abuse verbal outbursts i'm sorry
um
threats intimidation
body language
all of that goes under the concept of
psychological abuse and you may be able
to divide it the verbal non-verbal
what's exactly emotional versus verbal
but they're all under that rubric and
they're all under the guise of
maintaining control
do survivors of intimate partner
violence experience mental health issues
can you repeat the question do survivors
of intimate partner violence experience
mental health issues oh yes oh yeah so
survivors of intimate partner violence
and by the way i should start out by
saying
we don't expect in psychiatry we don't
expect our victims to be perfect we
don't expect our victims to be unscathed
by what they've received
so starting with that okay it is not
unusual as survivors
to see substance use substance abuse
substitute symptoms chronic depression
post traumatic stress disorder or
subsyndrome what some syndrome
post-traumatic stress disorder along the
lives of battery-wise syndrome
and some emotional unpredictability
that's and again you are a victim here
you are a victim
do perpetrators typically seek treatment
or counseling
no
perpetrators are
are not receiving
counseling uh treatment one because
they're going to be probably having to
tell someone
that they actually struck someone which
is what their thought is about the big
problem that intimate of violence is
just hitting again important but not the
sole part of it so perpetrators very
rarely
will go into any type of formal counsel
victims
go into counseling victims are seeking
actually couples counseling victims are
seeking couples advice to try to repair
what's happening
okay but in terms of actual
perpetrators
no they don't do that
in your review of this case is there
record evidence of physical violence by
mr depp
so objection
no foundation do you want approaching
what have you reviewed
that correlates
with
the risk factors for ipv
that mr
related to mr depp
so risk factor i reviewed that carly uh
so starting
uh with the i guess we'll start with the
physical because that was the question
that was put out there what i have
reviewed
has demonstrated uh
pushing
shoving
uh crap objection
let me let me see if i can direct this a
little differently dr spiegel
um
rather than giving the summary of what
that was what did you review that
correlates in other words
did you review
witness statements did you review
depositions
photos yes so what i reviewed was in
terms of
witness statements
dr kipper's
notes
very very interestingly actually early
on in the in i think it was 2012 around
that time circa 2012 2014
uh miss heard was uh beyond the scope of
the question
what he reviewed is the question
all right let's uh let's see so i viewed
just
so
ms herds
objection there's no question pending if
he's he's answering go ahead and answer
what you reviewed please continue with
what you reviewed therapists notes
counselors notes
text messages
depositions
video
pictures
psychologists
notes
and evaluations
uh and
i said physicians
notes that's what i reviewed all right
now you've indicated that uh intimate
partner violence includes physical
violence sexual abuse and psychological
aggression can you please describe for
the jury
what psychological aggression is and
what it entails
so
it says psychological aggression
would be
the
engaging in behavior for the sole
purpose of emotionally
and or mentally
harming someone
with
the main purpose of again to maintaining
control so behaviors that can occur
with psychological aggression include
uh insults
intimidation
um
by holding things financially against
someone
um
jealousy rants
property destruction
so all that
is involved
a non-verbal communication so
threatening looks glances things like
that
all that is involved in psychological
maltreatment and intimate partner
violence
what if any uh
what if anything would be psychological
aggression if it was trying to control
somebody's career would that be a factor
section
so yeah i'm trying to trying to control
someone clear that would be under
financial
the trying to uh to
mistreat someone
especially you know someone wants to
succeed
and try and have a career and you're
preventing them from doing so by
maltreatment that's another example
okay
so i'm going to ask specifically about
the risk factors for intimate partner
violence is substance abuse a risk
factor for intimate partner violence
yes it is a risk factor as well as a
precipitating cause
and
what
uh record evidence did you review that
correlates to mr depp engaging in
substance abuse
so
the record evidence of
i'll just start with dr kipper
and the the substances that mr depp
was using and misusing both in terms of
prescribed and on urine drug screen were
uh brought out through that
okay uh is lack of behavioral control
and impulsiveness
risk factors for intimate partner
violence yes they are okay
um and
what if any uh record evidence were you
aware of that mr depp
had lack exhibited lack of behavioral
control and impulsiveness
again
threatening
objection
record evidence
that correlates with and i'm on the risk
factors at this point thank you your
honor
threatening
destroying furniture property
breaking things
writings on
walls
mirrors
writing in blood and furniture
all that would be go with that
okay
all right
um
and
what if any
risk factor is narcissism for intimate
partner violence
so
a patient before we get into
narcissistic personality traits or
disorder the overall let's categorize
under what's called cluster b
personality objection beyond the scope
of the question he's explaining the
narcissism
i'll sustain the objection okay
can you explain to the jury what's
involved with narcissism as it relates
to the risk factors of intimate partner
violence and what that realm is
so narcissism patients have again poor
self-control
okay
rapid mood shifts
okay
as a result they they have an undue
sense of admiration
they worship power the worship control
um
they are they have lack of empathy and
people are generally kept around as long
as they're useful to them um a a
large sense of entitlement
um
anything else uh
do you need around need for need for
praise
so that would go under narcissistic
personality and ipv
what if any uh
uh require what if any traits would be
requiring admiration would that fit into
it
yeah oh yes i'm requiring admiration
need to be admires part and parcel of uh
narcissistic personality disorder
would would be an envious fit within
that yes
fragile self-esteem yes
and
what if any record evidence do you have
that correlates with mr
depp
being narcissistic
well i do think
that
the
fact that he thought that amber owed him
misheard objection your honor
thank you go ahead
the fact that miss heard
owed him and only wanted to be together
with him
because of his
fame uh is an example of that
i do think the jealousy aspects
are
an example of that
i do think you know uh as i think mr uh
mr tillett had testified that you know
being admired is one thing but then
behind your back saying something else
about people
is another thing
um
and i can probably say with a reasonable
certainty that
to some degree this whole trial
is that the objection your honor
what's the objection
that's not record evidence
speculation please continue
that this whole trial in terms of
narcissism narcissistic insult is what's
going on
i believe that uh mr depp was very much
a mainstay appropriately in in hollywood
and then this was pulled the wrong
without objection your honor can we he's
able to explain why he sustained that
objection
um
can you explain what you mean by this
whole trial
this procedure
there's an objection
well what other
conduct is in the record evidence that
correlates with mr
depp having being narcissistic having
those traits
was the thing about the trial rule i
can't explain right now you're not
allowed to say not say that okay
um
the the uh the only other thing about
narcissism i think in terms of trial
would be in order to
maintain any sense of control
a narcissistic person
really has to have lack of empathy
because in order to engage in behaviors
that quote unquote are used to keep
individuals in control
you don't really think about the other
person you're not really caring what
happens to that other person so i think
that's
another facet
so
are attitudes accepting or justifying
intimate partner violence a risk factor
for intimate partner violence
yes
um
do some perpetrators and intimate
partner violence try to minimize
the ipv
yes so
it is unfortunately not uncommon
especially during
especially during the calm phases of the
abuse cycle where there is no increased
tension there is no acting out
okay you are talking about more of the
honeymoon
apologetic phase
begging for forgiveness
telling them how you're going to change
maybe giving them gifts
and then when
the dust settles
later in the day a day or two later it
is not uncommon for the perpetrator to
kind of switch the blame over
to the victim
saying that hey
you know this either denial this never
actually happened and tried to make me
look bad
or an allopathic defense where
you instigated it or an altruistic
effect where i'm doing it for you
transformative effect that society kind
of accepts this so it is very uncommon
for all of a sudden
for that to start shifting during that
time
because it is during the calm phase and
everything is is relatively calm this of
course is when the victim wants to
engage in
in treatment but beyond that
uh the ability to kind of quote unquote
for lack of a better phrase when people
over
family
friends
the law i mean the very ability to do
that is part and parcel of that calm
charming
phase where it looks like the victim
is
you know just fabricating this
okay
and is victim blaming
uh a characteristic yes like i said i
made you blame the victim that one of
the defenses are the allopathic uh
defense uh comes along with victim
blaming that's what the sense you're
doing i'm blaming you
for what you made me do
okay and
is there record evidence that you
reviewed that correlates with mr depp
engaging in this type of behavior
so
i
i think for a lot of the
issues seen
the big precipitant
was going to be
the need for sobriety coming again
coming back to that severe
subjection unresponsive
i think he's trying to explain it thank
you please continue
this severe
substance use disorder
and
many
of their arguments but what i reviewed
in the record
stemmed around ms hearn's desire for mr
depp
to maintain sobriety
and
that what was happened so as a result
she was blamed
for
you know bothering him
in a way he didn't want to be bothered
and
that triggered what was going on
are you familiar with the term gas
lighting
um
i'm from blue trim gas light okay what
if any gas lighting
is
consistent with intimate partner
violence and the risk factors
so again when you start being able to be
when a
person starts to be able to be
manipulative and charming you start to
be able to win people over and
especially when you see someone who's a
victim who is essentially vulnerable
emotionally
emotionally
labile okay you see that person and then
you see this calm demeanor in front of
you who's very charming very engaging
very personable and then
all of a sudden it starts looking like
the victim is just a a i was
essentially losing it
and
i either make their being gaslighted
is there examples where an intimate
partner
violent perpetrator
claims that the victim is the person
who's actually
committing the abuse
yeah oh yes oh yes how common is that
that's very common again that's part of
the that's very common in the occurrence
of the like if the the
honeymoon phase
and the calm period of the abuse cycle
very common during that time where the
victim whether they're shifting the
blame or
anything along that line that's very
calm for that to happen and you
indicated that you reviewed some audio
tapes in this case correct yes and what
if any evidence did you review there
that correlates with mr depp
attempting to claim that amber was the
one
well i think that was what was said that
amber uh was the abusive objection your
honor
i don't understand the objection
what record evidence
thank you please please continue
so that claiming that amber was uh the
abuser in this particular scenario
and what
what i will reiterate again is that
one victims aren't perfect and two it is
not uncommon
in the context of being a victim
when you know that person is about to
proceed or relapsing to a substance or
going to a substance
and anticipating what's going to happen
that you anticipate the next mood and
start initiating self-defense
but
by and large
that's not what's going on here
by and large
mr deb
behavior objection your honor this
behavior was consistent objection sir
i'm sorry i'll sustain the objection
okay
all right we get we can move on to the
next one is prior victimhood of abuse a
risk factor for intimate partner
violence yes
and
so go ahead there is something known as
intergenerational theory of violence
which is basically along the line of
uh observation
imitation reinforcement so you observe a
behavior that occurred in childhood you
imitate it when you see that there's no
significant negative consequences but
you do get the positive consequence of
maintaining control
of a situation solving the conflict in
your way if you would
so
that theory is
interestingly it's it's it applies to
not only the
victims i'm sorry not all the
perpetrators but also the victims
because there are many victims who grow
up in a house of
abuse
that
are not abused but they're the victims
of abuse
what are the warning signs of intimate
partner violence
so
warning signs would be
increasing
the tension
escalations of tension so that's when
you start seeing
hey
partners getting angry
okay starting to starting to break down
the communication
starting to engage in verbal
nonverbal threats
victim concedes due to this tension
and that leads you to the actual act so
these acts are progressively build
and then
they occur
what if anything
have you seen an intimate partner
violence about apologies and promises
so again the apology is part and parcel
of the honeymoon phase and promises a
part and parcel of the honeymoon phase
and
you know the victim
wants to believe it's going to work they
want to believe their spouse is going to
be
faithful to this
and as part of the abuse cycle
um it ends up the as i should say in the
calming cycle like i said the victim
tries to get some help
to try to resolve this
until
the tension build-up phase where
something bothers them so again it could
be
bothering someone about
substance abuse it can be bothering
someone about finance it could be
bothered something about your career
anything is liable to build up tension
when you have this framework of limited
self-control and erratic
intense
mooches
what if any record evidence did you
review that reflected mr depp engaging
in these warning signs including the
apologies and the promises
i think it's that was almost routine
that after was all said and done
that he would apologize uh for
letting this monster out
letting this anger out
almost routinely
um and there's very well record evidence
of that
starting as
early early on the marriage uh in in one
of in therapy from his herd so um
that's that's
very common and very much occur
recognizing what happened
and the other part of this is
again
when you can recognize that when you're
sober
even short-lived sobriety when you could
recognize that
that things are better
things are happening better life is
better
then
even that should show you
that hey
there's an issue here there are issues
here
that when i don't use
could be resolved
thank you dr spiegel i'm going to now
move to the goldwater rule can you
explain the goldwater rule please
uh so the goldwater rule
is when senator goldwater was running
for presidency and i i'm going to be
honest with you i think it was in the
late 60s when he was early 70s because i
was
too young to even follow politics then
so i please don't quote me on exactly
what it was
but basically what's happening is
clinicians psychiatrists were making
these quote unquote armchair diagnosis
from their
homes or offices because they saw this
person on tv
the way they acted and were asked to
comment about what they think their
diagnoses are
and therefore it was felt that that
should not be done by professionals in
these public settings
does it have any applicability here
no injection
why not
no foundation
he was explaining with the cold water
dr spiegel do you remember the question
does the goldwater rule have any
applicability
shared to your testimony and your
conclusions and opinions
uh no it does not and why multiple
reasons one
the basics of expert witness testimony
would almost be thrown away if you are
not allowed to base things on what you
evaluated of an individual what you've
read about an individual so if i'm not
allowed to comment on
records or
charts or information that i look that
expert witness testimony can't be done
but more specifically for this case
um
in the goldwater rule the pure version
of it was the armchair diagnosis of
watching someone on tv just you don't
make a diagnosis more recently i think
that's even more recent had examples of
that so you don't make diagnoses like
that um this is not the case here
because i i said to you at the beginning
i have reviewed
a lot of professional
a lot of professionals and their
evaluations and their treatment course
video deposition picture deposition
court filings
emails i mean i reviewed
a whole lot of things that directly
describe
uh mr depp and his behavior so i'm not
commenting on a public opinion and i
have absolutely no
knowledge of of uh what's in mr depp's
history um if i was just doing that it'd
be like watching a movie
that's not relevant here
and in fact i think you testified
earlier you invited mr depp too oh yes
forgiven again objectional eating
so
to to be fair
uh for and evaluate for my own direct
evaluation again i was offered twice
that i can do an evaluation of mr depp
directly and both times
mr depp and or his lawyers decided that
that was going to happen okay and and in
fact the court did not require mr depp
too and the court did not require mr
depp to undergo this evaluation okay
dr spiegel these opinions that you have
offered here do you hold them to within
a reasonable degree of medical and
psychiatric probability or certainty
absolutely thank you all right
cross-examination
thank you mr
sir i'm wayne dennison
we haven't met
but
let me ask you let's start with what you
finished with i'm sorry one more time
let's start with what you finished with
you understand that the court was twice
asked by miss herd's counsel
to order a medical exam
of mr depp and those motions were denied
well
i think the the
your team
told the court you didn't want to have
them and the court
ruled on it i don't think the court
proactively did it you kind of had a
motion to them right
no
when
miss
heard's lawyers moved for them
and asked for them and did not get them
isn't that right sir
if if you're saying that's what happened
my understanding of was that you all did
not want him to undergo one they
petitioned for it the court said no yes
that's what my understanding was the
court said no to ordering mr deb to do
the medical exam
i said the court did not require it
right and there was one that was ordered
in fact right
there was
all right
all right so
the last thing you talked about
uh
was the goldwater rule
yes sir
been around for almost 50 years right
uh yeah i'm 59 that sounds about right
yeah
and it's been around as a result of a
presidential election that you
referenced yes
and
who has that rule
what organization uh maintains that rule
the american psychiatric association
an association you're a member of
associated not a member of yes
aren't you a fellow or something yes i
am okay so
and this is an ethical rule right
it is an ethical rule
yes it's ethical they say rules it's an
ethical guideline yes they're guidelines
and
you know that over time
the
american psychiatric association has
amended the rule so it's not just about
diagnoses but it's also about
professional opinions
could you be more specifically say about
professional opinion in regard to what
well
let me
let me read this and see if you're
familiar with it
it is unethical for a psychiatrist to
offer a professional opinion
about an individual
based on publicly available information
without conducting an examination that's
the rule right
if you're reading it directly i will
believe you okay
however a diagnosis is not required for
an opinion to be professional so my
question is
it's not just diagnosis that this
goldwater rule applies to its
professional opinions
so again i'll reiterate that that would
come down to essentially nullifying
witness testimony
expert witness testimony without
direct evaluation
and as we know it didn't happen but
regardless of that the whole expert
witness testimony thing would be
basically
rendered no bullet null and boy
the rule in fact contemplates
that issue doesn't it sir
again i'm just telling you the answer to
the question when you're reading me
those statements i'm telling you the
response by the other side who is
publishes also
is that
if that was the case there could be no
expert witness testimony in the
courtroom
psychiatrists are ethically prohibited
from evaluating individuals
without permit without permission
or
other authorization
such as a court order that's the rule
right
again if you're reading that then i have
to believe you're not misrepresenting it
and i would come back to you again then
this whole thing on effort we might as
well get rid of all the expert witnesses
we've had throughout all of time for
court proceedings because that you're
saying is unless a court orders it and
that's what you just said or the ap said
then therefore expert witnesses cannot
do an evaluation based on an observation
of the medical records insurance
companies cannot do evaluations solely
based on meta-record with our doctors
rendering professional opinions so at
the end of the day you are essentially
saying that unless someone has directly
evaluated it there this whole medical
system we have this whole legal system
we have is null and void i'm not saying
no yes you are sir i know you are give
me a give me a second and i'll give you
more than a second
what what i'm
saying and what i am reading to you
is a rule
by your organization
that
takes into account
that there could be court orders that
would permit the the exact kind of
evaluation that you say i'm eliminating
and i think we're going in circles
because i think i just said that means
expert witness testimony
would not be allowed and the branch of
forensic psychiatry would be especially
hindered and we know the branch of
friend sakai does not prohibit that so
i am a member of the apa that doesn't
necessarily mean every single thing they
put in there everybody has to
uncategorically agree with because
clearly that's not the case did you
agree in your deposition that the
the professional opinions you you
rendered were
uh
inconsistent with the goldwater rule
yeah
my friend because in because if we're
saying
that i if the global rule says and i
very much said that during deposition
that the goldwater rule was made for
presidents
and public figures such as that but
regardless of that because that's what
it was made for it's not made for
hollywood but i'll even take that mr
depp's a public figure
what i'm saying to you is that the gold
world rules say we cannot do any expert
witness testimony in our field that is
exactly what the goldwater rule is
saying based on exactly what you read
and i'm just telling you
what you are saying that rule
encompasses
what i'm asking you sir
is did you
comply with the ethical requirements of
the apa when ref when rendering the
professional opinions that you've
rendered today it is ag it is a
requirement of the ap is not the
requirement of the apa
secondarily
secondarily secondarily secondarily
again
in order to not
you we we waste our whole morning
because there was an expert witness
before me as an expert witnesses
everyone brought in so all i'm saying to
you that means the whole field
of medical legal law is corrupt and
unethical for engaging in an act that
the apa clearly says we should not do so
if you're saying that then the answer is
yes i'm agreeing with that statement
you're agreeing that the apa would deem
your
testimony and your professional opinions
rendered unethical
again i am saying you are saying that
the whole i'm an expert witness i am
saying as an expert witness
and solely as an expert witness
that guideline is permitting that from
occurring
i would say then that the whole field of
expert witness testimony again would be
disavowed
by what you are courting in the gold
order and we know that's not the case
because if it was we would not be
allowed to do it and you said the rule
was for presidents right that was
initially used yes
but and the name of the rule came from
that
but the rule says it is unethical for a
psychiatrist to offer a professional
opinion about an individual
that's right sir it's not just
presidents it's not public figures it's
individuals
funny it was named after according to
your logic if you don't put something in
the title it's not true that's what you
told me this morning i believe about my
intimate partner violence so what i
would say to you then
sir
is that
if you say this about an individual
again
any court would have to render an expert
witness testimony invalid any
doctor that reviews charts would have to
render it invalid i can go on the list
of docs that do not see or interview
patients directly and that's a violation
so basically you are saying that unless
you do a direct clinical evaluation then
all of the field of forensic psychiatry
and all of uh managed care
is doing an unethical violation because
we are not seeing the presence we deny
patients medications all the time
without seeing them we deny patients
treatments unfortunately without seeing
them and i'm on the receiving end of
that so the answer question again unless
you were saying to me that all of this
is unethical which is what you are
saying this is what you are this is how
i'm interpreting what you are saying to
me that unless you do the evaluation
directly yourself
therefore it could not be considered
ethical and i'm telling you how that
applicable to not just expert law but
also managed care and applicable to
multiple brands of medicine hospital
duration of hospitalization stay they
get evaluated so
tell me tell me where you want me to end
this
well
why don't we why don't we
why don't we talk about
what you just testified to because i
didn't ask you anything about that i
asked you whether under this rubric
under this principle of medical ethics
have you acted unethically yes or no
no as an expert witness i have not acted
unethically and if you want the jury to
believe that expert witnesses are
unethical then i guess that's for them
well
yes for them to decide no let's go to
the next question okay
right
psychiatric diagnosis occurs in the
context of an evaluation based on
thorough history taking
examination
and where applicable correlated
or collateral information
you'll agree with that i believe i said
that earlier yes
and it's a departure from the method
from the methods of the profession to
render an opinion without an examination
and without conducting an evaluation in
accordance with the standards of
psychiatric practice incorrect well
again by the way for the record intimate
partner violence is not a psychiatric
diagnosis i'll start with that
substance usage by themselves is not a
psychiatric diagnose if you want to cut
to the chase so i use not a diagnosis of
that
narcissistic personality traits is not a
diagnosis
ergo i am basically commenting on the
things that were brought to me which are
not diagnosis but but an evaluation if i
was going to treat a patient or anyone
here
those are the steps i would take
we
i think started with the notion that
this rule applies broader than diagnosis
it
applies to professional opinions i
believe
professional opinions relate relative to
narcissistic personality traits haven't
you served relative to mr deb again i
believe you just commented on what it
takes to do a psychiatric evaluation to
establish a diagnosis i'm almost certain
that's what you said and maybe i'm wrong
maybe you didn't say that but i'm sure
you did and therefore what i'm saying is
neither ipv nor substance usage nor
narcissistic personality traits a
psychiatric diagnosis and then under the
rubric of expert witness testimony you
are saying i acted unethically on the
rubric of expert witness testimony so if
you so would like to proceed that expert
witnesses are unethical based on that i
am not going to sit here and disagree
with you and waste everyone time i think
it's fairly obvious but thank you i'll
go ahead
these were your words i'm just saying
back how they're interpreted
okay
let's start with the easy question then
maybe we can i was pretty easy go ahead
all right doctor you're going to have to
just answer the questions okay sorry
about that
you you need to just answer the question
you are not rendering any diagnosis
whatsoever
of mr depp
today or ever
no i probably would say to you that
certainly i would not say narcissistic
personality traits
certainly from what i have read intimate
partner violence not a diagnosis so the
answer is no for that
personality trace is not a diagnosis the
answer is no but if you want to tell me
that substance use disorder
is a psychiatric diagnosis
the answer is
yes and i but that wasn't an issue was
it whether mr
mr depp used substances
i mean you said you've gone through the
record that that wasn't really an issue
at this trial he's said it from day one
i should say he's already admitted to
the diagnosis he's already admitted to
the use of the substances well again
there's different admitting to substance
use and substance use disorder let's go
back to uh what you just said about
narcissistic personality traits yes
narcissistic personality disorder
is a dsm-5
diagnosis correct correct
diagnosis
diagnostic personality and you haven't
testified that mr depp has
um
narcissistic personality disorder have
you
i would certainly if i didn't i'm
certainly thinking that but at least i'm
going to say he has traits which are
characteristics of provisional diagnosis
of it's a provisional diagnosis probably
narcissistic person but yeah i mean i do
believe that well when you say
provisional diagnosis you know the dsm-5
requires
in order to find that diagnosis
five of the nine factors
and you haven't done that analysis
you've never made that diagnosis
you've just identified certain factors
that are criteria for the diagnosis
right but you need five of nine to get
to the diagnosis you've you've already
told us that you didn't make a diagnosis
you're just i
identifying traits correct
i'm identifying traits that are
consistent with the diagnosis yes right
and
did you testify in deposition
that the existence of traits as opposed
to the disorder
doesn't have a correlation
with
ipv
uh i if i said traits do not have a
correlation with the j that's what i
said i don't remember saying that but
that wouldn't be a correct thing
narcissism has a correlation with the
diagnosis yes that part's true how far
are we going to back this up because
there's a diagnosis of narcissistic
personality disorder right yes sir and
that one is type
it has some correlation with ipv right
narcissism has correlation with ip again
you sir i'm you're not allowed to answer
i'm you're splitting hairs you're
splitting hairs between the traits that
are consistent with which all i'm
commenting on is behaviors and traits
that are consistent with the diagnosis
and mr death
narcissism absolutely has
uh risk factors associated with ipv
let's go back again
and maybe we can
we can focus on the question i ask you
and we can get an answer that's
addressed to that question
narcissistic personality disorder
is a risk factor for ipv yes or no yes
and you've previously testified there
that there is no
literature at which you are currently
aware that the mere presence of
narcissistic traits is a risk factor for
ipv
am i answering the question yes that's
incorrect cluster testified a cluster
cluster b traits
which narcissistic personality sword is
part of
is a huge risk factor for intimate
partner violence which include
cluster b traits include narcissistic
personality disorder anti-social
personnel disorder amongst others so the
answer to the question is
every every
resource on intimate partner violence
will
support
that cluster b traits
where narcissistic personality falls
under is a risk factor for intimate
partner violence any single trait
under
is a risk factor for ipv
again i will repeat
cluster b
traits
i didn't say any trait i said cluster no
let me be more precise then okay
any
narcissistic trait
in and of itself
is a risk factor
for ipv
but you are miscounterize what i said
what i said i i'm pretty sure i said
cluster if you look at all the intimate
partner violence literature i would
behoove you to do so you will see that
cluster
b
traits
specif i didn't say narcissistic per se
cluster b traits
where narcissistic personnel disorder is
part of
are risk factors for intimate partner
violence part impartial uniformly true
and i'm not sure the thing i don't
understand is i'm not sure why we're
arguing psychiatry because i'm telling
you what it is dr siegel you just need
to answer the questions okay
so you want to talk about
cluster b so let's do that for a minute
borderline personality disorder
is a risk fact factor
for ipv
as part of cluster betrayed yes
histrionic personality disorder
is a risk factor for ipv
less so
but it less so
lesson
is a risk value but less so yes less
significantly less so all right
so
which traits
under narcissistic oh
before i move on there there's only been
one diagnosis
in court
of personality disorders correct
i'm not and so who you're referring to
are you referring to mr depp miss her
who i'm not sure what you were talking
about do you understand that there was a
medical examination done of miss hurt
yes i did do you understand that the
testimony
was
ultimately that misheard suffers from
two personality disorders okay so i'm
just being specific i just wanted to
know if you talk about misheard or mr
depp so that was that's all i was asking
you
yes or no to my question which was
there's only one
diagnosis of
ms heard was diagnosed with that yeah
and both of the diagnoses
are in cluster b and both of them
are risk factors for ipv
but both those cluster b things are i'm
i'm not allowed to comment on the
testing so therefore all i could say is
that cluster b trace and i'll tell you
what they are and by the way i guess i
testified this before which was that
one i don't expect perfection for my
victims two
absolutely there are clusters
absolutely
given that you've testified to it before
let's move on to a new question okay
all right
you
indicated
in your opinion today that you thought
oh well why don't we
why don't we move a little are you a
member of the american medical
association no
okay so you don't know what the ethical
rule of the american medical association
is
relative to doing
clinical diagnoses about individuals
you've never talked to
so you're saying in terms of doing
expert witness evaluations
under that rubric right
i'm just asking you do you know the
ama's rule
under doing you're saying
ama's ruling under the rubric of not
doing that was something you did not see
and i'm i'm questioning i'm asking so
you are talking about expert witness
testimony no i'm talking about do you
know the rule i'm not a member of the
ama so okay
okay move on you don't know the rule
all right
you rendered an opinion about mr depp's
purported cognitive impairment
yes yeah
what to use as a baseline
a baseline for processing speed yeah for
for analyzing mr depp
before he watched his deposition
what is a baseline for that
i mean i guess my baseline would
probably be what i how i've seen him
interact
in public i have seen interact with
others i've seen him in direct in media
i see him in direct all and his process
speed is certainly not slow i've seen
him do commercials his process speed was
not slow
a deposition didn't just say that what
you did was compare
mr depp's performance
in
lots of pirate movies
against his deposition testimony
what i said was i've seen mr depp
do
apology ads i remember did a policy out
with bad dog with no delay in process
speed i've seen him interact with the
media regarding to that i saw no delay
in processing speed all i'm saying let
me ask you about pirates though you
compared pirates to the tech to to the
depositions given
then i apologize for what i said then i
misspoke you misspoke you didn't make
the comparison
right now just a second ago
just a second ago i i may have said that
i spoke i apologize i misspoke okay
because you know you can't compare
pirates to sworn testimony right
yes
okay
but you can but as an aside you can't
judge someone's processing speed
at any time like i'm judging yours right
now you're judging mine we all judge
processing speed as a baseline because
of what we know about each other i would
say your process speed right now is not
slow
so i mean we're judging processes i'm
just saying to you
yeah um
so but no any of mr depp's other
portrayals
in movies did that affect your analysis
of processing speed only i've seen him
interact
on interviews and that was it right when
he wasn't in movies right but willy
wonka doesn't matter to you
you see in that movie charlie chocolate
factory
did you look at that one when you were
comparing this processing speed
is
is that do i have to answer that
question
you have to answer questions yes sir no
you'll be happy no i didn't see willy
wonka as her at i didn't see 21 jump
street when it happened or it was about
no i did not
all right
you'll
you made a very kind admission i think
early on in your deposition
that you're not
claiming to be a better actor than mr
depp
that's correct isn't it
100
all right but with respect to acting
you know that actors actually
rehearse for their parts
and work on the language diction
timing of their dialogue as part of that
rehearsal
if you say that i'm not an actor so i
don't know what goes on i can't tell you
i have no idea what goes on in acting
okay but
you you don't know enough about acting
to know whether
actors rehearse
sir i am not an expert in acting i have
no idea what an actor does
okay
during your deposition
what were the circumstances under which
you decided to call mr depp an idiot
under somebody call me as a deputy idiot
yeah you called mr deaf an idiot in your
deposition well i think
okay so i think it was in the context i
think it was
probably should read the context of it
because i think the context was and i'm
trying to think back and i'm trying to
think back okay and what i thought it
was related to was if you're coming to
some deposition
okay and again i'm thinking back so i
you have it in front of you
i don't so i'm thinking back where he's
coming in from
europe for a deposition
uh video deposition that he gave and
he took it overnight the night before
and what i think i said was that if
you're going to take a
if you're going to do a major thing
toward a trial that you're involved with
i think you'd be an idiot to come in the
night before
all right so i think coleman's a deaf
idiot i certainly call that planning and
he i didn't call him an idiot so the
words so i mean he's an idiot are
mistranscribed
no i'm sure again if i said it in that
time if you just read one line one
snippet i'm sure was in the context i
just said but again you have it in front
of you i don't yeah um
is uh
idiot a professional opinion i wasn't
writing professional opinion yeah is it
a psychiatric opinion
and that follows the goldwater rule
how does it follow though i just said
that i'm not rendering a professional
opinion i just said idiot that's not uh
so idiot is not a professional opinion
is it your
practice to describe people as idiots
my practice described me in my practice
no i don't describe people clinical my
clinical cases these are patients as
idiots or victims as idiots no sir but
you set for a deposition in this case
and and describe the plaintiff as an
idiot correct uh you gave me nine hours
of deposition and if i said the word
idiot it was an idiot in planning it
wasn't making him an idiot i don't know
mr depp's iq i don't know his overall
functioning so therefore if i said it it
was an idiot in planning which is what i
meant to come across as all right so you
did say you don't know his overall
functioning but you made some testimony
today as to
some evaluations you made relative to is
functioning
you would agree with me
that it's
probably a good idea
to think about the questions that are
asked you in a court proceeding before
answering them am i allowed to answer
that question yes okay so
what i meant by function what i said by
function i believe that his agent
reported how late he was showing up to
every movie while the cast is waiting
for him i believe that would be an
impairment if i showed up late for that
i would not be here right now would not
have a job okay i believe the thing was
in terms of uh
barking out of treatment for substance
rehab that his doctor is prescribing for
him so if you're asking me if that's an
impairment of functioning i would say
i'm very much substantiated in that
i'm trying to understand how you got to
this notion of cognitive decline
and i thought it was based at least in
part on the man in which he testified
i'm sorry what on the manner in which he
testified on the manner i'm sorry i'm
sorry i'm not being difficult i can't
hear i'm sorry what
i was asking you about the cognitive
decline yes testimony that you made yes
and it was my understanding that at
least a portion of that testimony that
you rendered
was that
you
derived some evidence of cognitive
decline
from the way mr depp testified
yes
okay and that's what i said yes right
and so all i'm asking you is you
don't you think it's a good idea
when you're in the middle of a court
proceeding to answer questions carefully
again professionally we diagnose
patients with a neurocog disorder
by gross evaluation
all the time with cognitive and the
thought that again age normal controls
i'm just saying age normative controls
does not put a 58 year old gentleman at
that processing that's all i'm saying
right all i said and you derived this
without ever once talking to the man
you need me me directly talking to him
because i heard because we know how i
derived it so you're talking about me
directly talking to him yeah you never
talk no i never no i've never talked to
him right
and this
exam you gave
well you did talk about miss dr
blaustein right yes sir
and you understand that the entirety of
dr blaustein's
uh medical records are 12 pages of
handwritten notes
the important part was what i said
for me as an example of cognition which
i'm trying to prove which is what you
asked me the important part was what i
said
and that was
irrefutable
the important part is that he give
he gave the mini mental status exam
yes sir
all right let's talk about the mini
mental status exam
scored on a 30-point scale right yes
all right
and it's it's an exam that
basically
most often used for
what alzheimer's dementia those kind of
testing
it's an exam that tests cognition in all
psychiatric illnesses not just
alzheimer's it was made
for dementia for all times but as the
standard
has been the standard for testing
cognition in all psychiatric illness
substance use disorders included
okay
now
there is an element of that
exam
that requires
drawing correct yes so
you don't know what drawing mr depp did
or whether the drawing should have been
fully scored i wasn't questioning his
visual spatial perceptual skills which
is what that does right
and you don't
know
what score mr depp received
on the exam i was very specific i know
three words not remembering at five
minutes that's all i said
three words not remembering five minutes
and he remembered one of them right
from what i'm saying you remember any of
them
all right
memory on the exam
out of the 30 points what's it worth
three three
three right
memory is three out of those thirty
yeah memory is three okay again the
memory section in and of itself tests
memory
that's the only question that test
memory only section that actually tests
memory so the memory section tests
memory it's the only section you
testified about and for all you know
that with respect to the exam that
you're relying on mr depp scored 27 out
of 30.
and that would be telling though
cognitive if you scored 27 and 30 and
you missed three points on memory that
would be very telling you don't know if
mr depp had been up all night the night
before
again you wouldn't expect to not recall
any words at three minutes
unless there's a cognitive issue you
don't know if mr depp was high
and again oh now that's again that that
could affect memory but i'm not i'm not
refuting that i'm not refuting that at
all he could have been high could have
been
drunk he could have been using cocaine
and that would absolutely affect his
memory which is what i said yes you're
right
so ultimately you have no idea
what state mr depp was in
at the at the time he took the exam that
you're relying on
short of what you just said about drugs
and alcohol okay there shouldn't be a
reason why 58 year old also with strokes
and other neurocognitive conditions but
short of that there shouldn't be a
really good reason why someone at that
age shouldn't come up with at least one
but but an answer but wait a minute you
you started that question with short of
drugs and alcohol and spent 35 minutes
talking about his use of drugs and
alcohol
isn't that right
oh i'm a great what i i thought i agree
with you i think i agreed i said that
drugs and alcohol can absolutely affect
cognition i'm not
sure yeah i agree but i'm not sure if
that's a
problem i agree with you on that all
right so you don't know
one way or the other
how he scored on the exam you don't know
whether he was at the time on drugs and
alcohol
but you're going to rely on it
in your testimony to say that he's
cognitively impaired
which is what we do in clinical medicine
sir
okay
you rely on a test that you don't know
the when it was
administered
you don't know the score of
of the test and you don't know the state
of the person being tested but you're
going to rely on it anyway again if we
had to know every test
when people get the mini mental state
exam we have no idea clinically if they
are high
wasted stone
stroke we have no idea so if you're
going to say that that means everybody
needs a drug test before they do a
minimal study and that's not the
standard of care
and i think you know that so
let's talk a little bit
about this word you kept using
correlation
you know the word right
yes
correlation and causation aren't the
same thing are they sir
no they're not standing no how are they
different
correlation is consistent with causation
is direct link
can you say that again
so fast i didn't hear it i'm sorry about
that
correlation
is
a risk
for something happening
causation is a direct link
right
so
just because something's correlated
doesn't mean it's going to happen 100
right
lung cancer for instance smoking is
very highly correlated with lung cancer
right
yeah and certainly and there's certainly
a link right to lung cancer and smoking
right but but not all smokers get lung
kids
no no not all smokers do no one like i
said no one fits the curve perfectly
right
and
you've made repeated testimony and to to
all of us all of us do this all of us do
that
your
your suggestion about all of us is
you're just looking at the world as a
sample
and not at any particular individual
correct
what i'm looking at is
that
i'm not talking about an individual how
they can or cannot be resistant what i'm
saying is invariably when use substances
this is going to happen now is there a
0.05 percent chance that someone who
does
absolutely there is but is that medical
degree of certainty absolutely not
a 0.05 chance of what sir
of developing eventually developing
symptoms if you're using excessively
eventually you're going to develop
symptoms right
but risk factors tell us nothing about
any one particular individual do they
no
sir
weren't done again risk factors tell us
nothing except that they have it they're
at a higher likelihood of developing it
that's what tells them
but you did a whole litany of risk
factors relative to ipv
yes right and none of those risk factors
tell us anything specifically about an
individual
other right other than they're at higher
risk right right
um
so someone could have every single risk
factor for ipv
and never commit ipv right
it would be again if you're going to say
a medical degree or probability the
answer is they will but if you're saying
uniformly the answer is no
right
ipv can occur without substance abuse
oh sure
someone can abuse substances without
ever perpetrating ipv
again
absolutely but
again you are saying
different than what i said
i did not say abusing substances i said
substance use disorder
you aren't there so two different things
because there are surely people who use
substances that do not engage in any
violence not become psychotic nothing at
all so that's equally true of people who
have substance abuse disorder there are
certainly people
who
have substance abuse disorder
who don't commit ipv correct they are
saying people have substance use
disorders
the majority of them over 50 percent do
so open center so that's medicine
the answer is
yes
as you said not everyone who smokes gets
lung cancer
so
there are
significant numbers of people you you
said it was over 50 so so
you'd say 40 percent of the people who
have substitute substance abuse disorder
don't commit ipv
and those are the ones that do not have
ipv risk factors are right so we're told
by people
it isn't
substance abuse disorder and ipv risk
factors yeah these are other people that
have don't have other risk factors right
right
but again we're talking about people in
general you don't know anything about
any particular individual as to whether
anybody's going to commit ipv
if statistics follow through all we can
say is more than 50
70 will if you combine more risk factors
you have
the more likely you're going to develop
the illness if you smoke cigarettes once
that might not correlate to lung cancer
if you smoke it chronically
that might
so that's why we're talking about
individuals here you either have lung
cancer or you don't right
if you're smoking right right
you either commit ipv or you didn't
oh i mean yeah you either did it or
didn't yes right
so you
took some issue with me because i was
asking about substance abuse generally
and you wanted me to talk about the
the disorder
i'm
i asked you earlier about narcissistic
personality disorder and you you haven't
made that diagnosis you've just talked
about the traits right yes
and
anybody somebody can have
these narcissistic personality traits
and substance abuse disorder
and never commit ipv right
so along that line right about about
80 to 90 percent of people who commit
ipv
have a personality disorder so the
answer is less than about 10
obviously do not
there are more
close links with ipv
for borderline personality disorder than
narcissistic personality disorder
correct sir i'm
not going to agree with that no i'm not
saying there are more links i would say
to you there are absolute if you're
asking me there are links the answer is
absolutely if you're saying to me more i
can show studies say yes so study say
that that has not been absolutely
definitely correlated no
no absolutely not
mdma
what is it
uh
ecstasy
yeah
and
what's the normal dosage of ecstasy for
people who use ecstasy
again i couldn't tell you the
quote-unquote normal dose because
honestly speaking no one no one knows
what they're getting when they're using
it right it's not regulated so but
the effects of ecstasy
enhance sense of well-being
at
low doses
the answer is yes
i'm going to gather when you're using it
at higher doses and develop tolerance
you develop the sympathomimetic effects
which are not so enhanced well-being
increased extraversion
again at lower dose you are 100 right at
low amounts you are 100 right it is an
antaction we feel closer to people
that's what people who use it say they
feel close to people warmth to people uh
100
but with continual use and higher doses
it could be fatal
right
so that's not that's not well-being i
don't know if i call that well-being
so continued use at higher doses mdma
can be fatal
correct correct
what if you took eight to ten tablets of
empty mdma
if what if you took n h again you don't
know what it's it's very hard to say
that you don't know what it's uh uh uh
what's the worm look for
contaminated with
okay you can't just say hey let me just
take eight to ten pure ecstasy and see
what happens that's that's not gonna
happen so what i would say to you again
because substance of abuse are
unpredictable they are not regulated no
one knows what they're going to no one
apps has any idea whether it's going to
cause this empathic and tactogen effect
at very low doses
or is it going to cause the
sympathomimetic i'm sorry increase um
uh uh it's like a stimulant like cocaine
cell we talk about like that no one
knows what's going to happen it's not
regulated and no one knows if you're
using with other substances either
like
other stimulus
or if you mix it with alcohol or mix
with alcohol
no one knows if it's going to be
potentially worse
right but if this is a potentially
lethal combination eight to ten mdma
this is a this is a potentially toxic
combination can it kill you yeah i mean
it is a potentially toxic combination
that's true
ever heard of someone cutting off their
own finger on mdma
have i ever heard of it yeah uh no i can
only give you one example i hadn't seen
that one before oh
so
sarah quill
that one
put you to sleep right
uh if you want a phrase a barbiturate
putting you to sleep then the answer is
yes yeah you heard mr
mr depp talking about sometimes being on
the nod right
and again i think i i think i explained
sarah quell very well this morning
good i'm going to ask a few more
questions okay
okay
all right
you kept making references to street
value why were you doing that
because that's why people with substance
use disorder use quetiapine than
seroquel
that's why people who use quetiapeed and
or slash cerakwell
can get has it sells on the street
because it's so barbiturate-like in
effect right but you said that mr depp
had a prescription
there are many supplements used to sort
of patients who have prescriptions for
adderall and quatiopede from their
doctor and that doesn't mean they're not
getting high out of it that doesn't take
much doctors like to believe what
patients have to say they're not going
to go in there being uh expert witness
testimony all i'm telling you is that in
people who have substance disorder it is
not uncommon and the thought was
initially that because quatiopein was
not addicting that it's safe to give in
people with substance use disorders when
in fact we absolutely know it has three
values absolutely know that for a fact
right but my point about this is you
made it a bunch of testimony about
street value
but you knew at the time you made the
testimony that mr depp in fact
had a prescription he also had a
prescription for oxycodone and oxycodone
is that does that count
because that's also probably not a good
thing
it's just because you're a prescription
doesn't it
because i would agree with you it wasn't
a good thing just because you have
prescription doesn't mean you can't
abuse it no i'm not suggesting you
you're abusing it i'm just wondering why
your testimony was in any way tied to
street value when every single drug you
referenced mr depp had legally
again you can have prescription
substance abuse and we know that correct
i shouldn't be asking that we can have
prescription substance use disorders and
that's not uncommon if you look at the
opiate epidemic that we're living in
right now we can have that that's not an
uncommon thing
unfortunate but uncommon not uncommon
so sarah quill i think you described as
a sleeping agent when used off label
when i saw what
sleeping agent seroquel when used off
label when use of labels used i can be
useless yes right
so
mr depp's use of seroquel
could
account for some of the photos we saw in
this pic in in this trial where he's
asleep in a chair again what i would say
to you is that if you have a substance
use disorder
you are using it to be knocked out yes i
agree and i'm but i'm not sure at the
end of the day if she had vomiting over
you either i've never seen sarah well do
that
so when he was passed down the chair he
also vomited us over him i've never seen
cerebral do that ever
what
n is another one of the
drugs you testified about
that one's
also
uh
prescribed right
yes it is
and what's the prescription for that
what's it used for
and what's its indication or what's it
what's its indication i mean syndication
is for seizures it may have one pain
indication again i'm not a neurologist
so i can't tell you exactly if it does
but but it's chronically used off label
for pain it's used off label for anxiety
right
and what's its effect that's another
that's another one that'll put you to
sleep right
uh
well yeah i mean sure 100 right
and
you made reference to a picture
that
there's been testimony around the
around that picture that
mr depp fell asleep with
ice cream in his hand that's not
vomitous right i was told it was
vomitous okay
um
you talked about the fact that mr depp
uh
indicates that from time to time
he uses an earpiece
i was yeah i mean i i read that yes
okay um
did you
read the testimony of mr wyatt who told
you what was being pumped into that
earpiece yeah i mean if i if i remember
right i mean it was i think it was lines
right
no it was music
it was music not inclined yeah okay so
if
if mr depp was listening to music
rather than being fed his lines
does that change your opinion as to his
cognitive function
if he was never fed his lines through
the earpiece which i know he was
but read he was and that may have been
that example mr wyatt may have said that
it was music i guess the question is
were you having the music
during the during the actual talking of
your line is that what you're saying to
me
well you know if if you can do two
things at once that's a pretty high
cognitive function isn't it you know
it's very good point actually divided
attention is something humans have a lot
of trouble in so for instance we have
trouble driving and putting on the you
know using our uh cell phones and direct
so divided attention humans actually are
not very good at i'll put that out there
but mr in general not just mr deputy but
but mr depp is pretty good at acting you
you you acknowledge that early on
absolutely better than me so i know that
because you don't act in fact you don't
know about acting
you're right i have no idea about that
and you don't know
how prevalent the use of ear pieces are
in acting
again i i know nothing about acting
irrespective of the fact you know
nothing about acting you've testified
that mr depp's use of an earpiece is
somehow a cognitive deficit
so if i was giving a lecture and i was
fed my lines i would think there's a
cognitive deficit so i'm and maybe i'm
wrong i said maybe i could be wrong
maybe hollywood stars get
lines fed to them through earpieces all
the time and i i don't know
i that could be it sounded to me to be
unusual if you're doing a movie and you
don't know the lines but like you said
i'm just judging into what i do with
lectures and that would never happen
if you gave lectures you wouldn't use an
earpiece but you're not going to tell
anybody how to act
i'm sorry what was the question
i said if you gave lectures you wouldn't
use an earpiece but you're not telling
anybody how to act right i would not use
an earpiece during lectures right
but i again i don't know what the
standard for care of how standard is
hollywood is for that i have no idea
your use your testimony about the use of
an earpiece
as
maybe you were wrong
you're comfortable with the fact that
you may have made a mistake there
no because i think in the basis of what
i've read about it i'm comfortable that
i i don't believe that
actors are routinely given their entire
script through earpieces i find that
hard to believe
yeah but but not one word of evidence
that this ever happened i hear i guess
what i said i just said i find it hard
to believe i didn't say it i said i find
it hard to believe that's all i said oh
yeah but what you found hard to believe
sir was that every
every line of the script was was pumped
through an earpiece where did you ever
get the idea that ever that occurred
that's what i have been that's what i
read and the court review the court
evidence that's where i got it
and um
you know where whether marlon brando
used an earpiece
whether isn't he dead
yeah so the answer is no he does not use
one now oh no i i i use the past tense
oh i'm sorry uh i again i know nothing i
will concede to you i know nothing about
acting
i will concede to you 100
if that is the standard and people have
done that acting then i apologize and
that was wrong on my part
if that's the standard i'm wrong i don't
know
okay
let's go with that no further questions
all right how long is your return a
little bit you may want to take all
right let's go ahead and break for lunch
then ladies and gentlemen again do not
do any outside research do not discuss
your testimony with anybody okay
all right so let's come back at 155 then
all right
thank you
[Applause]
wow
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank
[Applause]
[Music]
they're very sweet
[Music]
[Applause]
get back
okay
uh
so
so
all right maybe seated
your next question or redirect thank you
dr spiegel
you were asked about whether you
were able to examine mr depp do you
recall those questions back and forth
yes and so if i understand your
testimony you asked twice for mr depp to
be interviewed by you correct yes
objection leading and
overall
and uh
and then in addition to that ms heard
requested twice of the court for mr depp
to be submitting to an examination of
you correct yes and those were denied
correct yes and now mr depp is
contending that it's unethical for you
to provide an uh an opinion in this case
because you didn't get an opportunity to
interview him do you think that makes
sense objection your honor
i sustain the objection all right
is that your understanding that is my
understanding of it okay um now
when counsel for mr depp was reading to
you the goldwater rule there were two
words that he kind of went over pretty
quickly and i'm going to go over them
again with you a little bit slower and
that was that the goldwater rule
was that you cannot make an armchair
diagnosis right objection based on
quote
publicly
available
records do you recall that
yes okay now the records that you
reviewed in this case were private were
they not yes and in fact dr blaustein's
records were marked confidential correct
yes and his deposition was marked
confidential yes okay and uh dr kipper's
records were all marked confidential
objection leading
and
sustainable okay what what if any
labeling was there on dr kipper's
deposition
all the documents i reviewed were
confidential and also signed a
confidentiality agreement so everything
i looked at was confidential okay so
that in fact does not even comport that
doesn't meet the uh restrictions
objection leading i mean
so would it be fair to say that you have
not have you rendered any opinions in
this case as an expert witness based on
publicly available
records i have not rendered any opinion
based on any publicly available records
thank
you
now you were asked a number of questions
about narcissistic traits and your diet
your diagnosis or findings that mr depp
exhibited narcissistic traits or had
that disorder do you recall that
testimony yes all right and
uh the question was asked of you of the
uh whether if you have five of nine
narcissistic traits do you remember that
testimony yes okay now one of the ones
you testified before was in for
narcissism it requires admiration
correct yes
what if any record evidence was there
that mr depp
requires admiration
the
the very people that surround him
need to admire him or they're no longer
in his employment or his uh working
circle okay the second one that you
discussed was sense of entitlement do
you recall that testimony yes all right
what record evidence is there that mr
depp exhibited exhibits behavior of
needing a sense of entitlement
so again thinking that uh ms heard
was marrying him solely for his money
and his influence and that that was the
case was in my opinion very entitled all
right and the third one you discussed
was exploitative do you recall that
yes okay and what is the record evidence
that mr deb exhibits behaviors of ex
that are exploitative again i think the
whole concept of abuse is exploitative
okay on the fourth one was lacks empathy
do you recall that yes and what is the
record evidence that mr depp exhibits
lacking empathy to be able to
commit intimate partner violence and the
control you have over someone
i'm sorry
can i be heard okay
i'm just going to ask you to
give the record evidence of
mr depp's uh lacking empathy that you
know of yes
am i lab am i a lot elaborate yes just
just a little different than what you
said before okay
um
so
if
if one does so i'll make it more direct
so if you're not agreeing
with what mr depp has to say
you are no longer useful okay therefore
you don't really care about others for
others you care about others for your
benefit so
off and on dismissing
dr kipper
for dr kipper setting some boundaries on
substance use protocol substance detox
is an example of lacking empathy and not
really caring what other people have to
say
all right another one of the
characteristics that you cited was
envious do you recall that testimony yes
what is the record evidence that mr depp
exhibits envy
i think jealousy is a good start for
that i i think that miss her wanting to
have a career start with that beyond
what she has uh and the the jealousy
parts of
with mr franco and
um
i think others uh comment this week was
bursting sorry last week ms burstin
commented about things about jealousy so
i think it's pretty apparent
okay
and the next one you listed was fragile
self-esteem do you recall that
yeah and what is the record evidence of
mr dev exhibiting that so fragile
self-esteem would be more along the line
of a cluster b trait i should put that
as not necessarily the criteria for
narcissism so it's a trait um and
basically what that means will be that
the
combination of
poor self-control and rapid mood states
is fragile
self-esteem fragile personality though
traits so go into line of cluster b
rather than per se narcissistic
all right now we've seen mr depp during
this trial doodling and eating candy
what if any
evidence would that suggest that he has
narcissistic traits objection you're
wrong no foundation i'll sustain the
objection
okay
now
you
were asked
about the cluster b and counsel for mr
depp came back and said
uh are you aware ms hurt has been
diagnosed with borderline personality
disorder or histrionic personality
disorder
now you reviewed
you i think you testified at the
beginning you reviewed the therapy and
counseling and medical records for ms
heard correct correct what if any uh
evidence was there that bonnie jacobs
diagnosed amber heard with either
borderline personality or a histrionic
personality disorder objection
that's fair cross he he asked the
question that's fair redirect
beyond the scope
it's not overruled thank you
so if i can start and miss jacob's uh
demonstrating no
type of personality sort of borderline
or otherwise and on a review of uh dr uh
the uh dr currie's objections beyond the
scope of the question it is i'll i'll
ask each of them separately and you you
also reviewed the medical the therapy
records for ms heard for conor cowan
correct
yes what what if any evidence was there
at any time that he diagnosed amber
heard with borderline personality
disorder or histrionic personality
disorder not only did he not he referred
to mr depp as a narcissist
okay
now you also re reviewed all of don
hughes records and her testing correct
yes and what if any evidence did you
find in any of that extensive testing
and note taking uh that she had found
that amber heard had borderline
personality disorder or histrionic
personality disorder objection leading
okay and you also reviewed dr curry's
notes and her testing correct yes all
right and what if any evidence did you
find in any of dr curry's testing that
amber heard had either borderline
personality disorder or histrionic
personality disorder she had traits she
did not meet the font herds own
evaluations you did not have the full
endorse enough criteria to meet the
criteria for borderline personnel
disorder
and or historic personnel she definitely
had traits she did not have the disorder
by going by the strict number of
criteria
all right now you mentioned in response
to mr depp's council's questions you
started to talk about battered wife's
syndrome
what is your experience with battered
wife syndrome sometimes
being mistaken with borderline
personality disorder or histrionic
personality disorder
objection compound
and leading
overworld
um so battered wife syndrome which is
more sub-syndromal or not quite ptsd has
70 symptoms of ptsd and if you hear some
of them you'll see why someone might
think that
they do have reliving experiences is it
feeling as if the abuse is happening
even if it's not
upon reminders of
via upon reminds abuse such as getting
ready to use something getting reused
substance or something along the line
they do have hyperarousal they do have
hypervigilance which is very easily
mistaken for the emotional reactivity of
borderline personality disorder they do
have avoiding symptoms so they avoid but
emotions
activities people and if that can't be
happening they start becoming much more
anxious much more hyper-aroused
they have inter disturbances in our
relationships which clearly can be an
issue
intimacy uh problems again which could
also resemble borderline personnel
disorders so
those description and traits that were
there
a did not meet the full criteria for
borderline and b could rather easily be
explained by battered wives syndrome a
form of ptsd
thank you now you also indicated earlier
that you reviewed the deposition of amy
banks correct yes and what if any uh
determinations did you make based on her
deposition
from her meetings with mr depp and ms
hurd
so
dr banks is a professor who uh at
harvard the leading institution in
america for medical schools who's an
expert on intimate partner violence she
had a chance to meet them in
relationship uh counseling uh
question your honor and unresponsive
that's that numbers well i said what if
anything did she find sustained
all right
tell the jury about amy banks the
significance of amy so what ms but uh dr
banks found was that she fully believed
uh miss heard's version of what was
going on objection hearsay
i i i reversed those let me let me do it
again please tell the jury
please let me please tell the jury
what about the qualifications of dr amy
banks this is the one who saw both ms
hurd and mr deb dr banks is a uh
professor at uh i don't know whether
assistant associate professor at harvard
uh university medical school one if not
one of the two top men of the schools in
the world who specialize in intimate
partner violence she is above all people
who understand if someone is victim
perpetrator because she does this
researches this for a living every day
and that's that's your qualifications
can i say what you reported that i'm
going to ask you what if anything did
did dr banks indicate relating to
histrionic personality disorder or
borderline personality disorder from his
heart
dr banks didn't mention anything about
personality disorder at all
what she did mention was whom she felt
gave a more accurate version
of objection your honor
what's the objection
that's a credibility testimony i i think
he can testify to that i'll sustain the
objection next question
what if anything did dr banks report not
saying what the ultimate conclusion was
what if anything did dr banks say about
what was reported to her by
ms hurd and mr depp and how they
responded
so
ms heard discussed the um
in trying to again as a victim trying to
save the relationship uh discuss with dr
banks
these accusations these these these
facts of intimate partner violence
um mr deb
objection hearsay
i i think he's he's entitled to rely on
here saying he's not giving what
ultimately was he's entitled to it
that's why you can rely on hearsay but
you just can't
state the hearsays he can rely on it
all right
what if anything did mr depp do in
response
mr deb said nothing when miss heard
accused him of intimate partner violence
mr depp said nothing and what is the
significance objection here safety
objection all right and what is the
significance of that
uh significant of that is with objection
no foundation
sustain
all right we'll move on um you were
asked about mdma
and what the impact could potentially
uh be
of taking eight to ten of these pills do
you recall yes okay and
now i'm gonna take you to australia
2015.
you've reviewed testimony over that
right for mr deb ms heard a number okay
um
were you do you recall that ms hurd also
said that she found dime bags of cocaine
in drawers at the end of that three days
yes okay i'm going to ask you michelle
can you bring up 1828 it's already in
evidence
and if we can publish that okay we can
thank you um
i'm going to this is one of the pictures
that was taken in australia and the
testimonies been that these two canvases
of ms herds were painted completely over
is that something that could be the
impact of having eight to ten
tablets of mdma and combining that with
cocaine and alcohol objection no
foundation
speculation
the foundation's already been laid your
honor let's
sustain the objection next question okay
what if anything if you look at the
painted canvases on this one
what if any
evidence is that that reflecting
behaviors
indicative of taking a lot of mdma
cocaine and alcohol objection
speculation no foundation same question
sustained
you testified earlier
about uh
property destruction of property do you
recall that yes okay could you tell the
jury what
uh
what how that relates to the correlating
factors of risk factors for ipv
again destruction of property is a form
of psychological uh abuse psychological
uh mistreatment and so destruction of
properties used as intimidation and as
needs of control
okay
michelle can you bring up 1829
and this has already been admitted yes
thank you your honor um and what if any
evidence
does this
reflect as correlating behavior to risk
factors of ipv
i would say that one that demonstrates
uh a good deal of violence and
psychological uh uh
abuse uh
i think it's pretty clear that they're
trying to be intimidating
i i don't think objection your honor
thank you please continue
it would be it would people who would
misuse
ecstasy
with without coke without cocaine
are prone to agitation
suspicion jealousy violence
what we're seeing there would be very
consistent
with that presentation
thank you michelle can you now bring up
18 30
30 i guess
and that's already been admitted into
evidence as well your honor had asked
that it be published
and what if any evidence uh does this
correlate with behavior indicative of
ipv perpetration again this is
intimidation psychological abuse where
you're solely trying to emotionally
objection around can we be heard
okay
dr spiegel if you uh if you can answer
the question
what if any evidence is this
correlating to the risk factors for ipv
perpetrator
again i i think the the violence comes
through
the objection
just the evidence of risk factors
evidence i'm sorry the evidence of risk
factor would be
um accepting and more than average
a degree of violence
as well as
psychological
abuse okay
are you aware of any uh
record evidence of ms heard writing on
walls mirrors counter tops or painting
canvases
no okay
thank you michelle you can take that
down now now you were also asked about
seroquel
and
some of the other prescription
medications
um
did you during the course of your review
of evidence see the lists of medications
that mr depp was on at one point yes i
read this michelle i'm going to ask you
to bring up defendants exhibit 301
and dr spiegel it's not into evidence
yet i'm going to ask you to take a look
at this is this one of the documents
that you had that reflected
uh the amount of medication that mr depp
was on as of october 26 2014 yes okay um
and
this was an email from debbie lloyd to
dr blaustein his treating psychiatrist
correct yes okay
now can you tell the jury
that we've got seroquel 50 mg objection
hearsay
can you just tell the truth i haven't
finished asking the question yeah
so will it hurt
okay
michelle can you scroll up just so i can
see all of them at the same time
thank you
so
doctor
siegel if
someone was taking
50 mega meg
milligrams of seroquel
25 milligrams of seroquel
and 50 milligrams of seroquel and 50 all
in one day
how would that impact them
so
obviously this is not for sleep
because um
presuming you're not wanting to sleep in
the morning
noon and from four to six although
you're sleeping at night
uh what i would say is he's using it for
one purpose as i say with substance use
disorder they're using it to calm down
using it just as a down to relax
and
given that you're taking 45 milligrams
of adderall a day
to stay awake and
um
that's
more than the uh prescribed for adults
and children for that matter
um
the combination makes very little sense
at all to me
and if a person was taking 300
milligrams of neurotin i'm going to
pronounce that wrong again
four times a day and 600 later in the
day how would that impact again you're
looking at medications that are there
solely for a substance use disorder
patient you get them up and you calm
them down
that's all this is this regimen is about
uh
deb penn doesn't have a psychiatric
indication other than actually doesn't
have psychiatric indication although it
does calm you down and
as i may have been to bed before
similar adderall
uh gap uh pen is also abusable similar
quotation cerakwell is also abusable so
you're getting these kind of unusually
calming effects
from these medicines while at the same
time getting what's called a super
therapeutic dose or an excessive amount
of adderall
and for the record book
adults are only indicated with adderall
for the extended release not the
immediate release preparation and why
that's relevant is the immediate release
preparation is more abusable you get
more high quicker extended release goes
out throughout the day the immediate
release gets you up right away
and then down now in adhd
this medicine is very effective
but for what this is being used for
clearly based on the combination
no
all right do addicts lie
yes
all right
now you were asked about mr depp passing
out do you recall reading testimony of
mr depp
passing out in the bathroom in his vomit
yes okay was that does that help refresh
your recollection of what you recall
i mean for the record book i don't think
that falling asleep with ice cream on
you is a objection beyond the scope of
the question
keep going i don't think sarah taking
sarah well at night
and falling asleep with ice cream on you
is not what cereal is indicated for it's
not meant to put you out in a state
where you don't even be able to stay
awake to put ice cream away
all right michelle if you can pull up
defendants 109-0
that's already into evidence
if we can publish that to the dirt jury
your honor
dr spiegel uh does this look like uh i
mean would this be evidence correlating
with
uh
behaviors consistent with ipv
perpetrator risk factors this would be
carly a person who is completely
knocked out and there's usually only one
way someone gets knocked out that badly
and that's with pharmacological
assistance whether it be illegal or
illegal they make it to the bed they
don't sleep with their head
on
a game box in a
furniture that that doesn't happen to
people who sleep no matter how tired you
are
about how to i've been a resident in the
past and
i i was up for
40 45 hours objection beyond the scope
it's just explained and done assistant
all right uh michelle can you pull up
109.5 please
and this has been i'm going to ask you
the same question dr spiegel uh what if
anything does this indicate relating to
risk factors for ipv perpetrators again
you know colloquially passed out and
there's very few ways to get like that
without pharmacological assistance
illegal or illegal and or illegal
and then let's pull up 1094 please
michelle
defense and that's also been admitted
and now we have the ice cream picture
and
what if any indication does this have
probably could see how i could objection
speculation no foundation
what if any uh correlation uh what if
any evidence does this indicate
correlative with the risk factors for
ipv again this proves one of the major
risk factors and precipitating factors
for
intimate partner violence objection you
are moved to strike all right sustained
i'll strike it from the record next
question
uh we'll we'll just move on okay um
you were asked about earpieces did you
do you recall reviewing tracy jacobs and
joel mandel's depositions yes all right
and do you recall them both testifying
that mr depp had someone on salary to
feed him his lines yes okay
now
you've testified that you reviewed a
substantial amount of evidence in this
case did you find any evidence that
amber heard exhibited conduct or
behaviors indicative or consistent with
any of the risk factors for perpetrators
of ipv objection beyond the scope
well it was suggested with the
borderline personality okay
but you did find that for mr depp
correct yes okay
and did you find
record evidence that mr deb had a
substance abuse disorder severe
substance use disorder all right did any
of the questions asked by mr depp's
council change any of your opinions in
this case
nothing there no not my opinion has not
been swayed in iota okay do you hold
them all still within a reasonable
degree of medical and psychiatric
probability or certainty absolutely yes
thank you very much dr spiegel all right
thank you sir you can have a seated in
the courtroom or you're free to go thank
you
all right your next witness
my next witness is catherine arnold
catherine
arnold truthfully in this case
thank you will you please state your
name for the record
catherine arnold all right
and what is your profession
i am a entertainment industry consultant
and i also serve as an expert witness
okay and can you please tell the jury
your educational background
yes
so
i was in the in i've been in the
entertainment industry for
over 20 plus years i started
uh as an assistant at icm which is one
of those largest talent agencies in los
angeles that represents actors writers
and directors and i worked with the
talent agent there and then i also
worked at william morris
for william morris as a script reader so
i was working on scripts that they were
delivered
and submitted to for their actors
writer's directors
after that i went into
development of
film and television projects for a
company based in new york called the
maltese company which
actually produced animated
television shows and feature films based
on wall street you know animated product
you know like toys
and then i went to work uh
with a company called the guber peters
company and goober peters was
at the time one of the largest
production companies in los angeles they
did films like batman and rain man and
tango and cash they did tv shows like
witches of eastwick and there i was
involved in the development of scripps
we worked with the studio directly in
terms of what cast would be attached to
the scripts and and brought directors
and talent to those projects
i then went on to
uh
work
in
um
there's a lot i went on to work uh in
the independent film world as a film
producer so i found the material i would
get the financing i would get the cast
and the director attached to the project
we call that packaging and then we would
go and and obtain financing for that
either through equity sources or
international sales and financing and
bank financing
and then i also uh went on after that
i produced
five or six films with actors that you
may know including salma hayek
vincent d'onofrio kirsty alley thomas
jane ethan hawk
and then i worked with a
international sales and production
company where i was the head of
production and i worked again on the
development of scripps and the
procurement of financing so i worked in
both the independent world and the
studio world meaning independently
financed or financed by the big studios
like warner brothers and disney and
paramount and such as that
uh that's it that's the bulk of my work
in the entertainment industry any of
your films win awards
a couple of them did so a couple of the
independent films that i uh produced one
of them one called the coriolis effect
won the
venice film festival in its category
uh and then i also produced another film
that won the heartland film uh festival
award it's called crystal award all
right
and what other video production projects
have you been involved in
so throughout that time in between those
jobs i also worked in the corporate
world so
large studios like warner brothers and
disney and cbs would need corporate
videos for their live events so i would
interview executives and interview their
talent and then edit the piece together
to create
video and media for their live sales
conferences that they had at that time
uh
and then i also produced some
commercials all right and what if any
experience did you have in corporate
relations and licensing
so early on in my career i worked at the
los angeles olympic organizing committee
and i worked in the licensing department
where we handled the licensing of the
olympic logo and we also worked with
sponsors and suppliers who were funding
those olympic games so it was a lot of
contractual negotiations with the use of
the license of the logo
as well as
raising money for the games and working
with those uh corporate sponsors
throughout
the two years prior to the games and
then during the games themselves
and what if any experience do you have
working on film festivals
uh well i've had films and festivals
i've actually been very lucky to travel
the world and gone to a lot of festivals
with my films both here in the united
states and elsewhere and at one point i
was also hired to raise sponsorship
funds for the sundance film uh sunday's
film festival they had a new program
that they were starting to do online
festivals and so i raised about a half
million dollars for him in about a month
all right and
do you have a degree a college degree
yes i graduated from ucla with a
bachelor's degree in economics
what is your current consulting practice
entail
so as an entertainment consultant having
been in the business in both the
independent and the studio worlds as
both a producer and an executive
i work with investment companies and
production companies who are looking to
navigate
the various inroads of hollywood it's a
pretty
uh the business is very different and
unlike anything else and very
relationship based so i use my 20 years
of experience to help them
get cast get financing understand the
distribution process marketing process
and get them set up
to be able to produce their films
have you ever testified as an expert
witness in the field of entertainment
industry yes okay approximately how many
times have you served as an expert
i've been involved in somewhere between
85 and 100 cases as an expert from
beginning stages to testifying in court
and have you ever testified as an expert
on damages and defamation cases
yes i have okay and approximately how
many times have you qualified as an
expert on that on defamation yes i
believe
three or four times okay and have you
ever
been admitted to testify as an expert on
damages
yes okay and how many times have you
qualified as an expert on damages
almost all my cases have some form of
damage uh
relation you know economic damage
related to the case so i would say in
all of the cases that i've testified in
i have been qualified in damages okay
have you ever served as an expert for
both have you served as an expert for
both plaintiffs and defendants
yes i had okay how much of your current
practice involves consulting as opposed
to ex serving as an expert witness
so over the last 10 or 12 years it's
been about 50 50 so i spent half my time
working as a consultant and the other
half working with lawyers on their cases
your honor i'm going to move to qualify
catherine arnold as an expert in the
entertainment industry standards and
practices and related economic damages
all right any objection
all right so moved thank you
now you have a dual role here as an
expert correct
yes
you're going to be testifying with
respect to mr
depp's challenges to or claims of
damages and you're also going to be
testifying to amber herds damages
correct yes all right well i'm going to
start you with mr depp's claims for
damages okay
with respect to mr depp's claim damages
on what subject have you been asked to
offer your opinion
so i was asked to assess the any alleged
damages that the op-ed piece in the
washington post that ms heard wrote
whether that impacted his
career in any way particularly did he
lose any income or any economic
opportunities because of the op-ed b
specifically all right and
have you been asked to limit that to the
period of december 18 2018
with the date of the op-ed through
november 2 2020
yes okay
now what materials did you review in
making your analysis
there were a lot of documents uh i
reviewed the pleadings of the case the
complaints the discovery items the
responses to what they call
interrogatories which are the questions
that the lawyers ask both sides i
reviewed mr depp's test uh deposition
testimony which there were volumes of
that as well as miss herds
i also reviewed the deposition testimony
of of the experts that
uh
were proffered that had to do with the
entertainment industry you know the
agents and the management teams of both
both sides
ron schnell the data expert i also
reviewed
emails and texts between the parties
between their families between the
management teams the audio
recordings the visual recordings that
have been presented in this case and the
previous cases that have been involved
in the last couple of years
i also did my own independent research
from
general publicity and press and
investigative articles as well as those
that are specific to the entertainment
industry and utilize some entertainment
industry specific sources to get some
information that was helpful to my k to
our to that case thank you ms arnold
please describe for the jury
your
observations with respect to mr depp's
career trajectory
well mr mr depp has had an extraordinary
career over many years so it's it's a
it's a long one to look at um
obviously he was a rising star in the
late 80s and in the 90s starting with 21
jump street and you've heard you know
all the films that i'm sure he's been in
um he
he really started to break through when
he worked with tim burton the director
and and of course his character jack
sparrow in pirates of the caribbean was
you know world-renowned um and probably
um his biggest role and he was a you
know a well-liked um both critically and
uh within the industry and within the
public as a movie star
and at the same time
his behavior and
both on and off the set in his personal
life and in his professional life
start to interfere
with
uh
what we would say what everybody saw was
his great talent and it
started
you know there's some stories of of
issues that started back in the 80s and
the 90s but i would say really in the
mid 2000s between 2006 and 10 is when
the behavior started affecting
his work to a certain extent in terms of
lateness on set
and then as ms jacobs his talent agent
discussed with you in her deposition
it really started affect
her ability to get roles and and the
industry's willingness to work with him
given the issues that he was having with
both behavior tardiness
drinks drinking and the drug abuse
uh and you know other issues in his
personal life so it got more complicated
for her to find him work and i think he
got harder for production companies and
studios to hire him due to the
challenges that that would put on a
production
and when did mr depp's career downturn
begin based on your review of all the
record evidence
well again
according to miss jacobs his agent she
mentioned that it started getting more
challenging for her around 2010 the
lateness
on set
was being made she was being made aware
of that more and more often from
production executives and the producers
that she was working with on the pirates
movie and not only pirates it continued
on
on the other films including mordecai
and
murder on the orienta express
and
in around 2014
when he had the appearance uh it was
presumed that he was under the effects
of alcohol at the hollywood film awards
in 2000 objection your honor
non-responsive
she's answering the career downturn
overworld
please continue thank you um
in 2014
uh
when mr depp appeared in the hollywood
film awards miss jacobs received many
phone calls from both producers casting
directors and production executives
asking her what is going on with your
client why you know what's going on with
his behavior can we get him under
control and then i think it really
started to shift around the pirates five
movie in australia with again the
lateness and the
issues uh with the finger that stopped
production and and things of that nature
and then it just it got harder and
harder
now based on your analysis what has
caused mr depp's career downturn
objection
no foundation
can you please repeat the question
based on your analysis what has caused
mr depp's career downturn
and i realize you've said a number of
those so just is there anything else
sure uh well
we've talked about the erratic behavior
the tardiness the drugs and alcohol
abuse and
the lawsuits have had a really big
impact not just this lawsuit but
previous lawsuits that mr depp has been
involved with because there's a lot of
publicity around anything that he does
and uh every time he has filed a lawsuit
it is brought to light
various issues with respect to whatever
that lawsuit was about whether it was
about
you know erratic behavior or domestic
abuse
or drugs and alcohol and even spending
habits so every time a lawsuit has been
filed
the press and the publicity has just
been charged up and brought everything
back to light and it's
it's been an unfortunate
problem for for on that level for the
industry to continue to work with him
even though all this is out in the in
the public
for the films that were shortly before
pirates five how successful were they
we're talking mordecai uh
alice through the looking glass uh
i think you testified to some of those
the lone ranger tonto
right injection compound
overall
of course mr deb has had some extremely
obviously extremely successful films but
also in the you know the
four or five years prior and you know
through pirates there were films that
didn't do well at all and were
considered what the industry calls a
bomb which could have been
uh alice for the looking glass the
transcendence um
the the lone ranger
uh and mordecai were films that just
didn't perform although they were
valued in their financing based on mr
depp's star quality and acting ability
unfortunately they just didn't perform
so as many hits as he's had he's also
had a lot of recent what they call
failures in the business
and
what if anything did mr depp do with
respect to showing up for a press
conference in japan for mordecai
miss jacobs mentioned in her deposition
testimony that mr depp didn't show up
for the press conference in mordecai
which he was not only an actor for he
was also producer and he didn't show up
apparently he was sleeping so he wasn't
able to make it okay
now
what if any uh
impact did the brooks litigation have on
mr depp's career
is the jury familiar with this already
or
well i i think you can i mean okay so
the brooks litigation was uh
it was um
there was a litigation around uh mr dev
had punched someone on one of the i
think it was a location manager on the
set of a film called city of lies um i i
don't know exactly what happened to that
litigation however of course again it
was written a lot about in the press and
unfortunately came to the forefront that
he had you know violent behavior yet
again
so in
2018 and i'm going to say before the op
ed on december 18 2018 right were there
was there any negative articles negative
press about mr depp
for quite a while when you're a
celebrity such as mr depp you're in the
limelight and everybody wants to look at
everything that happened so
after every movie or eve after every
incident there was usually press but the
the ones that were more significant were
the ones in the hollywood a couple of
them in the hollywood reporter
and uh one of the rolling stones so in
2017
there was an article in the hollywood
reporter
where the journalists discussed i think
the article was called pirates of the
caribbean the diminishing returns of
johnny depp and
that pirates the one with the last one
was five right and that one didn't
perform nearly as well as the other
previous uh pirates of the caribbean
films and there was some discussion that
the character objection hearsay your
honor i think you can explain generally
sustained okay um
let me let me ask you this when was that
hollywood reporter article on
diminishing returns of johnny depp that
was in the spring of 2017 okay and you
said uh and i just want to make sure we
understand how well did pirates five do
compared to one through four it
performed less well by over 200 million
dollars okay um
what if any other negative press was
there in this time frame we'll take 2017
2018 before the op-ed so in 2018 there
was the rolling stones article that was
an in-depth expose on mr depp's life um
again his erratic behavior the money he
was spending on on why objection your
honor hearsay i i think she can give
generally your honor the negative state
all right um
what if any
knowledge do you have of
how whether disney
saw the rolling stone article
there were emails
between
the publicity department and the
co-chairs and some of the senior
executive disney that they would forward
the articles as they came out both the
hollywood reporter article
and the
rolling stones article
and they would make commentary and
alan horn who is the uh one of the chief
co-chairs of disney used the word sad
and i think one of the other executives
used depressing that their film star was
now being shown in this light to the
public in a rolling stone section
hearsay
sustained all right um
was there any more articles about the
pirates of the caribbean prior to the
op-ed in december of 2018
there was an article in october 28th uh
the hollywood reporter october 28 2018
where the journalists had spoken to two
writers of the film and they were
talking about objection
she's entitled to rely on hearsay and
she's just giving the general she's not
approached
okay
so without saying what the article said
say what it's about
okay so in october 28th the articles it
was called uh the article was about
whether the pirates of the caribbean
rebooted without overrule
please continue the part where in the
article in october 2018 was about
whether or not the pirates franchise was
going to be what they call reboot you
know redefined without johnny depp and
that was in
regarding two writers that were on the
project
okay uh
and there was one other one
okay go ahead please so there was
another article uh there was an expose
on uh the president of production is
also in the hollywood reporter and this
is the one that mr marx mr depp's expert
pointed to
um
regarding the op-ed's impact on mr
depp's career and
the online article was as mr marks
pointed out published on december 20th
of 2018 but the same article was in
print
on the morning of december 18 2018 which
is the same morning of the op-ed so that
hollywood reporter article that mr
marx used to say objection no foundation
overall please continue
the uh mr marks had used that article to
show that disney
wanted to let go of mr depp because of
the op-ed but it was actually printed
in the reporter the same morning that
the washington post article was printed
so there's no way that the washington
post article had any impact
on what the holly reporter journalist
wrote
so they were on the same morning they
were at least simultaneously
interestingly enough and and the one
that was two days later was the same
article just online same articles just
online yeah okay thank you now what if
anything was there about press in 2018
relating to the sun
and dan wooten and any litigation that
raised her
so a lot of press was about the uk trial
in the lawsuit that mr depart against
the uh the sun in the uk about the wife
beater um title that they use so there
was a ton of press around that both at
the time that it was filed and
throughout as documents were being
shared with the public and then of
course during the trial itself okay and
what is your understanding of when the
for the article the wife beater article
first appeared
i believe it was in july of 2018 about
six months before the op-ed piece what
is your understanding of when mr depp
filed suit against the sun and mr wooten
again in 2018 i believe okay
june would it be
would that would would it refresh would
it refresh you it was in the spring or
summer it was fairly shortly after the
article so it was
long before the op-ed piece was out okay
um
and what if any impact did mr depp's
litigation in the sun case have on his
career
that was a really tough one on on mr
depp's career because everything every
allegation of abuse and every text every
email all the audio all the visual stuff
was brought to light and made public and
so not only did the public get get to
see it but the industry was watching
closely and it's hard for
studios especially a studio like disney
who's family oriented
be connected to a star that has
texts about burnt corpses and violent
behavior in in in video so it was a it
was a big conflict for a lot of the
people in the industry to how to
navigate that if they're going to work
with star
and what if any impacted mr depp's other
litigation against mandel and bloom have
during that time period
as i was trying to say earlier every
time mr depp brings a lawsuit because
he's such a well-known public figure the
spotlight goes on him so every time a
lawsuit was filed whether it was to his
business against his business manager
against his former lawyer even when he
fired his talent agent it becomes news
and then everybody talks about what
could have preceded that why
would that lawsuit have happened and
then they look at the details so again
the erratic behavior and the financial
issues and the uh
drinking and drug abuse was all part and
parcel of every one of those and it was
brought to light yet again each time
what is your understanding of mr depp's
claims regarding pirates of the
caribbean six
and how that impacted
well
mr depp is claiming that he's lost many
on pirate six but pirate six hasn't even
been made yet nor is there even a script
that has been what we call greenlit move
towards production so i don't know how
you lose something that hasn't happened
so
i i think that's what you're looking for
me today and in fact since mr damages
are limited november 2
2020 and nothing since
and that hasn't happened
uh is there any way he could claim
damages for pirate six well objection
leading
overall
again you can't claim damages for
something that hasn't even happened
whether he was in it or not in it or was
going to be in it or might have been in
it whether it was 2018 or now
there just is no pirate six
um not only did he not have a contract
even back in the day
2018 or after that no contract had been
signed for a pirate six
it doesn't exist as we objection legal
conclusion
i
i
sustained at the last part
how do you know he doesn't have a legal
contract
well
miss jacob said he didn't have a legal
contract and also his agents at caa said
he had not
had not yet negotiated a contract for
pirate six
uh and
again there is no
script so they haven't greenlit as we
say they don't have it have it caster
with the director yet okay um
based on your analysis what if any
impact did miss herds op-ed have on
whether mr depp uh could
claim a loss for pirate six
zero okay
and why do you say that
again well
many things
the movie doesn't exist yet so that's
one but
even as important is that disney
in their file for this trial did not
have the op-ed piece as part of all of
the information they had read and looked
about and discussed
the uh conversations of mr depp not
being in whatever new version of pirates
the franchise that goes forward those
weren't discussions long before the
op-ed piece even came out
and
uh
there are other factors that disney was
considering the lateness on set
the cost overruns at that cost which can
go from hundreds of thousands of dollars
to millions of dollars when you have
crews sitting around for
two to four hours eight hours or even
several weeks to a month when the finger
incident happened so
on top of that mr depp is an expensive
actor
he can earn between 20 and 25 million
dollars per movie plus back end so it's
very expensive so when you put that all
together the rising cost of mr jeff is
talent the challenges that they had to
keep it on budget because of his
lateness and his tardiness and all the
other allegations that would affect a
brand such as disney right someone talks
about a burnt corpse does not
necessarily coincide with the brand of
disney so there were many problems and
interestingly enough
there was a lot of conversation in uh
at uh in internally in the industry or
something hearsay she's entitled to rely
on hearsay your honor sustain that you
can't say it's hearsay all right um
please
please continue without saying what the
discussion in the industry was
the jack sparrow character had
been
exhausted in terms of where it could go
creatively and i think the studio is
looking for
a way for it to renew the franchise but
not necessarily base it entirely on the
jack sparrow character which is where it
ended up the last couple of years okay
and and evidenced by the the lesser uh
box office of pirates five compared to
the earlier ones
and and
was there any article that came out on
november 5 2020 three days after the
damages are cut off relating to pirates
of the caribbean and mr depp's chances
of being jack sparrow
i think they reiterated the fact that he
was probably not going to be in
the movie okay
now
what impact has the op-ed had on mr
depp's career
very little hardly anybody even knew the
op-ed existed before he filed suit
okay if anybody that i know but
certainly not disney okay
and um
what impact has the head add on mr
depp's q scores
according to what i read of mr allen
jacobs
an expert in
statistical analysis and from my own
research on websites that are available
to us
mr depp's q score or if you're familiar
with imdb which is uh
internet movie database which is
available to public and to the
professional side
his q score did not change uh
dramatically it was kind of in the
middle of exactly the high and low of
his q scores overall it was in the
middle it was at like 113 which is where
it was a couple weeks before and a
couple weeks after so the op-ed didn't
have any effect
uh on his q score and that was
reiterated by mr jacobs in his
deposition testimony and then you
testified in response to an earlier
question i had that
that people or that nobody seemed to
notice the op-ed until mr depp filed
suit now that was on march 1 2019 do you
recall
yes that's when the lawsuit was filed
and why why do you say that they didn't
notice until then
because the op-ed
piece for most people in the industry
kind of came and went without much
fanfare or much conversation it was much
more about the
i don't think very many people even know
it was written until the allegations
were made by mr depp in the lawsuit uh
it kind of
came in and out of the radar very
quickly if anybody even saw it at all
all right
between december 18 2018 and november
2020
november 2 2020 our window here has mr
depp continued to star in films
so mr depp so the article came the op-ed
piece came out december
20 18 and 20 of 2018 in december i'm
sorry in january and february of 2019
he shot a film called minamata which was
an independent film that he is what we
call a passion project he loved the
script and wanted to do it so he was
able to film that after the op-ed piece
and then the dior campaign sauvage
i don't know the exact dates of filming
but i know that it did air throughout
2019
and uh it's my understanding that he
still may have that contract with dior
so he continued that product endorsement
and then in uh april or sorry in the
spring
and the fall i believe it was uh mr depp
was able to do press
uh for the film waiting for the
barbarians he went to the dauville film
festival he went to the venice film
festival he was well received at the
press conferences
you know life was at the same level for
him in terms of his popularity over in
europe they were
still uh he was still working on press
for the films and then of course he was
scheduled to film uh fantastic beasts in
in early uh november of 2020.
and
that's no longer the case is that
rejection your honor
what's the objection
can we approach
and that's no longer the case correct on
fantastic beasts i don't want you to say
anything more than that that's no longer
it's no longer the case correct he's no
longer in that film correct he was paid
for it but he does not star in the film
okay thank you now
what if any effect did the op-ed have on
mr depp's fan following
i don't know if i don't think it had any
effect on his fan following again his q
scores didn't shift and
he
clearly has a strong fan base in your
opinion what or who has caused the
damage if there is any to mr depp
on his career and reputation between
december 18 2018 and november 2 2020.
objection speculation
mr deb
and why do you say that
well again
filing the lawsuits bringing to light
the issues is mr depp doing that on his
own accord
and
any statements that were made
uh
by his team mr waldman or anyone else is
associated with mr depp and those
statements that came out the defamatory
statements which we'll talk about in a
minute uh were also
put out by mr depp's team so
in actuality he's causing his own demise
by bringing these lawsuits forward and
continuing to kind of ignite the fire of
negative publicity around both of them
okay
are all of your opinions to within a
reasonable degree of probability or
certainty
with respect to mr depp's damages yes
okay thank you
now i'm going to move you to
amber heard's damages
with respect to amber herd's claims for
damages on what subject have you been
asked to offer your opinion
so i was asked to look at the
reputational harm and economic loss that
mis
heard incurred due to the defamatory
statements that mr waldman
on behalf of mr depp made in april of
2020 and again in june in 2020
and what materials did you review
in forming your opinions
again many of the same materials that i
reviewed
for mr depp's case which was the
deposition testimony the pleadings the
discovery all of that was included as
well as
expert testimony that was based on
statistical analysis of
negative social media campaigns that
were created as well as what happened i
talked to ms heard's agents i read their
depositions i talked to her publicist i
read her deposition
i talked to miss heard herself to get a
first-person accounting of what happened
from her perspective after those
defamatory statements were made
and then i looked at the you know again
uh emails back and forth and text back
and forth
with
the studio warner brothers and other
producers that the management team is
working with to get ms heard more work
okay
now before i go into the questions that
i'm going to ask i'm going to go ahead
and just kind of define this so that
we're all on the same page going through
it we've the jury has seen the three
defamatory statements they're defendants
12 45 1246 a and 1247
um and i'm just going to refer to them
as the debt
slash waldman statements in asking you
all these questions will you understand
what i'm talking about yes okay good um
please describe amber heard's career
prior to the publication of the deb
waldman statements
so amber's had
a long career for someone who is not you
know is fairly young still she was in
over 50 productions uh
inc i believe including aquaman and
justice league but let's just say close
to 50 productions uh well certainly 50
productions before the uh defamatory
statements were made
she had you know a consistent
working actor's career
her agents were strategic
as she started getting more work that
they wanted her to work with better and
better directors to have cl you know the
danish danish girl is a film that had a
strong director and a strong critical
acclaim
and then she went from that to getting
justice league which is on the bigger
budget is the bigger scale movie and
then of course aquaman and aquaman two
so her career was following a very nice
steady rise
and she was on the precipice of a
meteoric rise with the wait you know
with aquaman and aquaman too prior to
the statements
was aquaman a successful film in terms
of box office sales
aquaman was an extremely successful film
it made over a billion dollars and i
believe it is the
highest grossing dc
comic film ever
now
what if any
accolades did amber receive for her role
in aquaman and i'm going to call it
sometimes i'll call it aquaman one just
to make sure we don't get confused right
so and aquaman one there were many
emails from the director
and the producer and objection hearsay
she's just characterizing your honor
she's not quoting them
well i don't know where it's going i'll
overrule at the moment thank you
uh she got
emails from the director and the
producer
stating that they love her performance
anyway
you can't say what the emails say but
you can summarize them or characterize
them can you do that accolading emails
emails of accolade
from her uh from the director and the
producers objection hearsay overruled us
thank you
okay
um
what type of press opportunities did
amber have prior to the debt baldwin
statements
so the press really
loved working with amber she was on the
cover of many magazines after the danish
girl after justice league after aquaman
she was the cover girl
i think it was of
marie claire or l in in the uk
she had a cover story of a big magazine
in mexico in australia they were you
know some magazine one magazine called
her woman of the year another one called
her role model of the year so she got a
lot of press
you know she did a lot of press both in
magazines but also on the press tours
and the press junkets that she did for
the films
and and were some of those california
style marie claire l
uh shape going yeah there was a lot of
leading
overrule and there was a lot of them so
i mean you know don't remember all of
them but it was you know gql marie
claire you know the big magazines both
here the uk
um east europe eastern europe in latin
america and in australia and what about
after the release of aquaman
which was december 2018
how was her press then
well the press tour was doing well and
they wanted to give her a lot more press
and i think up until the defamatory
statements came out she was on deck to
do a lot of press
and then
objection no foundation
please continue so the press and the
request for press went silent after the
defamatory statements were made and
which then the negative social media
campaign ensued after that
now
what factors relating to social media
does the enter entertainment industry
rely on when considering an actor for a
role
social media becomes a big part of how
studios decide to use an actor and
actress in a film because they want to
know how the general public feels about
them they want to know what the consumer
feels about that actor so when there's
positive social media that's a good
thing for the actor when there's
negative social media it can be
very bad because not only can social
media be directed at the actor or the
actors themselves but it can also be
directed towards
the movie towards the movie company
towards the product that the actor actor
is working with so it becomes very
complicated and it can get very messy
to continue working with an actor or an
actress if there's a lot of negative
social media around them okay
and after the deb waldman statements
what happened on social media
after the deb waldman statement social
media blew up with negative tweets and
instagram posts and you know facebook
posts and snapchat and trolling as we
call it it was just negative
uh according to mr schnell there was
over 1.2 million negative tweets about
hamburg using
hashtags that used the words in the
statement of the deb wald statements
uh
dep waldman's name excuse me
that 1.2 million negative statements
between
april of 2020 and november or january of
21
it's a lot of negative publicity and it
and there was just a lot of what we call
noise
around um misheard and her work of any
kind can you please describe to the jury
what negative what a negative social
campaign is
so
a negative social campaign would be when
a a
fan base or in this case according to
both
the forensic statistical analyst as well
as ms heard's agents and
the product that she was working with
l'oreal and her publicist it was a
campaign that included both
live
uh
accounts live twitter you know people
that actually have our individuals as
well as what we call objection
maybe heard all right
all right
other than the bots please describe the
rest of the social media the negative
social media campaign
the fan base was very energized by mr
is it
the depth wall state yeah let me let me
just step waldman i'm i'm i'm sorry i
love my brain right now that doesn't
matter why don't i do this let me
formulate a different question how has
the negative social media campaign been
used against amber heard since the debt
waldman statements great so the negative
campaign has been used both to
you know let's fire amber off of aquaman
to
the product that she was had an
endorsement contract with with l'oreal
the makeup and every time that l'oreal
mentioned amber heard and the product
together they would get harassed her
publicist company was harassed
any kind of movie that she was related
to or television project that she was
related to got negative attention from
the social media world even the uh
the charities that she was involved with
were getting
hammered if you will or bombarded by
negative social media which made it
difficult to work with amber on any
level because negativity was brought to
their product service or
uh film okay
and
is that negative social media campaign
ongoing to this day
yes okay and you were talking a little
bit before i think about uh
remove amber heard from aquaman two what
were your observations with respect to
that in connection to the waldman depths
the depth waldman statements
again the the the statements i'm sorry
the social media campaign whether called
you know remove amber from aquaman or
you know
negativity for her relationship in that
film it always tended to use words that
were inside the defamatory statements
they became hashtags right so
you know if it was said in this in the
in the defamatory statement they were
often reiterated in the tweets and the
posts
okay
how difficult is it for an actor to
repair this type of negative social
media
well first of all has to stop okay so
once it stops then an actor and their
team
can work slowly and patiently
in both
maybe it's press interviews maybe its
relationship with charity maybe it's a
small role in a movie and they do well
and they kind of rebuild their career
but it can take
two three four five years or more to
rehabilitate your career but first and
foremost it needs to stop
you know it just needs to stop so that
they can
the consumer can get beyond it and then
they can reactivate their career
by doing their work again
describe amber heard's reputation after
the deb waldman statements
well the reputation i guess depends on
who who you're talking to but in the
public it's been very negative
um in the industry they like her work
but it's very they can't work with her
right now again because every time her
name is mentioned the negativity flares
up again so it doesn't make sense for
them to try to make a movie which costs
millions of dollars and then have a lot
of negativity towards the film or the tv
show or the product so her world has
been
silent in terms of opportunities and
even things that
that she wanted to work on are no longer
available to her
has amber been able to obtain roles
after the deb waldman statements
for a long time no uh very recently she
was able to do a small independent film
um
from some people out of um who get their
financing out of europe
but up until that no she has not worked
now
[Music]
based on the fact that amber came out of
aquaman
what should her opportunity what would
you have expected
following the release of aquaman
december 2018
uh up to what's going on now
i like to call aquaman really
you know amber heard star stars born
moment it was that moment where not only
was she a good actor but she was now
world renowned because she was in the
most successful film
almost of all time if not all time and
certainly for dc comics she was on the
poster with the very handsome jason
mamow and they were this couple and she
was strong and beautiful and it was just
this extraordinary moment for her for
her to career to take off right
you know her agents were excited the
producers were excited
everybody just wanted to hit the ground
running and let's do more let's do more
work
what if anything happened to amber's
participation in aquaman 2.
so for a moment in time in february 2021
uh there were conversations that amber's
i'm going to be technical with you her
option for employment was not going to
be exercised so they may not have hired
her again even though she had a contract
for it there was some question as to
whether she was going to be hired again
on aquaman two
all right and did ultimately then she
still get hired for aquaman too
she did her management team fought very
hard and they ultimately ended up hiring
her but also not only because of what
her management team did but jason mamoa
the star and james wong the director
committed to her in an email saying if
we are involved in this movie objection
no foundation hearsay
said just
summarize it or describe it
i'm sorry i'm just trying to understand
this world
so
her management team worked hard
and jason mamoa and the director
were adamant that she was in the
objection here
she has to be able to say that what
sustain is to hear say
next question so
what if any uh assurances did
mr momoa and mr juan give amber
that she would be an aquaman too
objection hearsay sustained
uh
what if any
are you aware of any chemistry issues uh
between amber and jason mamoa from
aquaman according to the fact that they
did a chemistry test with miss heard
misheard and jason mamoa in order for it
to be hired that is a good indication
that they thought the two of them had
good chemistry
obviously when you look at the movie
they have good chemistry and the poster
they have good chemistry so i think
it's general awareness that they had
great chemistry
all right
and what if anything uh
would also suggest uh with respect to
aquaman 2
that jason momoa believed they had good
chemistry
he wanted her in the movie okay
i think she she has to be able to rely
on sustained
i'll strike it from the record
uh in your review of all of the record
evidence what if anything did you say
see in writing anywhere that there was
ever any chemistry or creative issue
with amber hurd and jason momoa from
aquaman one
there were no communications whatsoever
that there was no chemistry between the
two and and what if anything did you in
all the record evidence did you see
that the producer or jason momoa did not
want amber heard in aquaman two
i did not see any evidence of that okay
in fact the opposite correct correct
again
thank you your honor
now what if any leverage did amber heard
have to renegotiate her salary under the
circumstances of
the discussions you were talking about
with not exercising her option
she had zero leverage she was fighting
for her life to stay in the film okay
now
is it typical for an actor to be able to
negotiate an increase in their salary
after a successful franchise
you may know this already and so i
apologize if you've heard it before i
don't know what's been brought to your
attention but in a franchise such as
potential franchises justice league and
aquaman
the
customs and practice is that the uh
studio will make a
an agreement with the actor that
incorporates potential future films so
if justice league does well they want to
know what they're going to pay the actor
for the next one and the next one and
the next one and in those
uh successive terms in the contract
the
fee for that actor
customarily goes up it can go up by 10
20 100 percent you could double
what have you
and
in the case as um uh miss uh kovacevic
stated in her testimony
that
in a successful franchise that a movie
that's made a billion dollars the actors
agents will go back and try to
renegotiate that upcoming price tag so
if it was going to be x they might want
it to be 2x or 3x and that's very
standard in the industry to renegotiate
your contracts when there's
many films in one single contract that
each have their own price points
what if any other actors in aquaman one
were able to renegotiate their contracts
uh jason momoa renegotiated his contract
very significantly from aquaman one
tackleman too do you know roughly how
much more uh it went up from the you
know let's somewhere between three and
four million to 15 million
did amber have a contract for aquaman
one
yes how much was she paid for aquaman
one aquaman one she was paid two million
dollars okay and if
and did that same contract uh provide
for if she was in aquaman two
i'm sorry i apologize aquaman one i
believe she got one million dollars
aquaman two she was supposed to get two
million dollars i apologize the numbers
there were a lot of numbers in that one
contract so aquaman won it was one
million i'll comment two it was gonna be
two million
all right now based on your experience
and knowledge in the industry
how much would amber hurt have been able
to negotiate
her contract but for the deb waldman
statements
for aquaman two i'm asking right well as
you can see from mr mimo's contract that
went up exponentially up to 15 million
dollars uh misheard i don't know if she
would have gotten 15 million dollars for
the movie but she certainly could have
increased it by one or two million
dollars or even doubled it so if it was
two it could have been four
or even five or six depending on the
enthusiasm if had just rolled from
aquaman juan to auckland to without any
of this
negativity that was created by the
walmart the deb waldman statements
what if anything happened to amber's
role in aquaman 2 after the department
statements
it was diminished
now why would amber have been featured
more prominently in aquaman too
objection no foundation
it's only a foundation okay
um
what usually determines or uh
are you able to
speak to
whether amber should have been or would
have been more prominently featured in
aquaman too
well a couple of things
i'm trying to get your foundation are
you able to speak to that
yes okay
and
please tell the basis of that and then
your opinion
so there's two things when two actors do
well in a romantic relationship and you
know they get married or they're gonna
have a baby you know you want to follow
that through because part of what did
well in aquaman was not know the action
sequences but to have a strong female
character
having a relationship with a strong male
character it's very empowering right so
that was working for them in the first
place the poster of aquaman that went
around the world was
one of the main posters was of the two
of them together standing proud and
strong right being that couple and so
naturally as you go and develop scripts
in the industry you want to follow on
the things that are working and
according to miss heard when she read
the first script for aquaman 2 she had a
strong romantic arc for the entire film
and then she also got to do some great
action sequences at the end of that
storyline in that script so she was
featured predominantly throughout the
script of aquaman 2 when she first read
it all right and then what happened
well she didn't hear anything so she
wasn't getting the scripts but everyone
her colleagues were getting the scripts
she heard that through her agents and
then when she got the script um
it was pared down from the first script
dramatically they had her in the
hospital very shortly in the in the
first part of the movie called act one
they had her in the hospital and they
pretty much had her in the hospital and
then she was going to do this
action sequence in the end she trained
five hours a day for
several months for the trainer to do
this big action sequence
and then when she got to set
two things happened one the costume
designer said i don't know what happened
to your role it got
diminished objection
more importantly though this big action
sequence that she was going to do in at
the end of the movie and the third act
was cut out
and they took it away from her so it was
radically reduced from what it was in
the script and what she even trained for
uh while she was preparing for the movie
and what if any changes were made to the
storyline
i haven't seen the movie yet
specifically so i can't really speak to
that yet all right and when you say she
was in the hospital
what do you mean by was she injured in
the first scene i believe that in the in
the first act of the movie she was
injured somehow or has something to do
with the baby i don't know exactly i'm
just going with what miss her told me
about was that she ends up in in the
hospital early in this new aquaman two
movie and doesn't really come out until
the end to kind of wrap things up but
all of the interactions with you know
mamo's character
and the certainly the action scenes were
taken out
how has amber typically been involved in
promotions for her films
as we talked about earlier actively
involved in the press and the promotion
whether that was on the press junkets
what we call when they tour the world
and they and the actors tour together
and and answer questions from the press
at various screenings and film festivals
and then also she was you know on the
cover of magazines usually after her
movies especially after justice league
and how was the promotion of aquaman 2
affected by the deb waldman statements
amber has not been involved in any of
the promotion that's been done to date
or very little particularly in teasers
that i've seen we call you know short
little films about the making of and so
forth she's not featured in them and
also very specifically there was a big
event that warner brothers
put on during the fandom i think it's a
dc fandom event which is a big kind of
like comic-con style event and they
invited all of the actors of the
majority of the actors that had strong
roles in film to participate both in the
posters and the artwork and also
participate at
dc fandom and ms heard was not invited
to either be in the poster or be at the
event and in fact they told her she
cannot come
now can can this hurt amber's career not
being allowed to be in any of the
promotional materials
absolutely
it means that nobody knows about her she
doesn't have the same part in the film
it's not going to take her on to her
next movie
she's not being associated with the
tremendous amount of promotion that's
going to be made for this
you know
movie that everybody's looking forward
to see so she's not a part of it because
of this negative campaign
how have the depth waldman statements
affected any other films or tv project
promotions for amber
so uh
prior to the defamatory statements but
either around it you know after or
around the time that aquaman won
came out she was in the the tv show
called the stand it was based on a
stephen king novel so big book
you know going to be a big tv show and
again um mr didn't do any press or
promotion for that for the same reasons
and what if any plans were there to have
amber heard on the cover of l.a style
off relating to stan before the deb
waldman statements
right so miss heard was in and uh they
had done an article about her
participation in this tv show the stand
the stephen king novel uh related uh tv
show and they were going to give her the
cover picture and cover story and they
took that away i don't know if they've
even if the article existed but they
certainly took away the cover picture in
the cover story okay how have the depth
worldwide statements affected press
requests for amber
there aren't any
so so yes they affected it because there
used to be a lot of press requests and
now there are aren't any
has ever heard obtained any roles since
the deaf worldwide statement
again
for many years now for a good period of
time a year and a half two years until
she got this small movie called the
indepen uh into the fire okay
has ever obtained any studio movie roles
since the dept waldman statements
no
how if at all have amber's philanthropic
opportunities been affected by debt
waldman statements
again she had some passion projects she
was invited to do some charity work and
she also had her own passion projects
that she you know loved and wanted to be
involved with and even travel for uh but
they decided it wasn't going to be a
good idea because every time she appears
anywhere the social media negativity cam
you know campaign starts up again so she
hasn't been able to do any charity work
what is an endorsement
so an endorsement is when an actor
associates themselves with a product
either for
print promotion or commercials you know
like
jennifer aniston doing the water you
know or
uh matt mcconaughey doing the car
commercial that's a product endorsement
he's paid to say that the product is
good and be associated with the product
how how important are those endorsements
to the actors in the entertainment
industry
well very very important on two levels
one they
bring a good amount of income to them
when they're not shooting a movie so
it's a good way to make money in between
film roles and then also
it shows the studios and the production
executives and the financiers that the
actor is relevant in the community
because they're being associated with a
product so if it's a well-known product
that's really great if it's a medium
product that's great and so forth and so
on so you want to be if you can and if
that's something that you like to do not
everybody does but if they like to do
that then they can get a lot of um value
out of those product endorsements
because then the studio see that there's
a connection with the consumer not just
on the film but also with product
did amber have any endorsement
activities prior to the publication of
the dep waldman statements
yes
please explain
so amber was hired by
l'oreal to be a product and
endorsed their product the makeup line
and she had a 1.5 million contract for
two years
and they were able to
work they had 20 days of her work you
know they had the right to to work with
her for 20 days
and she started the work and then when
the defamatory statements came out they
essentially put a pause on working with
her so they no longer brought her to
photo shoots they no longer had her do
public events for the product and
basically said we love you but we can't
work with you right now because it's
just objection hearsay all right
i'll sustain the objection okay
um
have mister have the deaf woman
statements affected that deal in any way
with l'oreal well a they put it on pause
and haven't done any of the work so
she's not out there in the public eye
related to the product and they uh have
decided to continue working with her at
some point once as i said this all
quiets down this trial is over and
hopefully the negative campaigns will
stop
so they extended her contract but they
did not pay her for that extension
and has ever been hired for any other
endorsement deals since the deb waldman
statements
no
now did you assess amber's losses as a
result of the deb waldman statements
yes what did you do to assess those
well first of all i looked at amber's
career directly so i wanted to see you
know as i said earlier she worked
consistently and then she was on this
kind of
very large upswing with the big movies
justice league and aquaman and and all
of that in the stand with the stephen
king project
um and then it stopped
right so her work
stopped and then i looked at other
actors that kind of grew up at the same
time frame grew up meaning
they started their career and had the
same time frame to start going from the
smaller projects to the well-known
director projects to the big movie
projects and i looked at those actors
and i then saw after they had their
stars for a moment if you will i wanted
to see where their careers went so i
looked at several actors to see
including jason momoa
her co-star to see what happened in
their careers after such a successful
film as aquaman
came out and why did you use that method
of analysis it's a very common
methodology in the entertainment
industry to work with what we call comps
i think miss vazqvist even use that word
comp um for say you you know with films
you try to find comparable films with
actors you look to see comparable actors
so you can kind of it's not a distinct
actual this is going to happen but this
is the probability with a reasonable
certainty that with the right management
team that she had and her acting ability
and her looks and the press that she was
getting and should have continued to get
that her career would have been similar
to these other actors
have you used that method in other cases
in which you've been an expert on
damages yes i have
who did you select as comparable actors
for your comparison
well i wanted to look at actors that
were in superhero films that had done
really well at the box office so i i
looked at jason lamoa her co-star i
looked at gal gadot who was is in wonder
woman
i looked at
um
anna de armas who was in um
[Music]
blade runner thank you blade runner
i looked at zendaya who was in spiderman
and i looked at chris pine who was in
star trek and also wonder woman about
the you know similar age range
all attractive actors all with good
acting skills all able to do stunts so i
was it's not they're not that many
actors to look at who do super hero
characters so it was a small pool to
work from but i took a wide range from
those actors both men and women to see
what was what could potentially happen
to ms hurd's career do you consider all
of them to be identical for purposes of
measurement
well absolutely not i mean no two actors
are identical you can only look with
that within a range of characteristics
and
uh work history management team and so
forth
and we've heard from mr banya
did you review mr banya's q score
analysis regarding the comparables you
used yes i did and what if any opinions
have you formed and reviewing mr banya's
analysis regarding the comparables you
selected so mr banya looked at calendar
years to assess so what happened in
december of you know
2017 or 18 or 19 what happened in june
what happened in a very specific time
frame
which works on some statistical analysis
but when you're talking about actors and
their relationships to q scores q scores
are related to the actors viability in
the consumer's
mind if you will how well known or how
much they're coming up in conversation
and so mr benny did not look at time
periods of the actors that i compare
them with to the film when it came out
so like right after the success of their
big film what was their q score but
moreover he just
looked at them in a year range so
it doesn't coincide from actor to actor
just because you look at it over time
you have to look at it specifically
after each of those
individuals
box office success with a particular
film you look at the q score high or low
during that and then you look at how low
it drops
say a couple months afterwards and then
if it comes back up if they have another
film or another event that brings them
into the
the limelight again so it's not about
time it's a related to a specific
activity or event and he did not do that
okay
what did your comparison show in terms
of films that those actors had been in
since their breakout roles
i'm talking about the comparables
in terms of their
i'm not quite sure i understand um well
what
what happened with these other actors
after they had their
unrelated scores right right okay sorry
so all those actors careers the ones i
mentioned they all either were a steady
rise or even a meteoric rise in in terms
of where their career went after their
stars born moment then they got some
other good films and maybe they got
another film that performed extremely
well so it was a range but they all were
on an upward trajectory without a doubt
and what does this mean for amber
with a reason i mean the way that the
the kind of industry works is usually
unless there is an uh force major or
some really negative event
her career should have followed that
same upward swing and in about the same
time frame it give or take six months to
a year
but you it would be very reasonable to
to believe that her career would have
been on an upward trajectory
within the range
of those other actors what if any
comparisons did you make respecting
endorsement deals of these actors with
amber
you know again all those actors that
we've talked about all did
multiple endorsement deals after their
big movies or after their big series of
movies you know jason mamoa is on you
know rocket mortgage and harley davidson
as well as you know five or six other
companies
zendaya is lancome and fashion and water
and jewelry and gal gadot and chris pine
and and and and
they've all done either a couple or many
and all of them have associated with a
large brand uh unlike amber who hasn't
done even been able to work on the one
contract that she had she certainly
didn't get any others
so what did your analysis show with
respect to amber heard's losses but for
the deb waldman statements
they were significant
if if we follow the trajectory of her
you know colleagues
let's start with at aquaman too
what would she have realized there
well as i stated earlier so um
from aquaman one to two it went from a
million dollars to two million dollars
right so that was a pre-written contract
it doubled so the agents
were very excited after the success of
aquaman to go and negotiate a much
higher
uh fee like they did for jason momoa
they weren't able to do that so in that
instance alone it was more than likely a
two million dollar loss just from that
movie alone
so two to four you'd said before it
could have been for objection leading
sustain okay um what about other films
so once as as amber's agent
mckay
said that once you get that quote of the
2 million from aquaman 2 that kind of
was like the baseline for any other
movie she would have done so any other
studio movie would have started from
there and depending on
the success of aquaman and how much
press she did maybe she worked on
another
great director independent film whatever
that two million dollars for a studio
film
and had it jumped to four million uh
with the renegotiation that then would
have been the basis so any future studio
film
uh
that she would have done any big budget
film would have been the basis at four
million and then most
likely have gone up from there if she
was able to get others which he should
have just like the other actors
let's talk about tv for a minute what
would those losses have included
well on the stand which was you know
about the same time as aquaman but got
the press and the promotion got cut off
because of the defamatory statements of
the negative campaign
she got paid 200 thousand dollars an
episode on the stand so on a tv series
of nine episodes
it's 1.8 million dollars so if she had
again done other tv shows it's very
likely that whether she worked with a
streamer or with one of the networks
that that fee would have gone up from
there her agents would have been able to
use the leverage of the success of
aquaman 2
to put her if she had done another
television show given rise to even a
higher episodic fee some actors go up to
one million dollars an episode jason the
mo is uh in the in his tv show got one
million dollars so there's a you know an
exponential range of where she could
have gone right what about endorsements
same thing you know all the other actors
were doing
over the course of a couple years period
you know anywhere from
five six seven other endorsement deals
and misheard
realistically should have gotten
endorsement deals and other categories
l'oreal is makeup so probably not in
makeup but maybe water or clothing or
jewelry or wellness or it could have
been anything else and so she too should
have
with a reasonable degree of certainty
gotten other contract deals based on the
success of the films that she's been
associated with and the tv shows she's
been and what would that have translated
into in terms of dollars so in terms of
dollars okay so if it was 1.5 million
dollars for l'oreal for a two-year
contract
and let's give her four other 1.5 or 2
million
deals which all those other actors you
know especially the ladies have gotten
then you're looking at an additional
eight million dollars of income over
time i'm not saying this is in one
period we're looking at as far back as
the defamatory statements of 2020 to now
which is almost two years and again as i
said earlier even when this is quiet it
will take three to five years for her to
rehabilitate her career if she can
so we have to look at it as a period of
a minimum of five years so when i say
eight million dollars for endorsement
contracts it would have been over time
okay
uh what if any losses relating to
production or film activities
again
these other actors that we looked at
and there's a wide range of them some of
them did bigger films and some of them
did gigantic films but
it is very reasonable to assume that
once you are in an aquaman style film
you'll either continue to do those right
some of these franchises as we know go
for five six films or she would probably
have been in another studio film that
had nothing to do with aquaman but again
so over the course of five years it's
very reasonable to consider that she
would have been in at least one film a
year
at a minimum of four million dollars
because that's
what her president would have been had
she renegotiated and it's important to
note that in her inner justice league
contract
had their if there is a aquaman
three
her price is set at four million dollars
so it's very reasonable to assume
and to believe
that
if she did a film a year
for five years at a minimum of four
million a year without any negotiation
which probably would have happened but
let's just say that baseline that would
be another 20 million dollars over that
time frame
what if any opinions do you have about
amber herd's earning power over time
that it would continue to rise it's it's
customary in the industry as i've talked
about earlier that the negotiations um
especially with her agents at william
morris her fees would have gone higher
so i'm just using the baseline without
any ability to foresee in the future
that i already know she got negotiated
for four million dollars from aquaman
three so for we used that as a baseline
minimum but it very well would have gone
up had her agents done the work that
they wanted to do
so combining all of these opinions and
calculations that you've had what if any
range are the losses you are estimating
for amber heard but for the deb waldman
statements
right so again it's really important
that that i looked at and hopefully you
understand this that it's over time
right so let's just say a minimum of
five years that we're going to talk
about these losses and it could be more
but at minimum if you look at the
film
the television
and the endorsement contracts
it's very likely that ms heard should
have earned between 45 and 50 million
dollars over that time period
are all your opinions to within a
reasonable degree of probability or
certainty
yes all right thank you very much all
right let's go ahead and take our
afternoon recess ladies and gentlemen do
not do any outside research and do not
discuss this case with anybody
yeah you can step down that's fine i'm
sorry
no that's okay that's all right i
appreciate it ma'am
this reminder court is still in session
please
all right so let's come back at four
o'clock we can do that all right thank
you
how do you like
bye
okay sure while we do that can we have
the witness take this
your sound mixer
excuse me you're a sound mixer yes
all right ready for jury
do i stand
it's up to you
so
so
oh
all right you can be seated all right
cross-examination
good afternoon ms arnold hello how are
you so you've repeatedly testified about
what uh you were asked as the dep
waldman statements
miss you don't have any knowledge
whether mr depp
knew of the statements that mr waldman
made
do you only with association with mr
weldman correct
you don't know when the first time mr
depp learned about those statements
i don't know no
and the association you're talking about
is that mr waldman worked from time to
time as mr depp's attorney correct
action uh your honor may we approach
okay
all right and i understand that you're
uh testifying as a damages expert and
we're two hats
talking both about mr depp's damages and
about
miss hurts purported damages
let's talk about mrs hur miss herds
damages first
you understand
that
you have to testify as to damages that
resulted from the waldman statements
correct
that was my analysis
most of your testimony however was just
simply testimony about things that
occurred after the waldman statements
that's what i was tasked with yes right
the mere fact that
the mere fact that there were activities
after the waldman statements
doesn't establish
that the waldman statements
caused any damages does it
when you look at the time frame of when
the waldman statements came out and you
look at what was going on with mitsuh's
career prior to the statements and what
happened after the statements it's very
clear to make that correlation that they
were caused by those statements and the
campaign that followed afterwards in
terms of the negative social media
all right that's an interesting thing
because the witness this morning uh
actually described the
the uh
the notion of what's correlation and
what's causation
and
correlation does not imply causation
doesn't matter
i'm not an expert in semantics
okay
but you're an expert who is purporting
to say that i misheard lost between 45
and 50 million dollars and i'm trying to
understand
where you
put the link
between the waldman statements
and
all the other activity that occurred
since then
as i stated and very clearly wanted to
make sure that that everybody understood
was that it was a time frame
under you know between which the waldman
statements were made
and the negative decline in her career
started happening and and
in discussions with her agents and her
publicist there was a very tight
timeline and a very close link to when
those statements came out and when
everything started pulling away from his
heart
right but the what you're talking about
is
just
a link in time you do not
put any causal connection between what
mr waldman purportedly said
and the damages that that misheard
purportedly suffered you have no idea
whether mr waldman's statement
uh caused any damage to ms heard do you
well actually
both the words in the statements were
used as hashtags in the campaign as well
as when the statistical and the
investigative analysis was done
on the social media campaign it turned
out that one in four of the statements
were had wald
men or waldminion in them so that was
another connection that i was able to
make between the defamatory statements
and these negative negativity that the
studios and the product endorsements and
the television and the press connected
as well all right let's start with first
principles if they're true they're not
defamatory correct
again that's outside the scope of my
expertise
all right
let's then go back to what you just
testified to and i think you said the
waldman statements appeared in hashtags
i said words from the waldman statements
appeared in hashtags right and the
hashtags that were analyzed however
don't have the waldman statements
in the hashtag
i've also seen them online myself
well but the the analysis that mr
schnell did
he looked at four right
that was shell's analysis and i do
believe i remember reading that yes all
right and the 25 that you just raised
that's mr schnell's analysis you didn't
do that he did it correct all right so
you know what mr schnell did
and he didn't look
at hashtags that contained the waldman
statement words he looked at justice for
johnny depp right
that's one of them yes
one of them
of the 1.2 million hits that we that you
talked about
that was
nine hundred thousand nine hundred and
eighty four thousand
well also in my conversations with mr
schneiderlin we talked about all the
words that were in the statement that
also appeared so what he wrote in his
port and what i had in my conversation
may not have been the same thing ma'am i
don't want to hear about conversation
with mr schnell
it's part of what i relied on and i'm
allowed to talk about that all right so
your conversation
uh with mr schnell let's move beyond
that let's talk about
what the other hashtags were
amber heard is an abuser that's not in
the waldman statement is it
the fact that she was called the hoax
can be related to amber abuser but no
those words were not used correct
and
we don't we just don't like amber that's
not the waldman statement
correct
and amber turd is not in the waldman
statement
correct right none of those things are
and in terms of the use of the words
fraud and hoax
that appeared in only
six and a half percent
of the uh millions
of
of uh tweets that mr schnell analyzed
right
i don't have the definition or is the
report in front of me but we can look at
it together if you'd like to right
and uh and you said waldman appears in
25 percent waldman or waldminion
according to mr show yes all right
but you st
if that's your only evidence however
that any of this activity
has any link
to mr waldman
is that correct
well no we also look at the timeline
because those those campaigns were not
active prior to the weldment statements
and then they started appearing so there
is some
connectivity there as well
mr depp bears no responsibility for for
the social media campaigns he doesn't
if the social media
campaigns caused
ms heard to lose her
ability to
generate income that's not the waldman
statement that's a social media case i'm
gonna object your honor may we approach
okay
all right so i'm i'm just looking for
all evidence
of the causal connection that you claim
exists
between
the 45 million dollars in damages that
you assert
and the three statements made by
made by mr waldman
well you also wanted i also looked at
ms hurd's career
after
the divorce proceedings and other
lawsuits that she was either involved
with or was discussed and her career
might have had a pause but she was able
to overcome that when she did aquaman
and she did the stand both very
prominent productions
and
[Music]
there was no dramatic downturn in her
career after any publicity i don't mean
to interrupt you but do you have notes
with you
no i there's dust oh okay
it's just dust and i'm just
distracting myself but i guess i'm sorry
it's just nervous it's really just that
i just yeah that's okay dust sorry so
you looked at her career but
and you looked at the way her career was
moving
right so as i was saying her career was
moving forward and even she had been
able to overcome the negative publicity
uh surrounding the divorce or the
initial filing of the uk lawsuit and the
other lawsuits anything that she was
associated she overcame that
she did justice league and she did
aquaman and she did the stand and she
got the l'oreal contract all after that
the only time her career slowed down and
stopped was at the same time that those
defamatory statements came out so
but there was a lot of other activity
that happened following the defamatory
statements you said every time mr
depp files a lawsuit it ignites the fire
around the both of them
right no i actually said it it ignites
the fire mostly around mr depp that was
in contact excuse me please i'm sorry
that was in context of when i was asked
about mr depp's career i was not in
context of when i was asked about miss
hurd's career
it's not the same fire
it isn't isn't who's the the protagonist
in the case in the uk was mr depp miss
heard was a witness to that case she was
not a part of the case so most of the
negative press went there was enormous
amounts of negative activity around ms
heard as a result of the uk case isn't
that true
there was negativity yes about it
remember them in the case yes right
substantial amounts of negative right
right
and
so you can't tell me
that that negativity isn't the thing
that keeps your or misheard from working
well again it was a close time frame the
negative statements for a much closer
time frame to the press and publicity
around aquaman and the stand than the uk
case which was months later so again i
will look at the defamatory statements
is kind of the igniting force and it was
promoted and and kind of more oxygen was
uh
put on the fire when the uk's came out
so it kind of became a snowball effect
of you know the match was lit and it
kept getting stronger and stronger right
but but ms heard isn't claiming a causal
connection between the uk case in her
damages right
yeah
all right
and you can't distinguish between
the uk
bad
publicity
and the
bad publicity that derived after the
waldman statements what time frame are
you talking about with the bad publicity
from the uk so we can at least be
specific on time frames well you talked
about a five-year time window
a five-year time window from 2020 to the
two years that we're at now plus the
three years moving forward is what i
talked about in terms of the time frame
that it would take someone who's been
under this much duress to kind of
rehabilitate their career that's when we
talked about the five years right that's
when you talked about the five years so
you look over this five year window
and during the period that precedes this
window there's
lots and lots of negative press about
misheard
irrespective
of the waldman statements correct before
the wellman statements as i said she was
able to overcome that and she got great
jobs and was getting endorsement
contracts
right but after the waldman statements
there is more
activity
in the press there's more social media
activity
and you cannot put a causal connection
between
that activity and what mr waldman said
it can be the instigating event if you
want me to call it that we'll call the
waldman statements the instigating event
of a torrential reign of social media
tactics that went on has gone on for
years yeah
the instigating event
and and therefore
you your damage analysis with a degree
some degree i guess
of reasonable certainty is that once
there's an insta instigating event
um everything that happens thereafter
is fair game for damages
well it's like a fire if one tree burns
and then more air or wind is added to it
then the next three burns and the whole
forest burns but if that first fire
hadn't started with the one tree there
would have been no loss of acreage so
you can look at it with that same
analogy
trees burn one at a time don't they man
know i'm not a firefighter i'm not going
to go there with you but obviously we
know that a single match can cause
thousands of acres to burn so
we can leave it at that
i think i went there with you
all right let's do this
um
you decided
that
there were
a number of
persons that you described as comparable
in order to determine
what your what ms heard
was likely to make over time correct
yes
all right
of those
comparable
actors and actresses
is there a single one who has had
any press
suggesting that they defecated in the
marital bed
i don't know
you would agree with me
that that is a negative
influence
with respect to hollywood
if one believed it yes yeah if one
believed it
you know it was reported
yeah it it certainly has been discussed
we don't have any proof or video of of
anybody defecating on the bed
i i certainly do not have proof or i
mean a video of anybody defecating in a
bed i'll give you that that's a good
thing yeah
um
so but what you
what you know is that mr waldman didn't
say anything about defecating in a bed
correct right so
all of the bad publicity around that
activity
has nothing to do with waldman right
uh waldman as you said didn't talk about
defecation okay
and you haven't considered
how that
story
has
adversely impacted miss heard's career
that story you're going to ask me for a
causational link between that poop story
and her demise of her career i can't no
i'm not going to do that nor can i
you couldn't do it
can i make it no i can't right
and you can't do it with waldman
statements either can you
well again i did and i have and i stand
by them so
you you did by just pointing out the
time frames are relatively close
the time frame and the instigation and
and if you will the rallying of the
forces again
it's like a lit tree it's gonna ignite
everything it's like free game
afterwards so it was the instigating
event if you will it you know and that's
what i looked at yes
all right so
from your perspective
anything that happened after waldman
that was negative to your client
is attributable to waldman and therefore
attributable to the damage analysis you
made i was tasked with looking at that
specifically and that's what i was asked
to limit it to i was not asked to look
at anything else
all right
um
jason mama
that's one of your comparables right
yes
he's
been prominent since 1999.
he was in baywatch in 99
44 episodes on baywatch do you know that
you can look it up if you did i'll i'll
go with that right
but you remember my baywatch
actually didn't watch baywatch but he
certainly had the physique for it so
stargate
atlantis
he was on that
many episodes
right
did you know that
yes okay
he played conan the barbarian
in tv or film film okay
i don't i don't have mr momoa's uh
resume memorized so
no i'm just trying to understand how you
came to the conclusion they're they're
comparable because i i'm just want to
spend a few times a few minutes talking
about mr momoa's career
game of thrones was one of the most
popular things on tv
for a period of three years correct yes
he was and he was in game of thrones yes
he was yep
and
he's aquaman right
yes he is right he's the title character
in aquaman
yes yeah and he was
actually aquaman in a movie before
the aquaman movie started
you mean justice league and other things
like that yeah
batman vs superman
dawn of justice what wasn't he in that
as aquaman i didn't see that one didn't
see it no
miss heard wasn't in that movie was she
not that i know of now no
and he was in both justice league movies
correct yeah
uh
and he's in agreement too
yes
they used him in the second lego movie
right yes
um
he's one of the most heroic characters
in the recent dune blockbuster
which happened post aquaman
right
in fact
likely he's character he's not the lean
though
no
and doom no he's not the lead jeffrey
dune
did you ever read dune i know but i've
seen the movie yeah
do you understand whether his character
will come back from the dead in the
third movie as again i didn't read the
book so he might i don't know we're just
talking about that one movie that might
be a bit of a spoiler
oh man
dude
he's one of the principal leads in the
new fast and furious franchise movie
fast acts right
i i don't know that for sure now okay
uh
but that's not the career path that
that ms heard has had she's never been
the title character in a movie she
hasn't spent
uh years on television she did what
eight tv shows eight
single episodes of tv
again i don't have their resume if you
want to show to me we can count them
together
um
mr mimo
remains
well liked even though he's engaged in a
recent divorce from
another actor
that's correct right
i don't know i don't follow his fan base
you don't follow jason mamoa but you use
him as a comparable to to come up with a
45
i said i don't follow his fan base i i
understand him as a prominent actor in
the business but i don't follow his fan
base
isn't fan base one of the things that
you analyze of course you can look at
numbers but i don't keep a watch on his
social media feeds all right
all right you
indicated that uh
gal gadot is in wonder woman
yes she's a star
she's in fact wonder woman
you know she's good too yep all right
she's the title character
and there's been now multiple wonder
woman movies right
yes yeah and even before that she was in
franchise films
which one are you referring to fast and
furious
oh excuse me i honestly don't don't
remember her being that as one of the
main characters i know it's the rock and
you didn't even know she was in the fast
and furious franchise i've seen it on
her resume but i didn't i again i'm not
a fan of the past and furious
yo
agree with me that wonder woman is a
more prominent role than mira
if you're going to talk about apples
apples in that exact movie yes
what about
does meera have
any
you know self-titled franchise films
not yet no
and miss goodell played a much bigger
role in the movie they were in together
the justice league movie
in what movie they were in together oh
and justice league yeah
i haven't encountered the screen time so
i can't really say
okay
you indicated
that another person that you
compared miss heard with is zendaya
same day yeah
person so famous she goes by one name
i guess when you have a name it's a z it
works i
guess yeah
she's
she's been on the disney channel since
she's 13 years old right right
she's one of them
yes she did right
she
was singing and dancing and swimming
from trapezes in the greatest show right
yes yeah
she's not but in multiple spiderman
movies
yes she's 10 years younger than your
client
hey yeah
but this is a person that you deem to
convert
well as i i was explaining to you how i
chose them when you look at superhero
characters there's not that many to pull
from so i just tried i worked on pulling
characters that were in superhero movies
that were about the same age range
within
10 years as you've
noted to me thank you
and also just where her career would
have gone i said that they were
comparable they're not identical so you
can just
look at what their career has done
either before that superhero movie then
in others or the one they were in and
then you look at where her career should
have gone
even though she may not have been at the
stature of zendaya at that time you can
still look at it as a comparable
trajectory of what happens when you're
in a blockbuster movie it's just a
reference point it's not meant to be
identical they're not meant to be the
same people are not even have the exact
same career it's meant to be a reference
point simple as that
so far everybody we've looked at
have been in more blockbuster movies
than than miss hurt but miss heard was
also in the biggest blockbuster movie
and the light that shines on jason mamoe
will also shine on her so you have to
look at it in context of the biggest
movie that didn't become jesus
and also one of the biggest
box office films ever probably within
the top 10 because i've looked at it
right so that light was going to shine
brighter on her
um than someone who wasn't in that movie
and again it would have just helped her
in her career move forward not stalled
it and be
in her world be silent
afterwards
for the jury to accept your damage
analysis
they would have to agree with you that
ms heard was on the precipice
of a meteoric rise that's the word you
used right actually no i didn't i did
use meteor with someone like let's say
gal gadot or zendaya but i i actually
gave you a range and gave the jury a
range that they weren't all going to
have a meteoric rise some of them would
be smaller right
and so i what the numbers that i gave
you do not represent a meteoric rise a
meteoric rise is when jason mamoa goes
from i don't know 4 million 5 million to
a 50 million dollar payday that's a
that's a meteoric shift in our business
but when someone has contracts that
actually go from one million to the
first one two million and then four
million
that is standard for a franchise that is
perceived to do well and so i based
those calculations on very specific
numbers that were already contracted i
wanted to stay within reality and look
at the numbers that were already
contracted from his heard and just move
out forward on one film a year
maybe a tv show here or there and some
endorsement contracts which was very
typical
for an actor in our business to make
that kind of money it just is what
happens
so
the example you just used is somebody
went from 1 million to 2 million to 4
million
your client has never had a contract
that exceeds two million dollars correct
incorrect
and the aquaman just isn't it's actually
the justice league contract because
they're associated so justice league
aquaman she was paid 1 million
then in aquaman 2 it was written that
she was going to earn two million and if
there's another one it was written in
the terms that she would get four
million so it actually was a contract
that misheard signed with the studio
right but the movie hasn't been made
aquaman 2 hasn't even come out yet so
the third one is still on deck as they
say yeah
um
okay
let's put it differently your client's
never been paid two million dollars for
a movie she she she appeared
she was paid two million dollars for
aquaman two aquaman two and she's never
been paid four million dollars
she was contracted to be paid and when
the movie goes that's what she will be
paid so that's what i said she was
considerable
right but if if aquaman two does even
nearly as well as aquaman one there's
going to most likely be a third one so
we can look at that as a precedent that
was set
in in writing actually
if a movie makes 795
million dollars you think there's likely
to be a next one
um
if it was the first or the second one
but if it's the fifth in the series i
assume that you're referring to pirates
five it performed well at the box office
yes but certainly not in comparison to
some of the other ones and that's what a
studio like disney will look at to say
has that franchise had its run
or do we need it
like disney
wants to walk away from an 800 million
dollar payday
well an 800 million payday has to be put
into context to the budget that it costs
to get that movie and then the marketing
thereafter and with the increasing cost
and not only mr depp's fee or any of the
and plus the other actors fees plus
general production costs that are
getting more expensive then you put in
the marketing costs which are sometimes
one two or three times the budget of the
film a film like that a studio can spend
six eight hundred million just making
and marketing the film so it 795 million
dollars is a lot of money and it seems
like a really good box office but you
have to put into perspective of what's
spent on production marketing and the
overhead costs that the studio takes so
you have again it's all in context
of what the budget of the film and the
marketing of the film is all right let's
put some more things in context honored
armis
that's another one you used yes all
right she's um
most recently i guess in deep water with
ben affleck
i i don't again i know some of the
movies that she's been and i don't
remember about deep water i don't
is that i don't even know if that's out
yet okay
um
she was in the last james bond movie yes
she was yeah they were talking about
making her the next
female bond right right after her big
star of moment star's born moment yeah
she's gotten a lot more um big roles
which is what we have from his herd
yeah um
and she said that her breakout role was
blade runner
it was it was like the first big you
know studio movie that got a lot of
attention i believe that was the one
that we can look at as a as a marker for
her sure
did
did you watch blade runner 2049
i did
do you know what she did in the movie
it was years ago i don't remember
exactly what she was at what what role
she played but she was in that movie and
from that her agents used that as
leverage to get her more movies
you have no knowledge that her principal
role in that movie was it's a gigantic
naked billboard
are you saying that's the only thing she
was she was a gigantic naked billboard
she wasn't that's the principal role in
that movie i i don't i don't remember
the movie well enough to know okay
um
and
did you know that she was we i talked a
little bit about ben affleck right right
uh
he's an interesting example because
it
he's been in a role
that's been recast
multiple times
you know that role
about batman yeah yeah
sure
all right
so
the title character in that dc series
has seen how many actors
several right
michael keaton
he used batman
vel kilmer you're a movie buff yeah
yeah
christian bale was batman
i think he was you're right george
clooney was batman definitely yeah
i guess robert pattinson is now batman
don't know
okay
um
but you're taking an absolutely iconic
role
that the dc universe has recast
four five six times correct
correct so that just because you have
the role in the first movie or the
second movie doesn't mean it you get it
in the third movie or the fourth movie
unless it's contractual
right
unless it's contractual
so
now
let's look oh
anna armas
she's like the new marilyn monroe on
netflix too right
i believe so she was also in knives out
which is probably even a bigger breakout
role for her but again i chose blade
runner because it's a similar thing you
have to start somewhere but knives out
probably was her big moment in time yeah
all right
the other person you picked was chris
pine
uh chris pine is in a superhero movie
wonder woman
he is in wonder woman he's also well
star trek being a blockbuster but not
necessarily superhero right yeah um
he was in both wonder woman movies right
uh yes he plays the love interest to
galata down yeah yeah um
on star trek in in the star trek
franchise
he plays captain kirk
right
i don't remember exact role that he
played i didn't see it in the movie i
just know from his resume to be honest
do you know who captain kirk is
yes i do
well
but you didn't know that chris pine is
is captain kirk in star trek
i hate to say i'm not a star trek fan
okay
but you used mr pine as an example
irrespective of the fact that you didn't
even know he starred
in this franchise film i did know that
he started that's why he used it again
we can go over this a couple more times
and i'm happy to do so all i wanted to
do was look at from a small pool of
people that have been in huge franchise
movies or or superhero movies
and and give you a sense of what the
range is or what summon trajectory can
be again
they are not apples and apples they're
not both green apples they're both red
apples i just was looking at a range
it's what we do it's what we do in the
industry it's it's what you do to kind
of
get a sense of how much you're going to
pay an actor what they're worth in the
foreign markets and the domestic
question was did you know whether he was
in star trek yes and you were asking me
why i chose him is which is what this
conversation is about and again i chose
him because he was part of star trek and
wonder woman but mostly because he was
in wonder woman
and i don't know the exact time frame of
which came first but the fact that he's
in both of them is consistent with what
actors of this ilk tend to do once
they're in a movie like this
but
you you talked about breakout roles but
you don't know which which was his
breakout role
chris pine's been an actor he's been a
well-liked actor he was in both star
trek and in
wonder woman and star
did a movie with denzel washington
he's had a good career yeah great career
yeah yeah much longer career than than
miss hurt right she was on the precipice
of a great career yeah she hasn't had
the chance to negotiate that for that
yet or be in those movies yet so we
don't know yet we're getting back to
precipice didn't you just deny precipice
a few minutes ago i said
i thought your testimony was she was on
the precipice of meteoric rise you said
i guess
i i didn't say meteoric i said
consistent i don't know she could have a
meteoric rise but i was talking about
consistent with miss heard
all right
um
so the co of the actors you selected
two of them are the title characters in
their dc movies
one
one is aquaman who's the other title
character
gal gadot wonder woman right right she's
wonder woman and oh and you mean jason
memo sure yeah
yeah
so you get two title characters
you got
james kirk
and those are the people that you
thought were most representative
of misheard
again
there are not that many in the pool to
pick from i'm not going to put
comparable actors that haven't been in
either large what we call tentpole
movies or franchise movies or superhero
movies so i i wanted to work within
those parameters and that's what i did
so those are the actors i chose yes
and to show what type of work happens
when you're in a big movie and what
happens afterwards when you say
comparable
um
every one of the actors you chose had a
much longer tv career than misheard
again they were all in superhero or or
franchise movies that did very very well
the box office and there are tons of
actors and actresses who are in
superhero movies that don't have meteor
meteoric rises thereafter correct not
when they're the lead character with
jason mamoa but to your point there are
many actors that have no career prior to
a breakout role and then have a meteoric
career and have had no career prior so
you don't always just look at the past
it's helpful and with ms heard she had
good reviews so that's what i looked at
but if you look at other actors and they
have their first role and all of a
sudden they become a superstar
from one role so that happens in our
business it just does
all right
with respect to your
comparable actors
you
have no personal knowledge
as to how much
any of them were compensated
over the period you reviewed incorrect
you have personal knowledge as to who
jason mamawa
and you derive that personal knowledge
from talking to somebody yes he didn't
tell you his agent did okay
so
what you will rely on what mr momoa's
agent told you but you have no no you
didn't see the contract
no his agent is at william morris as
well so they told me that
right and you've never seen anybody
else's contracts as to what they were
making no but in 25 years of being in
this business i understand the basis of
which actors are paid when they're in
blockbuster films and then they're in
large budgeted studio films so
it's it's not a leap to kind of
understand where where the actor's
making and again
i really didn't want to try to be
speculative in my analysis i wanted to
work with the numbers that amber had
contracted for already and just take it
from there and said if she had done one
movie a year
and one series and done product
endorsement that's how it got to the
number so i wasn't looking to take her
on a meteoric rise i wasn't looking to
give her the same career as jace mamoa i
took her numbers that her agents had
actually negotiated and worked from
there
when you say you weren't
trying to give her the same career as
jason mama
the
the tv
program that she most recently did the
stand
she made 200 000 an episode that's what
you testified to correct
and in your damage analysis
you give her a million dollars an
episode had the waldman statements not
occurred and you do it only because you
believe mr mamoa has gotten that in in
in something that he's in right so you
are giving her the same career as jason
malmo well again with someone like
uh
ms hurd who was in a blockbuster film
with the team at william morris in my
discussions with william morris that's
what they were looking to negotiate for
her on other projects so i got some of
that information from her management
team directly
so her agents were looking to get her as
much money as possible
i think that's the job of an agent they
usually try to get the most money as
possible your testimony is they were
looking to get the money for it but
you need somebody willing to pay on the
other side of that deal don't you
right but agents are working with people
in the industry and have a pulse on what
have a finger on a pulse of what's going
on so they know who's marketable and
what the prices that all the streamers
are paying these days
you haven't seen a single one of the
endorsement contracts that you
referenced other than miss hurts no
other than again what i was talking i
was talking to william morris in terms
of the pricing that they are aware of
not only for their own clients but
what's out in the marketplace and it's
pretty consistent and i've also worked
with other actors on other cases that
have gotten similar contracts so i'm
familiar with the rates of endorsement
contracts
you
you haven't made any reference to the
actual earnings of any of these actors
again as you do an analysis you put
together the numbers that you know from
both your experience and the marketplace
and the agents that are working in the
marketplace so together that's how i
created those numbers and mostly using
ms heard's numbers specifically
and giving her a very steady career
which is what she had had prior to
uh aquaman
yeah and you don't have the prior
earnings of any of the actors you looked
at other than miss hurts
i don't have all the contracts now you
don't have any of that information i'm
sorry you don't have any of that
information no
okay
in fact that information
i guess aside from mr mamawa's
is confidential right
usually it is yes yeah
and the only reason you know anything
about mr momoa is that you
misheard shares an agent
right but i look i've also been in the
industry for many years and i know what
actors get paid i talk about budgets
constantly so it's not a
secret within the industry the amount
that actors are in those types of movies
are paid very very well
you're not currently working as an agent
for anyone are you
no
sorry
so
the salaries of these comparable actors
did they form
some basis for your opinion
no
okay
so your opinion as i understand it is
that
ms heard
should have been able
to
renegotiate an existing contract
which is standard in the industry as
well as
with her agent specifically you know if
it's standard with warner brothers i'm
sorry do you know if it's standard with
warner brothers i don't know if it's
standard at any of the studios but it is
standard for agents to renegotiate and
oftentimes are successful when the film
is done so well right but what you're
talking about is there's an existing
contract
where miss hurt has made a promise that
she will do the next movie for in this
instance two million dollars right
right
and
what you the agent is trying to do is to
get warner brothers to say
hey
you should pay her more
than your contract says
because
you like
her well as miss ko
kovacevic said also it's standard in the
industry as again i've been in the
industry i've worked with agents and
i've worked with lots of lawyers and you
know we have conversations about what is
an actor getting or what can they do or
what are they going to do the next time
so again it's a standard practice in the
industry especially when a film is as
successful as aquaman that the agents
will go back and renegotiate uh in fact
that was conversation standard practices
that they would try to renegotiate but
it's up to the studio sure but
oftentimes in a movie such as the nature
of aquaman they're very successful
usually but the entirety of your
analysis
assumes a renegotiation
with a studio for terms that are double
what
the studio had already got a promise
from miss heard she would work for
correct
so
have you
talked
to walter hamada
have i spoken to him no do you know who
he is
yes
who is he he's a senior executive at
warner brothers or yeah i think he still
is there but certainly
at the time of the renegotiation was a
senior executive
then do you know whether he's the
president of dc based film productions i
think that's exactly his title yeah
who's in a better position
to determine whether warren warner
brothers would renegotiate
you or mr hamada as again i based this
on the on the agents that were talking
to warner brothers about mr momoa and
they were wanting to talk to them about
misheard as well
okay so they i based my information on
them so you the the connection should be
mr hamada or the agents not mr mata and
me
all right
who's in a better
uh position to to know whether warner
brothers would renegotiate objectionary
calls for speculation
just asking
i'll sustain the objection next question
do you review any testimony from mr
hamada
i did
did you understand that mr hamada says
that they don't
that they want to hold the lawyers i
mean hold the actors to their deals
that was a philosophy that he said
warner brothers had yes
did you understand that mr hamada said
that nothing mr depp did
impacted her compensation
i don't remember that part of the
testimony do you have it available for
me to read
you don't know whether mr hamada
testified did anything mr dip mr depp
said about amber heard affect her
compensation
again i don't i don't remember i don't i
don't recall that right now
do you know whether mr hamada indicated
whether he even knew who adam waldman
was
again i i don't remember the
conversation about hamada and waldman or
deb
and you don't remember whether mr hamada
made any statements as to whether
anything mr waldman said affected miss
hurt's compensation
in my experience studios don't talk
about what how or why they make
decisions based on publicity or
conversations they're not going to try
they're going to be very protective of
all the relationships so that's just
natural
yeah unless you can get them to testify
under oath at a deposition right
well even so they're not going to say
anything negative they may bypass it by
being positive but they're not going to
do anything that could potentially
damage a relationship that may change or
be worthwhile in the future so that's
just what a studio person does
it mr hamad is in the best position to
determine whether there were chemistry
issues with misheard objection you're on
calls for speculation he's the president
of the company
overrule
i don't know how involved mr hermata was
on a daily basis in in terms of
chemistry but i do know that warner
brothers did a chemistry test with uh
miss heard and mr mama before they even
she even got the role she went in and
did what they call a chemistry test so
that was to actually see whether there
was good chemistry between them and
evidently there was good chemistry
because she was then hired to be the
romantic interest so
whatever mr hamada said during his
deposition i look at what actually
happened in real life which is she got
the chemistry test and then she got the
job
yeah let's look what happened in real
life
she went in before and took the test
then she made a movie
there was an existing movie under which
warner brothers they could then decide
whether there was chemistry right
the movie worked it made over a billion
dollars and they're all over the poster
if they didn't think that there was
chemistry they wouldn't have put miss
hurt on the poster
next to mr momoa so
you know there were multiple posters for
the aquaman movie yes there always are
that's that's that's standard and that
three out of the four posters the
standard posters for aquaman
didn't even feature misheard right so
when you when you make a poster at the
studio it's normal to have three or four
variations because you want to appeal
the different
people's perspective so you want the
romantic poster you want the action
poster you want the superhero poster so
it's normal for them to have many
posters but the romantic poster was of
misheard and mr memoa right and everyone
and all the others are just of mr momoa
like we talked about it's aquaman but
she was prominent in the ones that she
was that warner brothers wanted to
appeal to women and to the romanticist
of the consumer
what
movies
would ms heard have gotten
absent mr waldman's statements
well the ones we know about specifically
that she was in conversations with was a
movie with um
gail garcelle bernal i believe that's
how you say his name at uh amazon which
is what miss kavachu said and she was
also in consideration for a movie called
ambulance with michael bay um but again
after the waldman statements nobody
would talk to the agents and so they
weren't able to garner more oh she also
had a movie that she was interested in
producing that a good friend of hers
or a friend of hers or colleague was was
doing so um there was at least those
three
um
those were three movies that she was
being considered for but you don't know
what movie she would she was going to be
in
well again they stopped the conversation
after the statement so we don't know
where they would have gone of course but
they she was in consideration for all of
them
that would have helped all those movies
so it would have
made a lot of sense you're projecting
movies way out into the future that you
have no knowledge would ever have gotten
made well that's what we do when you
talk about comparables and and economic
damages you talk about the future that's
standard in our industry as as a
forensic expert and in the industry
that's how movies are financed as a
matter of fact is by forecasting what
happens in the future
what
connection do you draw
between
mr waldman's statements
and
the
reported reduction in ms heard's aquaman
ii role
again it's just it's
the timing of it all was the timing and
also they were going to take her out of
the movie after the statements and they
put her back in and then
there i
can i talk about the emails that i read
i'm not sure at this point but
so
when you say they're going to take her
out of the movie
when you have an option
you literally have the option whether to
include
the actress right that's that's what it
means
correct right so they can choose to
exercise the option or not exercise the
option entirely up to them
correct and they have
that particular studio
to your knowledge has re repeatedly
recast even major
figures
in their dc movies
we talked about batman what about
superman
you know i'm not i i think i'm more
familiar with the batman actors i think
there have been a couple actors of
superman but depending on how the movie
performed if a movie doesn't perform
they'll look for other actors or if they
want to go a different direction or
reboot a franchise they will look at
different actors so
they're very successful they're not
likely to change the actors especially
not in the second one or the third one
another reason they'll look for a
different actor or actress if the actor
or actress is
asking too much money to play the role
again correct
uh yes not not in figures under 10
million dollars but yes
if you're asking for too much money you
might not get your role again
and
your analysis assumes
that ms heard could double her money
well her contracts doubled her money
from each one to the next so it wasn't
that large a leap to do that especially
when the agents had told me that that
was what had been they were considering
and what they've been discussing
yeah
you seen the script of aquaman 2
personally yeah
uh i did see a draft i don't know what
the date was or when it was or where in
the succession of the rewrites it was i
did see one draft yes you don't know
what
warner brothers has in mind for that
movie in terms of
the kind of movie it's going to be
it's a superhero movie right um
it's supposed to be like a buddy comedy
right
i i i don't know i don't know about a
buddy comedy it's an action movie
superhero movie who's patrick wilson
patrick wilson
i i've heard that name in terms of an
actor but i don't know mr wilson
do you know if he appears
in aquaman
again i don't i don't know him by name
if you want to show me a picture i can a
clip from the movie
do you know if mr wilson appears more
frequently in aquaman than than your
client does
i don't i didn't count the screen time
when i watched the movie it was a long
you know even when i watched it again i
didn't count the screen time of anybody
else
you did you read the testimony of mr
hamada
we discussed that yes
you disregarded all of it in your
analysis as to
her ability to renegotiate correct
well i remember the part where mr hamada
said that from time to time they will
break their philosophy and renegotiate
it's what they did with jason momoa and
with gal gadot so
you know
it's it that just goes it coincides with
what we know in the industry which is it
can be done it's what they did with the
two title characters
in
the dc universe again i've worked in the
business for a long time and i've seen a
lot of actors
uh renegotiate their careers it's i'm
sorry not their careers renegotiate
their uh
their fees it's it's common
practice and it's certainly what the
agent will think about first when a
movie makes a billion plus dollars right
again
focused on the agent but it's the
studio that
pays the bills yes right
all right
the honor i have a fair amount more to
do is
continue
i'm sorry continue okay i didn't know if
we're going to 5 30 today or not
every day is 5 30 today
okay
we may not even need to get there every
day is 5 30. perfect
all right
you talked about
ms herb's endorsement deal with l'oreal
yes
and that
l'oreal has concerns about using her
because every time they try to use her
people respond negatively to her
people don't the the debt fan base has
responded uh has been as
true uh
have posted negative things about his
heard
on their campaigns
so
did you say the depth fan base
well people that were using the hashtags
that were consistent with the rest of
the the depth fan base yeah but there
are people posting negative things that
other than things that came from mr
waldman correct
i haven't seen all the i haven't seen
all them that was i was just looking at
what l'oreal what l'oreal discussed and
what l'oreal said in in
their communications
they made
do you see l'oreal make a word cloud of
the words that were most uh commonly
associated with with misheard in its uh
marketing campaigns i knew they did that
i didn't see it myself actually
do you know what words there were
again now
you didn't talk much about this but in
order to get to the damage analysis that
you got
the 45 million dollars i think at least
in
initially you suggested that ms heard
would have a role
producing and starring in a movie
and that she would make 12 million
dollars
i i've talked about that but in the in
the latest calculation that was really
less what i considered and more about
what films and tv and endorsement deals
that which she would do the producing
was something that she had wanted to do
and again mr mamoa got that so that's
where the agents were discussing those
figures with me
the last movie that she has a production
credit for is in 2013 right
again i don't i haven't memorized
tourism there's a movie called syrup
do you ever hear of it
no
aside from having probably seen it on
her imdb
and soon the darkness that's her other
production credit right
i'll
if you say so if you're reading it off
of a resume i will believe you yes
2010
okay
12 years ago
but you at least at some portion of the
at some point in this
analysis
were of the mind that
she would
recover 12 million dollars
with a producing
role and a starring role in a movie
because that's what mr momoa got again
the agents were just saying that those
were the kinds of numbers they were
looking at to help her as she moved
forward in her producing career right
those are the kind of the numbers the
agents would like her to get right but
again i didn't use that in the final
analysis of my 45 million so
it was just a discussion point because
that's what the agents wanted me to
consider
all right
all right you
have testified that the breakout role
for miss heard
was aquaman right
i i didn't say the breakout role but i
used it as this you know a movie that it
was a superhero kind of super box office
success um i think that you know some of
her other critically acclaimed movies
probably helped her break into that role
which would have been the danish girl
and then her work in justice league
which was a natural progression to
getting to star in aquaman
all right
but
i used breakout perhaps you didn't but
this is the movie that springboards her
to the kind of money that you are
suggesting she should earn it should
have yes
and
either i mean
other than aquaman
which was released in 2018
how many
movies has she booked
well she booked
aquaman 2
and she did the stand which was a
significant television show
right
but
outside of the aquaman franchise she
obtained only one role
movie role
since 2018 right
right the industry also knows that she's
planned to be on that next move and they
understand her production schedule so
she's not going to go after films that
would conflict with a mega box office
movie so there's scheduling and conflict
issues as well that her she and her team
would consider
so from
when was aquaman released in 2018
it's december i it was either december
2018 and then it depends on where it was
in the world it was started in december
2018 and then it it moved out you know
into 2018.
how many months between december 2018
and the waldman statements went by
oh uh
12 i think 15 or 16 if my mouth is
correct
she got one role during that
that 15 or 16 month period
during the entirety of the post aquaman
boost
right
she got stand
and then she was in discussions for the
films as they were getting ready to go
but she didn't get another role
for 16 months
between the release of aquaman
and
what you say are the waldman statements
well she got the stand right she got one
tv role
a pretty significant tv role yes for a
stephen king novel
she was in a movie though
she was in a movie that was released
after aquaman
what movie are you referring to gully oh
well i don't know when that was shot so
you'd have to tell me when it was shot
movies get released at different time
frames like they can be shot in 2016 and
not get released till 2018. so you'd
have to tell me we'd have to look at you
know the actual filming dates of the
goalie didn't to for me to talk to you
about that she wasn't initially casting
gully was she
i i'm not familiar with the casting
process of gully
um
do you know who else eve is
who alice eve
alice eve
sounds familiar but i'm not i'm not
recalling who she she is she's an
actress been in
any number of movies you don't know who
she is
again i know her name but i i don't know
her resume she's in star trek
great right
um
she was in one of those breakout roles
star trek
but you don't you don't even know who
she is
i i talked to you about star trek before
i'm not a big star trucking
okay
miss hurd replaced alice eve in the
movie gullit right
i don't know the passing process i don't
know who's starting that movie do you
know what she was paid
who misheard
uh for gully yeah can you tell me when
that was in no no i don't but what was
the filming date of and what was the
start date of gully
do you you didn't look at the gully
contract when you were making an
analysis of
ms hurt's damages
i don't recall whether i looked at it or
not
did you understand that she was making
2190
per week for gully can you tell me when
it was shot
when does that contract get negotiated
it's relevant
the contract is negotiated prior to the
release of aqua
okay
so she signs this contract
for 21.90
is there a
do you know what
the screen actors guild low budget
agreement minimum scale is it changes
from year to year it depends on what
year and what the size of the budget
there's actually three or four different
scale num you know benchmarks so when
there's a low budget it can be a micro
budget it can be a minimum budget low
budget there's there's like four or five
different scales that they use when it
gets to anything other than a studio
film
and oftentimes actors do passion
projects and that has nothing to do with
or something that they really love to do
or they think that would be good for the
career it doesn't have anything to do
with the the fee made on the on the film
all right
what's a loan out
a loan out a loan out is the corporation
that a an actor will use so that their
money comes in through a corporation and
then that corporation technically loans
out the actor services
uh to the production so they the low net
is the corporation that the actor uses
and then they loan out the services to
the you know production company it's
just a really for tax purposes
do you know of any movie
that ms heard
booked
immediately prior
to
aquaman
other than gully
well i know she did justice league um i
i don't remember the dates and times of
the filming of the other ones
you always have to look at the filming
dates
um
you talked about mr schnell
gully was in his
chart right
i don't i don't remember where goalie
was right
did you look closely at his chart
did you look closely at his chart
at mr schnell's chart yeah
um
i looked at the numbers with respect to
the social media campaigns is what i was
looking at mr schnell for
okay
do you know whether any of the dates of
the waldman statements even appear in mr
schnell's chart
i i don't remember
okay
you talked a little bit about
q scores
and mr bonya do you remember that
yes
for miss heard mr bonya use q scores
from immediately after awkward right
again if you want to show me something i
can i can answer it i don't remember
every word of mr barney's but i remember
talking about the dates with you earlier
all right but do you you don't know as
you sit here today whether the q scores
that mr banya used
were but were after aquaman but before
the waldman statements he used a couple
different scores based on dates he
didn't i don't remember if they were uh
correlated to the statements or not i
remember
years more than anything else again i
looked at thousands and thousands of
pages of documents so i don't remember
exactly what his said even before
the
waldman statements misheard had very
high negative q scores isn't that
correct
very negative high q scores no very high
negative communications i said very high
negative case scores
um
we i remember discussions of a lot of q
scores i i don't remember exactly what
what or when which score or whether it
was net so in your analysis you didn't
consider
ms heard's
negative q scores
as
a restraint on what she might earn
on a going forward basis
no q scores change all the time ms
herzegue's misuse miss heard's imdb
score has been one
and it's been 300 mr depp's q score has
been won and it's been
you know q scores change all the time
scores change all the time they're based
on current events and movie releases
you talked a little bit about
mr depp's damages
um
did you talk who's jerry brockheimer
who's jerry bruckheimer the producer of
the pirates franchise well he's a huge
producer of a lot of movies but he
happens to be the producer of the
pirates franchise you didn't talk to him
prior to your testimony personally no no
and you didn't
you didn't have other people talk to him
on your behalf did you
i i
me personally no i did not talk to mr
buckhamer and you've never spoken with
mr bruckheimer about why mr depp has not
appeared in a six pirate movie
there has been no six pirate movie there
is not a pirates movie titled pirate six
yet
wherever but you haven't talked to mr
bruckheimer as to whether mr
depp was going to appear in the movie
mr from things that i've read in uh
newspaper publications and emails i've
read that mr brookheimer was uncertain
whether mr depp was star in
right but you haven't talked to him
and you've never spoken with sean bailey
about this right
no
or anyone at disney
i actually spoke i actually put a call
into something to disney and they didn't
want to talk on the record
you called somebody at disney and they
didn't want they didn't want to talk to
you no again as i said studios don't
want to talk about their stars whether
they want to preserve a relationship
that may or may not be used in the
future so it's it's their tendency not
to talk
about people they are in business with
so you have no personal knowledge why mr
depp
hasn't made a six pirate movie
well as i said there is no six pirate
movie right
but you don't know why you have no
personal knowledge why
i don't work at disney now okay
did you listen to mr whitman wiggum's
testimony in this trial
i read mr wiggum's testimony
and mr william said mr depp had a deal
for the movie right
i i've i think mr wiggum did the other
agent uh mr carino said he did not and
as there is no
uh as there is no pirates movie there
have been no deals negotiated and that's
what miss jacobs also testified to
but mr wiggum testified to something
else
it doesn't it doesn't
correlate as we say to the other two
agents testimony
you've indicated that a portion of the
reason
that
mr depp
has get has received a negative
has received a variety
of negative
comments in hollywood
is that
he
engages in losses
one of the one of the
elements that has contributed to
a lot of negative
press and attention is due to the
lawsuits and the activity and the
behaviors that we talked about earlier
have been brought into the limelight
mr depp's lawsuit here
has generated negative publicity
for ms hurt correct
yes
that lawsuit
until she's filed a counter claim
didn't relate to the wallman statements
did it
mr depp's lawsuits yeah
no
we talked about that it was pertaining
to the uh her op-ed piece
it related to what
ms heard said
i'm sorry
this
mr depp's lawsuit relates to what ms
heard said and and not to what mr
waldman said
that would well it related to the op-ed
piece that ms heard wrote
right
so mr waldman's statements
have no connection
to the negative
publicity
that ms heard
has
received relative to this trial correct
objection culture speculation foundation
hearsay and outside the scope
any response
we're looking for a causal connection
here sustain the objection next question
when was the last time
you met with miss heard
i only met miss hurt at lunch today
okay that's the first time you talked to
her first time i met her okay
um
what's your compensation for testifying
here today
uh for a testimony at 650 an hour
what has been your compensation to date
for providing
the assistance that you have in this
case
i've been working on the case for about
three years
and
over the three years i believe it's
around sixty thousand dollars
you said sixty yeah over three years all
right
i have no further questions all right
redirect
i think your honor and i'm going to make
it
definitely fit within that 5 30.
ms arnold you were asked a number of
questions about the different social
media the negative uh
and how do you know that it relates to
the waldman deb statements do you recall
all those questions yes okay
the
the social media that was connected and
some of that was your testimony some
jessica kova vachovich and some of it
was mr schnell
actually tracked the language from the
three statements from weldman correct
objection leading
sustained okay
what if any
uh
efforts were made to track the negative
social media that caused the damages
that you've attributed objection
leading overall
so l'oreal did a lot of research um
william morris did a lot of research mr
schnell did a lot of research and in
those conversations those were also
connective tissues to the
negative social media campaign and the
welding statements all right and they
connected back to those three statements
yes objection leading and what if any
connection did they have to those three
statements
again they we talked about this earlier
we talked about some of the hashtags
being similar we talked about the wald
waldman or the waldminion so there were
a lot of connective tissues between
the
negative social committee the social
media campaigns
and the weldment statements
okay and i'm gonna jump because i think
this is part of this so you were asked
some questions about mr hamada do you
recall that
yes and asked whether he testified that
um
whether anything mr depp said or
anything mr waldman said had anything to
do with
their initial decision not to exercise
the option to aquaman too do you recall
that testimony for that question those
questions yes okay now
the testimony from mr schnell
tracked the 1.2 million
um
tracers to january 2021 correct
objection leading
do you remember what month that was
until right so when mr schnell did his
analysis it was from april of 2020 to
january 2021 and when did warner
brothers tell amber heard and her agents
they were not exercising her aquaman ii
contract it was in february of 2021 all
right and what if anything did mr hamada
say about whether the reason they did
that was because of the 1.2 million
negative social media tweets and
instagrams and and other communications
objection no foundation had any impact
sustained
right next question
are you aware of whether he said
anything about that
i recall in the warner brothers
objection hearsay
do you know
whether that had any impact
objection
hearsay i'm asking now she's allowed to
rely on hearsay
sustain the objection next question
all right you were asked a whole lot of
questions about the different
comparables um and so i'm just going to
go to this
again of all the different movies of all
of those comparables
which movie was the highest grossing of
all of them
again i believe it's aquaman i mean
everybody talks about aquaman being
one of the highest if not the highest
grossing films certainly the highest dc
comic film or in that superhero world
but again i don't want to say it was the
highest but i think it was very close to
it
do you know whether walter hamada admits
it was the highest grossing uh dc film
yes he said that yes okay so
when you're looking at all the
comparables what if any relevance is
there to
the degree of success of that dc
superhero movie injection foundation
she can speak to that your honor that's
the foundation
do you know
the answer to that question do you know
i'm sorry can you repeat the question i
forgot it no i have to
okay so let's go backwards um so
what if do you know whether it makes a
difference
whether how successful that dc superhero
movie is in
uh what types of films they'll be able
to get in the future
objection foundation
i'm asking the foundation
if you want to ask the foundation go
ahead i'm sorry that's what i thought i
was asking do you know whether that
plays any role the degree of success
customarily when it comes to objection
foundation ask your house you know how
do you know
in 20 25 years of being in the film
industry it's customary for when a movie
does such an extraordinary amount at the
box office it shines a very bright light
on the actors especially if they're in
lead roles and it's customary that they
will get a customer it is uh
standard but it it it is very frequent
that a star in a movie that has
performed so well at the box office and
with a
role model character that mira was that
she would have gotten
uh
other roles and worked quite a bit
afterwards and that movie would have
helped her career i mean that's that's
no question
and with all these comparables uh when
you uh gave the range to this jury of 45
to 50 million in estimating this over
this period of time did you put amber
herds estimated damages ranges above all
those other comparables
no again i was very specific and using
the actual
negotiated rates that mr hurt's agents
were able to get for her in that
contract and use that as a precedent so
again i always wanted to be grounded
in what mishard actually
was in contract for and what her agents
negotiated and i used that as the
baseline for the financial numbers of
her loss i used the comparable actors to
show how consistently they all worked
and how their careers moved forward
after being in a box office
you asked about disney and the pirate
six again
what if any knowledge do you have of
whether disney is willing to pay mr deb
300 million dollars and a million
alpacas objection no foundation
i'm asking her what if anything does she
know about whether disney is if you can
lay a foundation okay
did you did you listen to or did you
read the disney testimony
in this case i did yes all right
what do you recall disney saying about
whether they were willing to pay mr depp
300 million dollars and give him a
million alpacas they would not be
willing to pay 300 million dollars and
give him alpacas thank you
you were asked about
the
defecation
what if any recollection recollection of
knowledge do you have
about whether
that social media negative campaign that
you've testified had the words
defecation in it or poop
objection no foundation
i know that the word poop and hashtag
poop is used okay was that in the
movement
sustain the objection to strike next
question okay um
in your review of the social media
campaigns and the negative social media
campaigns that you testified to with
this jury that include the l'oreal that
include the wme that include mr schnell
and we include what you've done
what if any recollection do you have of
how many of those that are influencing
your connections to the defamation
statements include the words poop or
defecation
objection compound
overrule
i don't believe poop was one of the
hashtags that was connected to the
statement okay thank you
you were asked about the time period
between the
defamatory state
between the release of aquaman 2
uh in december 2018
aquaman thank you and the defamatory
start statements that were in april 2020
and june 2020 do you recall that
testimony
i remember that questioning yes okay um
during that time
were you aware of whether aquaman two
was in discussions with amber heard
about scheduling the filming of aquaman
two
in the period between
the statements and
before i'm going before okay i'm talking
about the period of time when they
released aquaman one okay and
the april eight first of the defamatory
statements right do you know whether
aquaman whether warner brothers was in
discussions already with amber heard
about scheduling her for aquaman too
objection hearsay do you know i'm asking
her whether you know if
i'll sustain this to hear say okay
do you have knowledge of whether aquaman
was in discussions with amber during
that period objection hearsay
i i don't know how to i i'm asking ask
your foundation right right um
i um how would you know
uh
well amber received an early draft of
the script amber's agents were in
discussion objection hearsay i i think
she can say sustained okay
um what is in your experience based on
getting scripts what does that mean
i'm asking for experience
in my experience with the movie as high
profile as something like aquaman they
keep the scripts very tight you know
they don't let anybody read them they're
numbered they have your name on it so if
you're getting a script for a movie such
as aquaman that's kept tightly tightly
close to the best if you will by the
studio you are going to
they can they want you to be in the
movie otherwise they would never give
you the script okay
and so if a script was given to amber
heard before in the first april 8 2020
defamatory statement
what would that suggest
based on your knowledge that you've just
testified to objection speculation it's
not speculation
again if she got the script they were
going to use her in the movie that was
their plan okay
i have no further questions thank you
all right thank you is this witness
subject to recall
uh yes your honor all right so you're
still an expert so you can have a seat
okay courtroom i'm still thinking okay
thank you thank you
all right ladies and just come to the
end of our day all right so please do
not do any outside research tonight and
uh don't talk with anybody about the
case okay and we'll see in the morning
bright and early at nine o'clock right
okay thank you
so
all right
just a few planning notes okay um
after testimony tomorrow and we've
excused the jury we'll go ahead and have
the properties that you requested mr
rottenborn we'll do this tomorrow after
said okay does that sound good all right
we'll do those
right after like right now tomorrow
okay that should give you
with all the profits that you need to do
for the record okay
all right and then whenever all the
testimony is done possibly at this point
it'll be thursday afternoon after the
jury is excused i will go over the
remaining jury instructions i have three
under advisement we'll take up those
and we'll also if there's any other from
the evidence this week that we need to
talk about we can discuss those as well
after the jury's gone on thursday
evening or if earlier if the evidence is
done before then okay and just as times
up to this minute
the plaintiff is used 45 hours and 24
minutes
the defendant has used
57 hours and six minutes which means the
plaintiff has left 15 hours and five and
51 minutes and the defendant has four
hours and nine minutes left okay so
that's where we're at
all right anything else for this evening
your honor the last witness that appears
that
is on the plains witness list it's mr
depp and i was just hoping we would get
an answer as to why
defendants await this list i don't know
changing
witness i mean i'm not sure
okay
make a decision in the morning okay all
right everybody have a good evening all
right thank you
you